Seit Jahren ist uns die Freak Show als Quell aktueller Informationen und unterhaltsamer Diskussionen bekannt. Aber was sich die Mannschaft in der Episode 172 ausgedacht hat, erhebt den Podcast zum Kunstobjekt. So erhielten die ersten Downloader unbemerkt eine ganz besondere Ausgabe. In dieser wurden die einzelnen Audiospuren nach einer Spielzeit von etwa vier Stunden. Kein Wort im Podcast für diese Audiokunstinstallation. So entfaltet sie auf jeden Hörer ihre ganz eigene Wirkung.
Die Christo, das Loch ins A.
Wodurch ist sozusagen dieses Ausstanzen......einer erneuerlichen History. Die Newsfighter ist auf jeden Fall tatsächlich vor Freehand Release.
Das ist eben der......desiree.
Ist es ein Sinnbild für die Gleichzeitigkeit von Themen in unserem Alltag, dafür, dass nicht ein Thema zu Ende gebracht werden kann, bevor das neue schon auf der Tagesordnung ist? Hören wir hier, dass uns Antworten auf die großen Fragen unserer Zeit fehlen? Ist das ein Gleichnis dafür, dass wir verlernt haben, einen dazu zu hören? Oder dafür, dass jeder nur noch in seiner eigenen Filterblase lebt?
Naja, die Frage ist halt, wenn sich das herausstellt, dass das eine gute Idee ist, dann können sämtliche Konkurrenten wahrscheinlich relativ wenig Aufwand des Nachbohren.
Diese Installation wirft mehr Fragen auf, als dass sie Erkenntnisse gibt und ist mittlerweile aus diesem Internet schon wieder gänzlich verschwunden. Sie lässt uns zurück fragend, diskutierend, nachdenklich.
Was soll man jetzt noch sagen?
Ein Zehnapplaus für David, soll man jetzt sagen.
Ja, ein Zehnapplaus für David. Auch wenn es mich sehr an die 100 Meisterwerke der Galerie Stenkelfeld erinnert hat.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Da werden wir dann irgendwann mal eingereiht werden.
In 500 Jahren, wenn sozusagen in der modernen Digital- Archäologie, sie sich dann endlich ein bisschen die Frühzeit des Internets vorgekämpft haben, weil ja dann irgendwann mal in dem großen Digital-Unfall von 2150 alle Aufzeichnungen von archive.org abhanden gekommen sind. Ja und das war eine dramatische Phase, also Menschheit war gerade dabei, sich sozusagen das dritte Mal genetisch komplett neu zu erfinden und dabei ist halt auch ein bisschen was schief gegangen und auf einmal fehlte der Bezug, auf einmal hatte man sozusagen so eine Art genetische Amnesie und um sich sozusagen seiner Herkunft wieder zu besinnen, musste man halt auf die Archive zurückgreifen und halt festgestellt, oh scheiße, die funktionieren ja gar nicht.
Die Geschichte erinnert mich an Bäume und Lotum.
Das ist diese bekloppte Bäckerei, die so furchtbar schlecht ist.
Genau, die jeden Bezug dazu verloren hat, wie Brot eigentlich zu schmecken hat.
Das ist wirklich geil, oder? Und die werben auch noch mit, wir sind bio und was nicht alles. Jeden Bezug dazu verloren, wie Brot eigentlich... Das ist wirklich wahr. Was ist bitte mit diesem... Was ist mit diesem... Gibt's den eigentlich nur in Berlin? Reden wir jetzt über Berlin?
Keine Ahnung, aber es gibt den in Berlin auf jeden Fall mehrfach. Wir können ja mal auf der Webseite schauen. Das Geile war, ich war Sonntag, wollte ich eine Milch kaufen und Bäume und Lotum hatte halt diese gläsen Molkerei Biomilch, die ich ganz gerne mag. Ich gehe so rein und stelle die Milch auf den Tresen und dann sagt die Frau, darf es denn noch was sein? Und ich so, guckst du aufs Curry, egal ob ich noch ein paar Eier haben will oder so. Und dann meint sie, na ja, sie sind ja in einer Bäckerei, also hier ist ja alles voller Backwaren und wollt jetzt irgendwie... Und ich guck sie so an und meinte, tja, was soll ich sagen? Und hätte sie noch eine Frage hinterher geschoben, hätte ich ihr auch gesagt, dass ihr verdammtes Stück Teig, was sie Croissant nennt, einfach überhaupt nicht im Entferntesten irgendwas mit Croissant zu tun hat. Oder ihr Brot, wo man eine Scheibe abschneidet und die Scheibe Brot beim Beschmieren auseinander bröselt. Das ist wirklich, das ist eine Katastrophe. Also, ja, und es gibt ja andere Bio-Bäckereien, die ein normales Brot machen. Das ist ja auch nicht so, dass es das nicht geben würde.
Das ist die Horst-Schlemmer-Partei unter den Probe-Alten.
Meine These ist wirklich, dass die so in ihrem, und jetzt sage ich es ein bisschen dispektierlich, ich mag Bio auch und so weiter, aber manchmal hat man ja dieses Körnerfresser, das riecht so und irgendwie komisch. Und das ist halt irgendwie so das sinnbildliche Ding, dass das alles so Bio sein muss und Dinkel hier und Dinkel da und irgendwie zehn Jahre lang kein richtiges Brot mehr gegessen und überhaupt total vergessen, wie das eigentlich zu schmecken hat. Also für mich ist ein Rätsel, warum Leute das auch...
Ja, leider bin ich umgeben mit Wäumer und Lotum, die haben sich hier überall festgesetzt. Und ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, wie die sich überhaupt wirtschaftlich halten können.
Sind die so schlecht geworden in letzter Zeit?
Nein, ich war auch schockiert. Also ich dachte so, naja, hier neue Bäckerei, weil die haben natürlich dann hier massenhaft alte Bäckereien verdrängt. Und ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, was ich da alles gekauft habe, aber ich war einfach auch so, ist das euer Ernst?
Es gibt relativ viele Dinge, die nicht so ganz so toll sind.
Ja, ich meine, es gibt Bäckereien, okay, da ist jetzt mal die eine Sorte Brot nicht so dein Ding, oder was weiß ich, Weißbrot hast du anders kennengelernt, oder man hätte ja auch, was weiß ich, ein bisschen weniger von dem Roggen oder irgendwie so. Aber bei dem Bäumer und Luthum, da ist irgendwie alles im Eimer. Keine Ahnung, also wahrscheinlich ist das so ein bisschen gelaufen wie mit der Aufnahme der letzten Sendung. Das Rezept ist da irgendwie einfach so, da sind so die Trecks durcheinander gekommen und am Ende wusste auch einfach keine mehr, wie das geht, weil es sind ja auch alles keine Bäcker mehr, das sind ja einfach alles nur noch Backwaren-Produktverkäufer.
Na ja, also sie haben ja eine Backstube. Nee, die backen schon, die backen zentral. Aber genau, und sie berühren halt den Teig nicht selber an und so weiter. Es gibt bei mir ja 200 Meter weiter gibt es so Luna, die haben einen großen richtigen Steinofen im Laden, die kneten und backen alles selber, das schmeckt Brot. Also wenn das frisch aus dem Ofen kommt, willst du dir direkt ein Stück Butter kaufen, das auf das ganze Brot schmieren und einfach den ganzen Leib am Stück verschlingen. Ja, es ist nicht weit weg und es geht.
Ja, aber deswegen frage ich mich halt, was ist kaputt mit diesen Menschen, die da die Qualitätssicherung oder Produktplanung machen? Also nach welchen Kriterien entscheiden die?
Das ist jetzt wirklich ein Bio-Bäcker, der macht halt viel.
Es gibt Bio-Bäcker, die wirklich auch lecker Brot machen und die haben keine Kette und haben irgendwie so anscheinend so eine hohe Puppe.
Geh da mal hin, kauf so ein Produkt.
Also ich finde zum Beispiel das Dinkel-Rosmarin-Mohn-Brot relativ geil.
Das Dinkel-Rosmarin-Mohn-Brot.
Ne, Lauge-Rosmarin-Mohn.
Das Claim, Roddy hat gerade eine Pizza-Shop-Sui oder sowas gegessen.
Das ist so wie bei Starbucks, wo du wirklich noch zehn Fragen beantworten musst. Du willst einfach nur einen Scheiß-Kaffee, aber du wirst erstmal, soll da Kakao drüber gestreut werden oder soll irgendwas anderes drüber gestreut werden oder soll da noch irgendeine so Sirup da rein und dann diese Größenbezeichnung, die keiner versteht, was denn Venti bedeutet.
Habt ihr Oh Boy gesehen? Den Film hier aus Berlin? Ganz, ganz episch, weil da gibt es die Kaffeeszene überhaupt. Hier im Prenzlauer Berg um die Ecke und der Protagonist ohnehin übel launig und irgendwie auf dem falschen Fuß aufgestanden und sich gerade von seinem One-Night-Stand getrennt kommt also rein und sagte, ich möchte einen Kaffee. Und dann kommt also genau dieser Dialog.
Wie heißt der Film?
Oh Boy.
Der Film überhaupt, der deutsche Film der letzten Jahre. Also jetzt hat er Sicherheit mehr. IMDb 7,4.
Na bitte, qualifizier, krieg das Hucke, Gütesiege.
Ein deutscher Film. Ein deutscher Film in schwarz-weiß, hervorragende Ästhetik mit Tom Schilling, den ich sowieso sehr schätze. Und diese Szene gibt es auch auf YouTube, die können wir mal in den Chat reinwerfen. Und da entwickelt sich also ein wundervoller Dialog, mit dem ich will einfach nur Kaffee. Den muss man unbedingt drauf haben, selbst wenn man den Rest des Films nicht sieht.
Dann kann man bei Bäumen und Lotum auch sagen, ich will einfach nur Brot.
Das gibt's da glaub ich nicht.
Aber also, okay, sagen wir mal kurz, wie heißt deine Brotsorte, die gut ist?
Laugerosmaenmonen.
Laugerosmaenmonen. Das ist doch kein Brot! Ja, das ist so ein überdimensioniertes Laugenbrötchen. Aber es ist ganz lecker.
Okay, also da ist wahrscheinlich der Eineräugige unter dem Blinden in der Bank, im richtigen Moment über die richtigen Eimer gestolpert und dann so, hm, ja, das könnte man ja eigentlich auch noch mit anziehen.
Oder Kunden, die auf Pizza Bank kaufen. Und Roddy hat sich auch dazu noch einen Mango und Raspberry Hagen das Eis. Also bei dir ist wirklich Geschmacksfasching, ne?
Heute Mittag hab ich auch Chili Con Carne mit Sushi gegessen.
Ja, liebe Hörer, ihr merkt es schon. Es ist Freak Show Time. Und ja, wir sind gut aufgestellt heute. Roddy ist da.
Das ist super.
Perverses Schwein.
Und Huckel ist da.
Und wir begrüßen unseren Gast, den Ralf Stockmann. Der uns mit seiner gesamtkulturellen Expertise heute durch die Sendung präguiert.
Ja, durch die Sendung gerettet wird.
Nicht da ist Denis, der kommt wohl auch nicht mehr. Auch nicht da ist Clemens, aber der landet gerade oder ist gerade gelandet oder befindet sich gerade auf dem Taxiway und wird uns vielleicht hier noch später beehren und dazustoßen und den thematischen Rahmen erweitern. Und wie ich ihn kenne, verbraucht er gerade wieder ein paar wertvolle LTE-Gigabytes, um uns dann auch irgendwie die ganze Zeit zuzuhören. Ja, wir müssen dann vielleicht auch gleich mal auf das Desaster der letzten Sendung eingehen. Das hat natürlich einige, wie ich das auch nachvollziehen kann und wie David das hier auch noch wunderbar aufgearbeitet hat jetzt hier im Previously, sehr verwirrt, mich auch. Und ich kann euch sagen, das sind so Momente, wo bei mir wirklich auch alle Alarmglocken angehen. Weil erstens, also was ist passiert, um es nochmal ganz genau zu sagen, die kurz nach Aufnahme veröffentlichte Sendung war vier Stunden lang wunderbar. Und dann an zwei Stellen, in meinem Track und in deinem Track, Hucke, ich glaube deinem Track zuerst und später dann meiner, gab es einen zeitlichen Bruch, der der Aufnahme so aber überhaupt nicht anzusehen war. Also das sah alles aus wie immer. Also dem Endresultat wäre es natürlich vielleicht anzusehen gewesen, aber wer guckt sich jetzt schon das zusammengemixte Audio von vier Stunden, was einmal durch die Orphonikwurstfabrik gegangen ist, an? Naja und irgendwann, nachdem mindestens vier Stunden abgelaufen waren, berichteten mir halt Leute von irgendwie, da ist auch irgendwas kaputt, alle reden durcheinander und so.
Und du so, ne ne, das ist Konzept.
Das ist immer so.
Hört mal zwei Sendungen, gewöhnt euch dran.
Aber dann nahm das halt irgendwie zu und ich hörte da halt rein, dachte mir nur so, alter Schwede, was ist denn da passiert? Naja, ich will es jetzt nicht zu lang machen. Ich vermutete natürlich alles mögliche. Also ich vermutete erstmal den Klassiker, dass ich mich da irgendwie verschnitten habe, aber ich hab da eigentlich kaum, also da waren keine Schnitte, mit denen ich jetzt irgendwie hätte was falsch machen können. Und ich schaute mir halt auch nochmal diese Aufnahme an und es sah alles in Ordnung aus. Also sah alles in Ordnung aus. Aber noch ein bisschen herumklicken, stellte ich dann fest, dass Rieper halt irgendwie so komische Effekte zeigte, nämlich einerseits dieses durcheinander produzierte, andererseits quasi Audio abspielte, was da in dem Preview nicht zu sehen war. Also der Track sagte, hier spricht jemand und dann war stille und umgekehrt. Ich so, Kopfkratz, Kopfkratz, was bitte ist so? Und dann hab ich auch irgendwie auch gleich Alarm geschlagen und sofort natürlich alle verdächtigt von Ultraschall.
Wurde ich aus dem Bech geklingelt.
Genau, irgendwie dann würde... Genau, irgendwie, also ich hatte erstmal irgendwie Rieper im Verdacht, dass der da irgendwas falsch rausrennt, aber das konnte halt irgendwie auch nicht sein. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Nach einem Tag Analyse hatte ich es dann irgendwie raus. Und zwar waren, also ich nehme ja alles in Flak-Dateien auf. Das hat verschiedene Vorteile. Also lossless compression, das freie Format, kennt ihr ja sicherlich alle. Das ist den riesigen Vorteil hat, dass einfach der Gesamtspeicherbedarf einer solchen Sendung, auch wenn man viele viele viele Spuren aufzeichnet, einfach enorm klein ist. Weil es komprimiert einfach ordentlich weg. Aber man hat halt theoretisch keinen Qualitätsverlust. Praktisch gab es jetzt einen. Und ich stellte dann halt fest, dass die beiden Flak-Dateien, die also unsere beiden Spuren aufzeichnet haben, fehlerhaft waren. Und zwar eben nach vier Stunden und vier Stunden ein paar zerquetschte, war irgendwas falsch encodiert. Und der Fehler war in beiden Spuren, also in beiden war ein Fehler vorhanden, aber laut FFmpeg äußerte er sich anders. Also ich bekam andere Fehlermeldungen, wenn ich diese Datei da mal zum Fraß vorwarf. Und naja, da ich mir jetzt nicht vorstellen kann, dass in Reaper irgendwie so ein Fehler ist, dass er irgendwie alle Nase lang mal flackfalsch encodet, weil das wäre unter Garantie schon aufgefallen, also dafür wird da einfach zu viel mit produziert, bleibt eigentlich nur die These übrig, dass hier die Dateien auf dem Weg zur Platte kaputt gegangen sind. Sprich, entweder Bitrot im Buffer, Bitrot auf dem Weg durch das OS, oder natürlich, was auch möglich ist, Bitrot auf dem Weg in die Datei, beziehungsweise in das Dateisystem als solches.
Und das war wieder so ein Moment, wo ich mir dachte, hättest du mal ZDF geguckt und keinen Podcast gemacht.
Genau, das war sozusagen mein Gedanke. Wo ja immer alle so zweifeln, ob man denen das nun wirklich brauchen würde mit diesen Checksummen. Weil wir wissen ja, alle Computer schreiben, wir machen ja immer alles richtig. Und schreiben immer alle Daten richtig. Und das ist einfach so dermaßen nicht wahr. Sowas tritt jetzt nicht oft auf, aber hier hat man mal schön gesehen, wie so ein kleiner Bit-Fehler, also wie viele Bits da umgekippt sind, ob das irgendwie ein größerer Block war oder was auch immer. Auf jeden Fall führte es dazu, dass Reaper beim Rausrendern zwar keinen Fehler anzeigte, was eigentlich auch ein Problem ist. Also das wäre feststellbar gewesen, dass diese Datei halt irgendwie nicht in Ordnung ist. Hat aber irgendwie nicht gemacht und hat stattdessen Zeit übersprungen. Das heißt, er hat quasi diese fehlerhaften Blöcke einfach weggeworfen, aber eben die Zeitmarke nicht entsprechend angepasst. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass eben das gemickste Gesamtkonzept dann im Eimer war. Ich habe dann die Sendung ein bisschen umgeschnitten, habe diese Teile rausgenommen und hier und da so ein paar Pausen verdichtet und dann passte das da. Der Dialog, der, also interessanterweise war es genauso, dass sowohl der Teil, wo es bei mir kaputt war, als auch der, der bei dir hat. Keiner von uns hat irgendwas relevantes, nennenswertes gesagt. Soweit ich weiß.
Hat der Flank-Encoder gedacht, die Formation ist dichter.
Vielleicht ist da auch schon so eine Deep Learning Software am Start, die dann so, oh man, wir reden sich hier wieder um den Kopf und kranken.
Oder nach vier Stunden irgendwie, komm Leute her jetzt.
Wenn es so ist, wie wir jetzt vermuten, ist das ein schönes Beispiel für diese Robustheit oder auch nicht Robustheit von Datenformaten. Ich arbeite hier in einer Bibliothek und da spielen genau solche Fragestellungen von Langzeitalchivierung und digitaler Langzeitalchivierung eine Rolle. Was passiert, wenn irgendwo ein Bit umkippt? Und wir machen halt viel auf Images und wenn du einem JPEG oder einem GIF halt ein Bit kippst, dann ist das auch das Desaster groß. Je nachdem, es ist halt auch nicht vorhersehbar. Also je nachdem an welcher Stelle von JPEG du das hast, ist entweder so das ganze Bild weg oder nur so so ein 18-Pixel-Klumpen so. Aber dass Flak da jetzt dann doch auch so relativ schnell aus der Kurve fliegt, fand ich jetzt auch schon bedenklich. Mit Waff wäre das nicht passiert, da wäre es einfach völlig egal gewesen.
Also ich muss sagen, seit ich jetzt längere Zeit ZFS einsetze, habe ich das komplette Vertrauen in Festplatten verloren. Weil irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die kann man irgendwie eigentlich abonnieren. Eigentlich bräuchte man ein Abo für Festplatten, weil die immer irgendwie relativ flott kaputt gehen. Vielleicht kaufe ich die falschen Festplatten? Naja, die machen halt mal Bitfehler hier oder sie steigen mal ganz aus da und dann muss man nochmal wieder neu resilvern und wenn dann das fünfte Mal resilvern nicht hilft und die Platte immer noch Fehler hat, dann muss man halt eine neu besorgen und die da reinschrauben und so. Aber ich meine mit Ray-Z2 ist das irgendwie alles kein Thema, da tauscht man halt die Festplatte und schmeißt die alte weg. Beziehungsweise ich schraube immer noch die Magneten raus, weil die es sich am Kühlschrank so gut machen. Ja, das sind wirklich sehr starke Magneten.
Naja, sie sind stark auf kurzer Distanz, das muss man sagen.
Als Kühlschrank-Magneten gibt es nichts besseres.
Ja, das kann man bestätigen. Also auch zum Befestigen von anderen Dingen an Metall.
Also es gibt auch ein Leben nach den Daten. Aber vielleicht noch mal, Ralf, was du meintest, mit den Datenformaten, wie geht dir denn das Problem an? Mit der Redundanz und den Bildern und den Bit-Fehlern?
Dass wir nur TIF-Formate nehmen.
Ach, und inwiefern ist das da anders?
Also TIF ist quasi das Waff der Bildtechnik. Das heißt, es ist menschenlesbar, du hast quasi die RGB-Information, einfach nur stumpfe hintereinander weg, 0,0 Kompression.
Ja gut, aber ein Bit-Fehler äußert sich da ja auch. Also ich meine, da ist ja auch was falsch.
Ja, aber ein Bit-Fehler, dann ist ein Pixel in einer Farbnuance anders.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch nicht in Ordnung.
Naja, also da finde ich, muss man nochmal die Kirche... Also da könnten wir jetzt einen halben CAE drüber machen. Ich habe da nämlich mal so ein kleines Forschungsprojekt zugemacht. Da ist eine Frage, was ist visually lossless? Das heißt also, ab welcher Abweichung ist überhaupt jetzt so unser retinar gestehltes Auge in der Lage, irgendwelche Abweichungen wahrzunehmen und wo nicht? Und da wird also auch innerhalb der Digitalisierungsszene dann ein riesen Fetisch aufgebaut, was also unbedingt alles und wir dürfen nur in auch Raw-Formaten aufnehmen. Der Punkt ist, wenn man mal, wie ich, ein Digitalisierungszentrum geleitet hat und du siehst, wie eigentlich der Digitalisierungsprozess selber, aus dem die ganzen Daten eigentlich rauskommen, zustande kommt. Darüber wird irgendwie niemand. Das heißt, du hast also da so ein analoges Teil, da ist eine Linse, da wird irgendwie ein Fokus gesetzt, da ist Licht spielt eine Rolle. Dann hast du heute einen Operator, da legt dein Buch hin und macht die Aufnahme. So und wenn du jetzt dasselbe Buch dem nächsten Operator in die Hand drückst und das auf dem selben Gerät eh nicht hinlässt, hast du trotzdem jedes Pixel anders von der Aufnahme. Also da ist kein Pixel so wie bei der ersten. Das ist komplett anders. Und dann wollen die Leute mir erzählen, dass es also dann relevant ist, ob da ein Pixel jetzt irgendwie eine Abweichung von 10% ist. Das ist doch grober Unfug.
Na gut, aber es gibt ja auch TIF-strukturelle Informationen.
Nicht wirklich, die sind im Header alle vorne. Also im TIF-Format ist so aufgebaut, du hast am Anfang relativ lange Header. Wenn du im Header Fehler drin hast, die kannst du relativ gut reparieren. Und danach dahinter ist es einfach sequenziell weggeschrieben.
Warum kann man das da relativ gut reparieren?
Das geht dann so zeilenbasiert einfach durch. Also du kannst im Zweifelsfall, du hast die ganzen Produktionsinformationen von dem TIF hast du ja noch in diversen Produktionsdatenbanken bei uns.
Ist der Header zum Beispiel optional bei TIF auch redundant, speicherbar, also könnte man ihn zum Beispiel auch nochmal irgendwo zwischendurch oder am Ende auch nochmal reinschreiben, weißt du das?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das vorgesehen ist.
Aber so machen das ja Datalsysteme.
Es ist auch an der Stelle kein Bedrohungsszenario, weil da halt nur Metainformation ist, die sowieso in unseren OPAX drin sitzen und so weiter. Also da ist keine Information, die irgendwo was mit dem Objekt und dem Moment, in dem es irgendwie entstanden ist, wirklich was zu tun hätte. Die kannst du jederzeit löschen und neu schreiben, ohne dass irgendjemand aufschreit.
Und so ein Runlinks-Encoding, was sozusagen lossless nochmal Kompressionen macht, gibt es bei TIFF?
Es gibt TIFF-Kompressionsverfahren, die aber genau aus dem Grunde bei uns nicht zum Einsatz kommen. Weil die dann eben wieder weniger robust sind als Format. Dann müsste man sich im JPEG 2000 Bereich umgucken, aber der ist dann nicht open source als Codec. Ein schönes Thema. Was ein geiler Codec ist, ist der sogenannte Fax-G4-Standard. Das ist das, was wirklich auf Fax-Geräten läuft. Der kann allerdings nur bitonal, also nur schwarz und weiß, was allerdings für alte Drucke, die auch bitonal gedruckt sind, ich sag mal wirklich in halbem CRE, natürlich exakte Informationen wiedergibt. Weil was die Papierfarbe ist, ist eigentlich egal für alte Drucke. Die sind halt einfach nur schwarze Drucktinte auf irgendwie geartetem Papier, weißem, niedergelegt.
Eine Frage der Auflösung sozusagen.
Genau, die Auflösung ist viel relevanter als die Farbtiefe an der Stelle. 600 DPI, bitonal, und wie kriegst du da mit Fax-G4, was also auch dein Tippformat ist, super klein komprimiert, dann hast du die DIN-A4-Seite auf 80 Kilobyte. Und schickst die auf deinem 600 DPI Laserdrucker aus und hast quasi deinen persönlichen Reprint gemacht, in echt 1A Qualität, weil gescannte Auflösung gleich gedruckte Auflösung ist. Wird also nichts interpoliert oder so, es gibt richtig geile Ausdrucke.
Aber neu gerastert wird es ja trotzdem.
Ja, aber beim Digitalisieren ist es gerastert worden. Und beim Druck dann nicht mehr.
Da wird es einfach eins zu eins.
Ne, ne, ne, 600 dpi Laserdrucker. Der setzt das Pixel exakt so hin, wo es herkommt im Tiff. Naja, wir schweifen ab.
Ne, das ist mit drin in der Sendung. Also ich meine, hier gibt es gar keine Nebenthemen.
Genau, die baden gerade ihre Hände.
Der Abschwitz hat Methode.
Ich hab ja an der SOB Göttingen das Göttinger Digitalisierungszentrum geleitet und da haben wir sehr, sehr viel 600 dpi bitonal gescannt. Das ist alles dann frei im Netz verfügbar. Und das kannst du dann auch geil als PDF zusammenbinden. Du hast halt ein PDF, das ist irgendwie 10 MB groß oder sowas und hast aber halt da 300, 400 Seiten drin. Und dann haust du die zu Hause als Wissenschaftler auf deinem Laserdrucker und hast deinen privaten Reprint gemacht. Die Tricks funktionieren alle nicht, wenn du es halt in Farbe aufnimmst.
Ich schau übrigens gerade mal nach, wann du eigentlich das letzte Mal hier warst und das ist ja schon eine Weile her. Das sind ja mal locker zwei Jahre.
Das war zu 1.0 wahrscheinlich, ne?
Und jetzt sind wir schon bei der 2.1. Da reden wir auch gleich nochmal drüber. Aber vielleicht nochmal um bei den Daten zu bleiben.
Genau, ich wollte auch noch zu den Daten was sagen. Zum Thema Festplatten. Also es gibt von so verschiedenen größeren Providern gibt es ja immer so die Reports, welche Festplatten die höchsten Ausfallquoten und so weiter haben. Und wenn man so eine Festplatten kauft, dann halten die doch überraschend lange. Also hängt noch ein bisschen davon ab, welcher physikalischen Belastung man die aussetzt. Aber wenn die immer nur stationär liegen, passiert eigentlich nicht so viel. Zum Beispiel in dem Data Center meines Vertrauens habe ich auch letztens mal das Gespräch mit denen geführt und habe dann sogar mal gefragt, weil die irgendwie eine andere Festplatte angeboten hatten, als ich angefragt hatte. Dann habe ich mit denen so gesprochen, wie sieht es denn aus bei euch? Und dann meinten die, ja, also die Festplatte Western Digital Rate Edition kostet ein bisschen mehr, aber hat irgendwie so gut wie keine Ausfallquote. Und er meinte halt auch, generell ist es so, dass Festplatten innerhalb der Garantiezeit vom Hersteller fehlen, das ist so bei 1% oder kleiner. Und deswegen würde er auf jeden Fall empfehlen, auch die Festplatten zu nehmen, wo die Hersteller gleich 5 Jahre Garantie sozusagen ausweisen, weil man dann einigermaßen sicher sein kann, dass die jetzt in der Garantiezeit wahrscheinlich nicht kaputt gehen. Und es gibt dann auch noch so ein paar andere Modelle. Von Seagate gibt es ein Modell, das habe ich jetzt gerade nicht im Kopf. Und von Hitachi gab es, glaube ich, auch so eins. Aber es gibt hier von Backblaze...
Hitachi ist ja jetzt Seagate.
Genau, die wurden ja gekauft.
Und mit Seagate habe ich nur so mäßige Erfahrungen.
Ja, die haben ganz viele dünne Serien gehabt. Aber im Prinzip kann man auch sagen, bei jedem Festplattenhersteller gibt es diese Editionen oder Editions oder wie auch immer, oder Modelle, die so ein bisschen gammlig sind. Aber es gibt eigentlich in der Regel auch von jedem namhaften Hersteller mindestens ein Modell, was man anbieten kann. Und von Western Digital gibt es auch noch diese Red Edition, die sich, glaube ich, dadurch auszeichnet, dass sie nicht immer in der vollen Umdrehung fährt. Das heißt, wenn du sie die ganze Zeit benutzt und so, dann merkst du keinen Geschwindigkeitsunterschied. Und wenn du so immer mal wieder benutzt, dann fährt sie halt in der Nicht-Benutzung halt auch ein bisschen die Umdrehung runter, um Energie zu sparen und so. Oder ja, irgendwie so war das. Und ja, wie gesagt, wenn ihr halt irgendwie zum Beispiel für euren privaten, wie heißt das, NAS, Network Attached Storage oder was auch immer, für Server, für alles mögliche, für eure Backup-Systeme, kauft euch eine ordentliche Festplatte mit ordentlich Garantie. Es gibt auch immer dieses MBFS oder so.
Mean Time Between Failure, das liegt bei uns ungefähr bei 5 Minuten.
Das kann man auch, also bei den etwas Preis, also bei den Consumer-Modellen wird es meistens nicht dazu geschrieben. Und das hat Gründe. Wenn ihr eine Festplatte kauft, dann achtet darauf, dass mindestens dieser Wert angegeben ist. Und dass der über eine Millionstunde, nee, Quatsch, nicht eine Million, aber warte mal, ich suche den Wert nochmal raus, dass er halt auf jeden Fall hoch liegt. Kann man ja vergleichen, bei Alternate oder sonst was. Und dann hat man eigentlich in der Regel kaum Probleme. Ich habe Server im Betrieb, die laufen seit 6 Jahren und da war noch keine Festplatte kaputt. Noch ein Tipp, wenn ihr eure Festplatte gut beobachten wollt, wenn ihr kein tolles Fallsystem habt, was euch selber Bescheid sagt, dann gibt es ja noch die SmartCTL-Tools oder die Smartmon-Tools, so heißen die. Die kann man auch als Demon betreiben, immer die Smart-Daten aus der Festplatte auslesen und auch Bescheid sagen, wenn irgendwie Seek Errors oder Seek and Retry Errors oder wie auch immer, das da beschrieben ist, gefunden werden oder Blöcke realloziert werden müssen. Wenn das passiert, dann weiß man auch, die Festplatte ist bald Fritte. Das kann man auch sehr empfehlen, wenn einem die Daten wichtig sind.
Und hier nochmal der Hinweis zu ZFS. Wir hatten es ja noch nicht. Mir ist vor ein paar Wochen...
Kann ich kurz was sagen? Smart Mount Tools, kurz speichern, Roddy. Smart Mount Tools kann man sich auch auf dem Mac schnell installieren mit Homebrew. Und habe ich dann übrigens auch bei mir natürlich mal gestartet, um zu gucken, ob da irgendwie was braun ist. Da war es dann so, dass er mir sagte, mein Smart wäre gar nicht eingeschaltet. Und hab's dann mit diesen Tools mal eingeschaltet. Mich hat das so ein bisschen überrascht, weil gut, nicht dass ich mich bisher groß drum gekümmert hätte, aber ich dachte, sowas ist irgendwie immer eingeschaltet.
Na du kannst hier im System Report, steht das ja dann auch unter den SATA-Gerätschaften. Smart Status Verified steht da nur. Das hätte man mal bei dir auch mal gucken können, bevor du es eingeschaltet hast, ob es da auch schon Verified ist. Ja, wenn du bei SATA und SATA Express klickst und dann auf deine Festplatte, dann steht da Smart Status.
Ach so, man ist jetzt in der System Information?
Ja, genau so heißt das System Information.
SATA, SSD, ich guck gerade mal hier auf meinem Schleppi. Smart Status Verified steht hier.
Genau, aber man weiß halt in diesem System Information, das ist halt wirklich sehr dünn, wenn man halt diese Smartmon Tools benutzt, dann kann man auch einen extra Test starten, der auch vergleichsweise elaboriert ist und halt gucken kann, ob da irgendwelche Sachen gammelig sind. Aber noch besser ist tatsächlich, dann eben noch ein Fallsystem zu haben, was halt im laufenden Betrieb checkt, ob Bits flippen und dann eben auch auf Kommando wirklich jeden Blog auch von den Daten, die nicht benutzt werden, das überprüft.
Beziehungsweise auch repariert den Scheiß.
Oder eben doch repariert, wenn Redo und Duns vorhanden ist.
Ja und mir ist neulich vor ein paar Wochen eine SATA-Karte ausgefallen. Naja, da sind halt dann von sechs Festplatten plötzlich vier nicht mehr da. Da hat man natürlich nicht mehr so viel Spaß mit dem Dateisystem. Aber wenn man ein Hardware-Rate hat, ist das normalerweise Ende der Geschichte, weil man nie wieder die Hardware hinkriegt, die in der Lage ist, das Rate wieder zu verstehen. Bei ZFS war das jetzt kein Problem, neue Karte rein. Also erst die zweite Karte hat tatsächlich funktioniert, PC-Hardware halt, aber seitdem, als wäre nie was gewesen.
Verstehst du diese Outputs von diesem Smart-CTL?
Ja, machen wir auf einen großen Schirm. Da gibt es zwei Werte, die wichtig sind. Also Reallocated Sector ist interessant.
Der ist hier Null.
Genau, das ist schon mal gut. Die Seek Error Rate ist auch interessant. Und, warte mal, was? Der Spin Retry Count? Oder der, warte mal, einen gab es, glaube ich.
Calibration Retry Count, gibt es auch, ist auch Null.
Also ehrlich gesagt, die sieht jetzt erstmal okay aus.
Die sieht völlig nach dem aus. Deswegen hatte ich nämlich auch so für mich jetzt so ein bisschen die Theorie aufgestellt, hier könnte es halt auch auf dem Weg dahin. Ich meine, das passiert ja auch viel Elektronik, da geht es über den Bus, da geht es über Festplatten-Controller, Pieper-Po, alles kann mal Fehler machen, alles kann mal in dem Moment, kann ja sein, dass einfach gerade so ein Sonnensturm auf meinem Rechner eingehagelt ist. Man wisset ja nicht.
Hast du, kurze Frage, hast du diesen Self-Test da schon gestartet mal?
Welchen Self-Test? Von dem SmartZDL? Ich, äh, nee.
Weil dann kriegst du nämlich da drunter auch noch mal so Output, wenn er tatsächlich was findet und was er dann gefunden hat.
Was macht er denn da?
Äh, was er genau macht, kann ich dir tatsächlich gar nicht sagen.
Aber er rödelt auf der Platte rum? Also nichts, was ich jetzt tun sollte?
Ja, nö, vielleicht später dann. Mach's mal, mach's mal in Ruhe. Also, ähm, das ist halt auch so ein bisschen wahrscheinlich, das ist jetzt aber bloße Mutmaßung, äh, äh, so ähnlich wie bei ZDF, dass dir das Smart sozusagen alles, was im Betrieb so auffällt, sagt und dann mit diesem Self-Test halt nochmal so die dunklen, staubigen Ecken quasi abfegt und mal...
Mit Checksum draufschreibt und so.
Aber ich glaube, Reallocated Sector Count und die Seek Error Rate, das sind die, wo man so am ersten sieht, wenn es anfängt zu bröseln. Und Spin Retry Count war glaube ich auch noch da involviert, aber das...
Wenn die Platte nicht anläuft sozusagen.
falsch vielleicht. Aber da kennt sich hoffentlich vielleicht jemand, der Hörer sogar besser aus und kann uns das mal in den Kommentaren vielleicht im Zweifel nochmal sagen. Ich hab mir das auf jeden Fall gemerkt hier mit diesen Seek Error Rate und Reallocated Sectors.
Ja, also kurz gesagt, ich hab keine Ahnung, wo die Daten verloren gegangen sind. Irgendwo sind sie verloren gegangen. Was halt wirklich skurril ist, ist... Also ein Fehler hätte ich ja jetzt gesagt, okay. Aber zwei in unterschiedlichen Dateien, in einem Abstand von, was war das, fünf Minuten, paar Minuten, irgendwie so, weiß ich nicht mehr ganz genau, das ist nochmal richtig merkwürdig. Oder? Also hab da auch keine Erklärung für.
Hast du seitdem schon Sendung gemacht wieder?
Gute Frage. Nee, ich hab ja tatsächlich in den letzten zwei Wochen.
Na dann werden wir ja schauen, was heute dabei rauskommt.
Oder?
Nee, doch stimmt.
So was man hat nachzuperen, ist super eklig.
Sorry, ich hab Aufnahmen gemacht. Bisher keine Issues.
Ja, ich mein, das ist wirklich so dieses Problem auch, dieser immer mehr werdenden Abstraktion zu erinnern.
So ist es.
Und natürlich auch diese extremen Datenmengen, die wir hier machen. Ich meine, selbst wenn die Fehlerrate, die potenziell so bei 0,0001% liegt, die laufen durch, ne?
Ja, vor allen Dingen mit jeder Größenordnung Bits, mehr auf der Platte, geht dann die entsprechende Gesamtwahrscheinlichkeit hoch.
Ja, und natürlich auch so anfällige Dateiformate, die dann eben darauf basieren, dass eigentlich jedes Bit stimmt. Von daher kann man sich halt nur fragen, wann gibt es denn ein neues File-System-Layout bei unserem Lieblingscomputer? Es gab ja, vielleicht sollten wir mal kurz die File-System-Zukunftsdiskussion wirklich führen, ohne jetzt zu viel ZFS zu schreien, aber...
Ich bin nicht mehr der Meinung, dass ZFS das richtige Dateilsystem für Mac wäre.
Ja, das glaube ich auch nicht, dass es kommt.
Aber ich bin nicht mehr der Meinung, weil es halt ein Server-File-System ist. Dafür ist es gut, aber nicht für ein Laptop.
Für ein Laptop wäre es auch okay mittlerweile mit den RAM-Größen, aber fürs Mobiltelefon wäre es immer noch nicht.
Fürs Mobiltelefon sowieso nicht, ne.
Eben. Aber sie haben ja nun einiges an Abstraktionsgeschichten eingeführt in den letzten Jahren, ohne zu viel Gebrauch davon zu machen. Populärstes Beispiel ist natürlich File Vault, was ja im Prinzip auch so eine modulare Erweiterung des ganzen Subsystems ist.
Naja, da haben sie aber mehr oder weniger transparenten Volume-Manager drunter geschoben, damit du im Prinzip halt einmal das Device abstrahierst in ein virtuelles Volume, was du dann verschlüsselst, nach oben hin halt nach unten verschlüsseln, nach oben als normalen Volume.
Ja, aber genau so auf diese Art und Weise könnten sie natürlich auch eine Datenintegritätsebene einführen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt der Weg ist, der sich unbedingt anbietet, aber irgendwas müssen sie halt machen.
Ja gut, das sagen wir aber schon seit ein paar Jahren und passiert ist bis jetzt nichts.
Immerhin gab es jetzt Änderungen. Ich meine, sie haben jetzt, sie haben in, wie heißt das aktuelle Betriebssystem? Es ist erstaunlich, dass ich das überhaupt null präsent habe. Ich hätte jetzt fast Yosemite gesagt. Echt? Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich benutze dieses Wort nicht. Also früher mit den Katzen, immer.
Der Schnurleport.
Nichts gegen Katzen.
Aber jetzt wird mir das langsam zu blöd.
Ja, das liegt vielleicht daran, dass du in diesen ganzen schönen Nationalparks von Kalifornien noch nicht rumgestiefelt bist. Also ich auch nicht, aber...
Ja, daran liegt das wahrscheinlich.
Hier fehlt ja der Hangzünder.
Ja, das ist auch zu komplex irgendwie. Was kommt denn als nächstes?
Eine spezielle Route auf dem El Capitan.
Auf jeden Fall...
Die gibt's sogar. Wie heißt sie denn da? Die diese Huberburm hoch sind. Na ja, egal.
Es muss auf jeden Fall was passieren. Was halt passiert ist jetzt unter El Capitan ist, dass sie ein Feature rausgenommen haben. Sie haben ja dieses Disk Utility neu geschrieben. Ohne dass irgendwie absehbar wäre. Warum?
Na, es sieht jetzt schnuffeliger aus.
Und es ist schon sehr beruhigend zu wissen, dass ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel mit meinem Mac Pro diese Soft-Raid-Geschichte fahre auf drei Platten. Das Feature, das einzurichten, aber aus diesem Tool jetzt verschwunden ist. Also es ist nicht so, dass das nicht weiter funktionieren würde. Das schon. Der Code ist immer noch da. Aber sie haben halt die Möglichkeit des Einzurichten weggenommen. Und ich frage mich natürlich, hat das vielleicht was damit zu tun, dass sie sozusagen jetzt gerade alle Seile abschneiden, die dann nicht mehr kompatibel sind mit dem, was danach kommt?
Vielleicht hat das auch mit deiner Aufnahme zu tun.
Das sind die Vorboten. Ich sage jetzt mal nicht ZDF S oder so, aber wenn sie ihre File-System-Mechanik modernisieren, was würde sich natürlich als erstes anbieten? Natürlich allen voran erstmal Check-Summing. Ich denke, da sind wir uns einig, das muss einfach kommen. So ein Fehler wie mir jetzt hier unverschuldet passiert ist, darf nicht passieren, ohne dass ich davon Kenntnisse erhalte. Und dass die Software auch eine Möglichkeit hat, das zu recovern. Die hatte es halt derzeit nicht. Das muss auf jeden Fall sichergestellt werden.
Ja, du gehst da aber von einer Prämisse aus, nämlich dass der allgemeine Apple-User dann mit der dann aufpoppenden Fehlermeldung was ordentliches anfangen kann. Also wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen, dass das kein Einzelfall ist, sondern tatsächlich die bei Apple verbauten Geräte immer mal wieder Probleme machen, dann würde ein Dateilsystem, das diese Fehler erkennt und dem User kundtut, dazu führen, dass Apple Hardware tauschen müsste.
Ich will überhaupt gar nicht, dass dem User da was kundgetan wird. Es soll einfach nur funktionieren. Das heißt, sie müssen natürlich Layer einziehen, die in dem Moment einfach selber eine Strategie haben, wie dieser Schreibfehler wiederholt, umgangen, durch das Beschreiben anderer Bereiche usw. sichergestellt werden kann. Also das ist ja das Ding. Derzeit hat die Hardware keine Möglichkeit festzustellen, dass das, was auf die Platte geschrieben wurde, auch wirklich das war, was die Intention war.
Vielleicht ist deine Voraussetzung zu sagen, Platte auch die falsche. Ja, Storage, was auch immer. Aber ich meine, sie verbauen ja letzten Endes auch kaum noch Platten.
Ist egal, bei SSD geht das ja genauso.
Sie bauen ihren eigenen Flash-Kram ein und dann wäre es natürlich schon sinnvoll, ein Datalsystem zu haben, was über die Flash-Bausteine, die da sind, irgendeine Art von Raid baut.
Richtig. Genau, sowas oder was auch überhaupt, ich meine die Fallsysteme, die wir heute haben, vor allem natürlich auch HFS, ist halt gebaut für rotierende Platten.
Das Ketten eigentlich.
Das ist auch eine rotierende Platte. Die war nur floppy. So, und ich denke, es gibt eine ganze Menge Optimierungen, die man jetzt auch machen kann, schlicht in der Annahme, dass quasi der Speicher der Zukunft eben ohne diese Platten auskommt. Die Frage ist, wie weit liegt diese Zukunft noch vor uns? Und heißt das, dass eine solche Neuerung sich dann auch nur auf SSDs bezieht? Ich würde meinen, das müsste nicht unbedingt sein. Man könnte schon das neu aufziehen und sagen, okay, wenn SSD, dann kann das seine vollen Vorteile. Hier auch ausspielen, die dann unter Umständen nicht in demselben Maße ausgespielt werden können, wenn man es tatsächlich noch rotierende Köpfe hat.
Also meiner Meinung nach wäre Apple Style schon zu sagen, wir bauen jetzt da mal SSD, so wie wir uns das vorstellen. Und da machen wir dann auch alles rein, was das neue Dateisystem ausmacht. Und alle anderen Sachen können entweder wieder nur HFS Plus oder halt die super abgespeckte Version des neuen. Also das wäre Apple Style.
Ja gut, aber Apple Style ist auch Full Disk Encryption.
Ja klar, aber das funktioniert ja so, wie es jetzt ist.
Ja, aber was ist denn, wenn da die Bits kippen, dann funktioniert das nicht.
Aber das ist ja eine Ebene drunter sowieso, oder?
Naja, dann müssen sie, also entweder haben sie da jetzt schon irgendeine Form der Integrität. Ja, das weiß ich nicht, wie das funktioniert. Aber ein flippendes Bit im Flagg ist halt 10 Sekunden Audioverlust. Ein flippendes Bit im Krypto kann halt heißen alles im Arsch, aber so richtig alles im Arsch.
Da ja die Blocks alle einzeln verschlüsselt sind, ist ja der Block mit 2 Kilobyte Block im Eimer. Aber das ist das so?
Weil, das kann auch größer sein. Bei großen Platten ist der größer. Da geht er auch schnell mal auf 8K.
Ja gut, dann sind es halt 8K. Das ist halt irgendwie...
Dann ist ja die Frage, was bedeutet der Verlust.
Ja, dann ist halt eine Datei kaputt.
Ja, da ist vielleicht aber auch irgendein Direktorie-Eintrag kaputt. Da ist unter Umständen mehr kaputt als nur eine Datei. Und eine Datei kaputt kann heißen, die gesamte Datenbank ist kaputt, weil diese eine Stelle, diese eine Datei ist so der Holy Header. Weißt du auch, wie Software heutzutage aufgebaut ist? Software geht doch davon aus, dass immer alles okay ist. Welcher Programmierer baut denn wirklich Redundanz ein, im Sinne von ich überprüfe meine eigenen Daten? Da muss man sich doch nur mal die Security-Situation heute anschauen. Ich meine, die Leute, die kümmern sich ja auch nicht mal um Daten, die ihnen über das Internet zugegangen wird. Habt ihr das mitbekommen mit diesen LG-Routern? Die werden noch jetzt wegen dieser gesetzlichen Änderungen in den USA von der FCC, werden die jetzt alle so geändert, dass man sie nicht mehr flashen kann.
Hä, was ist denn die gesetzliche Änderung?
Die gesetzliche Änderung ist, die dürfen jetzt nicht mehr änderbar sein, damit da alles sicher ist. Und damit da nicht irgendwelcher Code draufkommt, der unsere Funknetze durcheinanderbringt, weil Terror und überhaupt, das ist alles vollkommen absurd, aber so ist sozusagen die Regelung. Und natürlich springen die jetzt alle hinterher. Jetzt hat LG, nee nicht LG, L.
D-Link.
Nein, die anderen.
Netgear. Links ist.
TP-Link. Da ist das L. TP-Link, Entschuldigung.
Na, aber hoffentlich war Clemens gerade in nem Funkloch.
Mann, egal. TP-Link. Auf jeden Fall kommen jetzt diese ersten Modelle und die Hacker gucken halt drauf und schauen halt nach, wie kann man das jetzt machen. Der erste Hack, den ich gesehen habe, ist, haltet euch fest, du platzierst halt so ein Shell-Skript, was dann halt das umflasht, auf so ein USB-Stick. Und wie bringst du diese Kiste dazu, das zu exekutieren? Du nennst deinen WLAN-Backtick, slash, tralala, Shell aufrufen. Du schreibst das Shell-Commando in Backticks in deine SSID, in deinen WLAN-Namen und bringst den Router dazu, irgendwann irgendeiner Stelle automatisch dieses Skript aufzurufen. Also kein Programmierer, also die Programmierer kümmern sich einfach nicht jeder und nicht immer, aber insgesamt auf jeden Fall deutlich zu wenig um Validierung von Daten, Validierung von Eingaben, von Usern, wo es ja schon so schon super volatil ist.
Ja, aber das ist doch jetzt nichts Neues, also zu sagen, das wäre jetzt irgendwie...
Nein, nein, das ist nichts Neues. Ich sag ja nur, so ist das. Und das ist aber auch ein Kulturwandel, der hier ansteht. Dass man einfach überhaupt nichts mehr traut. Nicht nur mit irgendwie Daten von draußen und Daten vom Netz und Daten vom User, sondern auch das OS ist im Verdacht. Du kannst mir viel erzählen hier, Datei. Naja, ich meine, die verifizieren doch ihren Kack nicht. Word, schieß mal in so eine Word-Datei rein. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass hier das Programm crasht, die ist einfach extrem hoch. Also dieses Fuzzing, was man so übers Netz macht, um irgendwelche Server aus dem Tritt zu bringen und die Choren alle dumpen, ist das so? Das Fuzzing kannst du natürlich auch mit Dateien machen. Lass die irgendetwas, was auch nur so ansatzweise nach einer Word-Datei aussieht, öffnen und da steht einfach nur gequirlte Scheiße drin.
Ja, so funktionieren Exploits.
Öffnen diese Datei, das ist bekannt.
Ja gut, aber das kann ja dann auch schnell dazu führen, dass sie halt dann anfangen, irgendwie ihre eigenen Dateien dann auch zu löschen. Also du kannst ja jeglichen Fehltritt da sozusagen auslösen.
Aber jetzt lass uns mal wieder die kleinen Brötchen kurz in den Ofen schieben. Und nochmal zum Kern des Pudels zurückkehren. Apple braucht ein File System, was toll ist.
Ja, genau.
Aber es gibt auch keine neuen Rumors eigentlich dazu, ne?
Ne, es gibt nur...
Den letzten Rumor, den wir hatten, war, dass sie File System Engineers geheiert haben vor Jahrzehnten. Erinnere ich mich dunkel, dass wir da ein Jobposting irgendwo rausgefischt haben. Aber das war es. Aber auf jeden Fall, ich kann nur immer wieder sagen, da ich ja im täglichen Alltag mit ZFS beruflich zu tun habe, immer wieder, wenn man sich mit anderen File Systemen befassen muss, ist es wirklich ein Trauerspiel. Ein Zurückkehren in die graue Realität.
Ja, so ist es, wenn man das Licht einmal gesehen hat, dann ist alles andere Keller.
Mit oder ohne Licht.
Mit oder ohne Licht, teilweise, ja.
Schreiten wir weiter mit Feedback zur letzten Sendung. Ich weiß nicht, wer hat das hier reingeschrieben?
Das hab ich da reingeschrieben.
Das hast du da reingeschrieben, Ralf.
Weil ich dachte mir, hey, das lohnt sich vielleicht für eine kleine, höherer Publikum-Live-Aktion, so Kunst und sowas.
Haben wir schon aufs Bingo hingewiesen?
Noch nicht.
Macht Bingo. Bingo.freakshow.fm. Da gibt's Bingo-Karte.
Jetzt auch schon mit Clean-Install oder was?
Ihr habt ja letzte Woche vor zwei Wochen über Clean-Install geredet. Das hab ich mir alles angehört und konnte das alles sehr nachvollziehen. Hab mir dann aber die Frage gestellt, wann war eigentlich mein letzter Clean-Install? Und dann hab ich mich gefragt, wie kriege ich eigentlich raus, wann mein letzter Clean-Install war? Und da dachte ich, hey, jetzt bin ich hier bei den Freaks, die werden das doch mir mit Sicherheit beantworten können. Also wie kriege ich jetzt hier an meinem Mac raus, wann war der letzte Clean-Install?
Ja, also da gibt's einen ETC oder...
Vielleicht noch kurz, warum mich das noch eigentlich interessiert. Weil daraus könnte man jetzt eigentlich noch eine lustige Competition machen für unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen. Sprich, derjenige, der ein komplett durchgepatchtes El Capitan laufen hat und die längste Zeit seit seinem Clean-Install hat, seinem letzten, der hat gewonnen. Und kriegt den Balls of Steel auf was auch immer Reward.
Also ich würde ja erstmal sagen, du gehst einfach in Library-Preferences und schaust mal, was die älteste Datei ist.
Also die User-Lite.
Ja, das kann aber...
Das ist ein Indiz.
Das ist ein Indiz, aber wenn du natürlich einen Install mit... Ich nehme die Dateien von meinem letzten Install mit dazu. Weißt du, so ein...
Das ist ja kein Clean-Install. Also das ist jetzt sozusagen die Frage, was verstehst du unter Clean-Install? Manche sagen ja, das ist OS und dann hole ich... benutze ich mein Home-Directory genauso weiter. Aber ich glaube, das, wo wir letztes Mal drüber gesprochen haben, war ja sozusagen...
Whole Turkey.
Der volle Bruch, ja.
Also mir würde jetzt für die Definition glaube ich schon reichen.
Also der significant other wird einfach entfernt. Das ist sozusagen keine Telefonnummer, keine E-Mail-Adresse, kein Facebook-Kontakt, nichts. Alles aus dem Kopf heraus, neu eingestellt.
Ja, man könnte ja beide Parameter mal durchbrühen. Also ich hab jetzt gerade mal hier reingeschaut, hier unter Library Preferences, das wäre bei mir Dezember 2014. Das kommt mir fast ein bisschen zu jung vor.
Ja, also ich würde auch sagen, wahrscheinlich ist es so, dass irgendwo in den Untiefen so der System Directories bestimmt irgendwelche Dateien lauern, die vielleicht dann immer so unangefasst bleiben bei so einem Update. Irgendwie sowas wie ETC Hosts oder so, wenn man die nicht selber editiert, dann könnte man mal gucken, ehrlich gesagt. Also ich würde wahrscheinlich so mal die ganzen ETC oder War Directories nach dem ältesten Datum durchsuchen. Wobei, das heißt ja auch nichts, weil wenn die ein neues Image machen und diese Datei einfach sich in ihrem Base-Image sozusagen nicht geändert hat, also die auch sozusagen von Apple-Seite nicht angefasst wurde, dann kann die auch von 2001 sein.
Also meine älteste PREV-Datei ist vom 24.11.2012 und das kann ganz gut hinhauen.
Die war jetzt in Root Library PREV.
Das ist aber eine schöne Frage tatsächlich.
Nee, kommt nicht hin. Also ich hab hier bei mir, das ist noch die Frage, welches Datum du nimmst, also ich hab jetzt mal Erstelldatum genommen und da habe ich jetzt der 2.05.2009, das ist sicherlich nicht richtig.
Das kann schon sein, dass du so bestimmte Dateien so lange übernommen hast.
Also ich hab ja meine Festplatte formatiert, wenn irgendwie in den Metadaten vom Fallsystem stehen würde, wann dieses Fallsystem erstellt wurde, dann wäre das der absolute Clean Install Ursprung. Jetzt weiß ich aber nicht, ob man mit welchem Tool auf der Command Line man eventuell solche Metadaten auslesen könnte.
Erstellzeit des Volumes wird hier auch vorgeschlagen im Chat.
Also bei mir ist die älteste Datei von Anfang 14 in den Preferences, in den User-Preferences. Das könnte sein, dass das der Zeitpunkt war, als ich die Maschine neu hatte. Weil ich weiß, dass ich die tatsächlich nicht auch migriert hab oder so.
Mach mal ein Apfel-I auf deinen Mac, ein Tosh HD und guck mal, was da Created Edge steht.
Also wenn ich mir einen neuen Mac kaufe, ist das in meiner Definition kein Clean Install. Ich krieg dann meinen Time Machine drauf und hab immer noch meine alte Suppe.
Ja, aber das war ja keine Migration. Also es war kein Time Machine draufziehen und es war auch kein Migrationsassistent, sondern es war einfach die Maschine, so wie sie war, anfangend zu benutzen. Also zählt das als Clean Install? Eigentlich schon, weil es clean ist, ne?
Ja. Also Festplatten-Datum scheinen mir nicht weiterzuführen.
Nein. Es stellt bis hier Oktober 2013.
Auch die anderen Daten sind natürlich nur eingeschränkt, aussagekräftig, weil es immer mal passieren kann, je nachdem, was für ein Tool du verwendest, dieses Tool darauf verzichtet, die alten Creation und Modification-Dates auch korrekt zu setzen. Dann kopierst du das alles rüber und dann ist halt alles von dem Tag. Und ich hab ja auch so viele Dateien hier am Anfang, die alle 24.11.2012 sind, dass ich fast das Gefühl habe, dass da das auch noch nicht so die ganze Wahrheit ist. Ehrlich gesagt, 2012 kommt mir auch ein bisschen zu neu vor.
Also ich mein bei mir, ich weiß, dass ich diesen Rechner, also ich hab's ja kürzlich clean installed, ich weiß, dass ich den clean install auf diesem Rechner gemacht hab. In dem Fall würde das Created-Ed von der Festplatte hinkommen. Aber klar, wenn du sozusagen auf einem vorherigen Gerät deinen letzten clean install gemacht hast, dann wird wahrscheinlich dein Volume Created-Ed nicht mehr stimmen. Tja, also für sachdienliche Hinweise.
Da brauchst du eine richtige umfangreiche Strategie.
Das ist nicht einfach zu beantworten.
Ja, wir freuen uns auf die Kommentare.
Ja, also das System Alter ist ja nicht das, was gemeint ist. Das ist sozusagen, wann hat man seine Prefs komplett neu aufgesetzt? Und ich trage das, glaube ich, alles schon sehr lange rum. Ich muss auch sagen, die paar Male, wo ich mal komplett meine Prefs verloren habe, das waren auch immer dunkle Tage, weil es einfach so viel Wissen in alten Präf-Dateien drin steht.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, so Preferences, einzelne kopiere ich schon rüber. Aber ich habe es früher halt eben immer so gemacht, dass ich mir meine alte Library auf den neuen Clean-Install, also auf den Desktop gelegt habe, und damit ich immer sozusagen einfach ganz easy so, ich habe eigentlich nie bei einem Clean-Install einfach alle Prefs übernommen, sondern immer nur da, wo ich definitiv jetzt nicht alles wieder von vorne durchhampeln wollte. Aber das habe ich dieses Mal tatsächlich noch strenger gemacht als letztes Mal und habe, glaube ich, nur so drei oder vier, sagen wir eine Hand voll. A fist full of preferences.
Im Chat kommen so Tipps wie guck doch mal ETC PassWD an, das hat natürlich auf Mac keine Relevanz, die Datei.
Ja, das meine ich halt eben.
Da sind die Dateien schon, die User schon lange nicht mehr drin.
Ja, und vor allen Dingen, was ich halt auch meine, bestimmte Dateien, die halt so mit einem Systemupdate eventuell abgedetet werden, wie zum Beispiel ETC Services, die ja hauen dann halt auch nicht hin. Und manche Dateien werden wahrscheinlich seit Mac OS 10 einfach so immer mitgeschleift, weil die zu einem POSIX irgendwie dazu gehören und nie geupdatet. Also insofern schwierig.
Gut, sehr viel mehr können wir da wohl nicht zu sagen. Kurzer Nachtrag noch, weil es schön erwähnt wurde zu diesem OK GO Video, in dem Parabelsflug, den wir hier ausführlich bequatscht haben. Ich bin erst später auf ein anderes Video von Ihnen aufmerksam gemacht worden, das sollte man nochmal erwähnen. Ist auch wieder so komische Musik, aber wie hieß das noch gleich? Moment, jetzt kann ich einen Fehler machen. Also kein schlecht geplanten. Das heißt, I won't let you down. Und wem der Parabelsflug gefallen hat und das noch nicht kennt, sollte sich das vielleicht auch nochmal anschauen, weil das ist einfach auch mal sehr cool mit Drohnen und Regenschirmen. So eine wunderbare Kombination.
Und wie heißen diese Mobile, mit denen sie da...
Weiß ich nicht, wie die heißen, diese komischen Sitzroboter, wo man drauf rumfahren kann. Ja, merkwürdig, so ein Einrad... Einrad...
Ich hab's ja auf dem Kongress auch, diese normalen Einradgefährte.
Wo man so mit den beiden Füßen draufsteht, aber man nicht drauf sitzen. Genau, und hier sind so komische Sitz-Einräder, die sich selber halten, und wo die dann irgendwie mit rumkurven, und dann machen sie halt Pixel-Kunst mit Regenschirmen.
Sehr schön.
Und dem Ornament der Masse nach Siegfried Krakauer. Weil ich bin ja hier für die Kultur zuständig.
Und verlinkt auch in den Show Notes nochmal ein FAQ zu diesem ganzen Video, wo sie diese ganze absurde Planung nochmal im Detail beschreiben und Fragen beantworten, wie lange das alles gedauert hat, und wie viel darum gekürzt wurde und so weiter. Und auch nochmal bekräftigen, dass alles wahr und alles in einem Go gefilmt. Das merkt man aber auch, wenn man sich das nochmal im Detail anschaut. Ja, dann vielleicht nochmal zu diesem Bahnunglück. Das will ich jetzt gar nicht weiter vertiefen, aber wir hatten ja da so eine ganze Diskussion, wo dann viele Leute auch meinten so, naja, wie soll denn das alles funktionieren? Weil da gab es ja irgendwie ein Funkloch. Stellt sich raus, gibt gar kein Funkloch auf dieser Bahnstrecke. Bleibt sozusagen nach wie vor ein Mysterium, wie denn es sein konnte, dass dieser Notruf nicht durchkam oder keine Folgen hatten. Kann natürlich sein, dass der zu spät war. Aber es hieß ja bisher auch immer, es sei keine Notbremsung ausgelöst worden oder zumindest zu spät, weiß ich nicht. Ich will jetzt hier auch überhaupt keine weiteren Vermutungen anstellen. Meine Vermutung, dass es doch wohl umfangreiche GPS-Erfassung gäbe bei der Bahn von den Zügen, hat sich als Wunschdenken herausgestellt. Es ist halt noch ein bisschen schlimmer als gedacht. Also es ist wohl so, dass fast keine Züge irgendwie live per GPS ihre Position bestimmen und diese übermitteln. Das muss ich allerdings sagen, wundert mich. Und zwar wundert mich das, weil das ja nun technisch wirklich kein Hexenwerk ist.
Das passiert bestimmt alles zu unserer eigenen Sicherheit.
Ja, also es ist wohl auch eine totale Sisyphus-Arbeit, diese ganze Datenwelt der Bahn irgendwie zusammenzubringen. Wir hatten ja auch hier diesen wunderbaren Kalenderhack erwähnt und wo dann ja sozusagen die Schweizer Fahrplanauskunft bezogen wurde, weil ja die Bahn sowas nicht liefert. Einen Tag später haben sie es dann bekannt gegeben, dass sie das jetzt auch tun. Die haben ja gerade so eine Open-Data-Initiative, wo auch so eine oder andere Person aus unserem erweiterten Bekanntenkreis eine Rolle spielt. Und naja, ist aber auch nur so ein halber Schritt. Also die haben zwar jetzt was und sind da am entwickeln, aber es ist halt erstmal nur der Fernverkehr. Also kannst du es halt nicht mit Nahverkehr und schon gar nicht mit Lokalverkehr kombinieren. Und der Grund ist halt, dass das einfach alles so gestückelt ist und dass da einfach die einzelnen Abteilungen, ich weiß nicht, ich hab da irgendwo die Horror-Stories gehört von unterschiedlichen Abteilungen der Bahn, haben einfach unterschiedliche Bezeichnungen für dieselbe Haltestelle. Wo du sagen würdest, wie Bezeichnung ist ja egal, da musst du doch eine ID geben. Nö, gibt's nicht. Ja, also das ist schon so, okay, da guckt man immer so auf die Uhr und so, immer noch 2016, was in aller Welt. Da kommt mein Hirn nicht mit. Also jetzt mal von dieser ganzen Digitalabstinenz, mal ganz abgesehen in diesem Lande, ist doch überhaupt nicht planbar so ein komplexes System. Ralf, sag du doch mal was dazu als passionierter Rubriken und ID-Bastler. Stell dir mal vor, ihr hättet in der Bibliothek unterschiedliche Titel für eure Kultureinheiten. Das sind ja nicht nur Bücher, sondern alle möglichen Artefakte. Oder jetzt erzählst du mir wahrscheinlich gleich, dass es genauso ist.
Nein, nein, wir haben unsere Signaturen und unsere persistent Identifier. Und da ist alles schick, so wie sich das gehört. Ich fürchte nur immer, dass man jetzt hier auf so einer Ebene von ungesunden Halbwissen unterwegs ist.
Das sind wir immer.
Da bräuchte man jetzt mal so einen Bahnexperten.
Apropos Bahnexperten.
Das ist das, was mir jetzt von Bahnexperten zugetragen wurde.
Apropos Bahnexperten, gibt es irgendwo eine Erklärung dafür, warum die Bahn auf ihren Bahnhöfen die Anzeigetafeln immer so aufhängt, dass man nur die von den Nachbarbahnsteigen sehen kann, weil die vom eigenen Bahnsteig immer mit Schildern zugestellt sind, dass man sich da irgendwie direkt drunter stellen muss? Gibt es da irgendeine Erklärung für? Ist euch das mal aufgefallen? Also in Berlin gibt es nicht einen Bahnsteig, wo du vom Bahnsteig aus das Schild sehen, also diese Anzeigetafel sehen kannst. Das ist immer was davor. Die Dinger sind immer so in der Mitte vom Bahnsteig, da sind dann Schilder, so hier geht es die Treppe runter, nach sonst wo, und dann ist das direkt davor. Oder dann ist irgendwie so ein Häuschen davor, wo irgendein DJ drinsetzen kann, das ist dann auch direkt davor. Und du stehst auf dem Bahnsteig und denkst dir, ja okay, am Nachbarbahnsteig fährt der jetzt dahin, aber wohin fährt jetzt meiner?
Du schaust auf den Bahnsteig auf Schilder? Nein, auf seine Handy, Mann.
Ach so, das ist natürlich...
Also ich muss gestehen, dieses Problem hatte ich noch nicht.
Ist dir noch nicht aufgefallen?
Ich konnte bisher die Anzeige tarfeln, relativ gut zu erkennen.
Mir ist es irgendwann aufgefallen und jedes Mal, wenn ich auf einem Bahnsteig stehe, denke ich mir so, ja, auch hier kann man es nicht sehen.
Und jetzt wird es von Neurose.
Ja, es wird von Neurose.
Ich hab eher ein Problem mit der Audio-Spur auf Bahnsteigen. Du hast selber noch Kopfhörer auf und du hast irgendeinen guten Podcast, und du merkst einfach nur so Herdentrieb, wie um dich rum plötzlich die Masse nervös wird und irgendwo wegrennt und man dann sofort in einen Panikartigen Fluchtreflex kommt, dass man auch irgendwo wegrennen muss und schon wieder hat man verpasst eine Durchsage, dass der Bahnsteig anders ist. Das ist eher ein Problem, was wir mal lösen müssen. Also irgendwie eine große rote Warnleuchte, einfach mal so buzzernäßig. Achtung, hier, jetzt ist es ernst, jetzt müsst ihr irgendwie was anders machen. Dieses durchgenuschelte Durchsagen. Schrecklich.
Und dann auch noch total Verhalten, wo das dann in diesen riesigen Katakomben... Am Hauptbahnhof geht's aber. Wie unsere Freak Show-Aufnahme. Man hat auch das Gefühl, dass es in mehrere Spuren zerteilt wird und in unterschiedlichen Zeitversätzen.
Und du hörst irgendwie immer den Nachbarn. Da würde ich auch sagen, man hört den Nachbarsdurchsage immer lauter als die anderen.
Eine wichtige Ansage auf Gleisweite. Also ich finde, am Hauptbahnhof haben sie es schon hin.
Am Hauptbahnhof geht das, aber andere Bahnhöfe, da gebe ich dir recht.
Also warum nicht einfach dann auch da an dem Display halt wirklich irgendwie eine große, strahlende, rote Leuchte. Achtung, schau mal dahin, hier ist jetzt was anderes. Und dann mal ein Display einsetzen, auf dem du auch mal mehr unterbringen kannst als irgendwie drei Buchstaben gleichzeitig. Dieses Crawl-Geschichten, wie die formuliert sind, das ist alles irgendwie so menschenfeindlich.
Ja, naja, nun, also ehm, immerhin sind sie davon abgekommen, irgendwie auf dem Display nur zu schreiben, bitte beachten sie die Ansage, damit man nicht fotografieren kann, dass es mal wieder eine Viertelstunde zu spät ist. Aber wie gesagt, dazu muss man halt auch die Anzeigetafel erstmal sehen können. Und wenn man nicht direkt drunter steht, dann ist irgendwas davor meistens.
Um den Winkel.
Nee, Stelzen nennt man das nicht, hochhackige Schuhe, Stelzen.
Okay, genug Bahngraben. Da haben wir eh keine Ahnung von. Da warten wir mal wieder, bis die Experten vor Ort sind. Und jetzt, wie ist es gelaufen?
Na super, nee wirklich gut.
Vielleicht noch mal kurz für die unwissenden.
Ansatz war nicht weniger als die weltbeste am Markt verfügbare Recording-Software für Podcasts und nur für Podcasts anzubieten, mit der man also nichts im Musikbereich machen kann, nichts irgendwie anderes Audio, sondern wirklich nur Podcast, Podcast, Podcast, weil ich da irgendwie wie viele andere auch ein gewisses Defizit irgendwie gefühlt habe. Ja und darum basteln wir jetzt so seit, ich glaube, dreieinhalb Jahren in einem eigentlich stetig wachsenden Team, was auch ganz erfreulich ist.
Seit dreieinhalb Jahren?
Ja, ungefähr. Oder?
Ich hab dann anderthalb Jahre gebraucht bis zum ersten Release.
Ja, also es ist immer auch die Frage, wann man da den Startpunkt sieht, aber...
Ja, das stimmt.
Drei Jahre jetzt mit Sicherheit. Drei Jahre ist mit Sicherheit, ja. Als Grundlage dafür, ist immer die Frage, was nimmt man halt, baut man komplett was selber, was mir einfach vor allen Dingen in Anfangstagen mangels Programmierkenntnis und Menschenlebensressourcen, also noch einen anderen Job schlicht nicht möglich war, was selber zu entwickeln. Auch wenn das immer mal wieder jetzt im Team diskutiert wird, muss man nicht alles wegwerfen und alles mal einfach selber coden. Habe ich aber irgendwie da noch einen sehr gesunden Grundrespekt vor. Stattdessen war halt die Strategie, sich so die DAW rauszunehmen, die zum einen mit am wenigsten kostet und die zum anderen hochgradig anpassbar ist. Wo man also zwar ist sie Closed Source, aber sie verhält sich eigentlich, finde ich, so in vielen relevanten Bereichen eigentlich eher als eine Open Source Software. Und das ist halt Reaper geworden, die hat der 343 Max hier mir empfohlen, mal vor langer, langer, langer Zeit. Da war er, glaube ich, sogar noch dann hier unter Mobile Max. Und das habe ich mir angeguckt und das habe ich schon vor zwei Jahren erzählt. Ja, es sieht alles ganz schrecklich aus, wenn man Reaper installiert, lustigerweise jetzt auch immer noch. Ja, also, dann könnt ihr auch sagen, na ja, mittlerweile ist auch Reaper selber gewachsen und sie haben dazu gelernt und wir könnten jetzt auch unsere ganzen Theming- und Skinning-Gesachen mal bleiben lassen, weil so die Standard Reaper GUI besser geworden ist. Nein, ist sie nicht. Die ist immer noch total schrecklich. Aber wenn man das mal überwunden hat, merkt man, dass da zum einen der vielleicht beste Audio-Könnel der Szene drunter steckt. Das ist einfach ein grundrobustes Audio-Engine-System, was die haben und man hat eine sehr breite API, wo man an viel dran kommt. Man kann selber Extensions reinprogrammieren, die dann irgendwie sich mehr oder weniger nahtlos ins Restsystem einfügen. Man kann praktisch alles themen, kommen wir gleich noch ein bisschen dazu, wie man also die Nutzeroberfläche vom Design her angeht. Das ist also einfach eine schicke, sehr flexible Geschichte. Und jetzt versuchen wir so im Halbjahres-Release-Takt, die meistens immer so gekoppelt sind mit unseren Podcasts, Podcast-Workshops, quasi immer wieder neues Spektakel zu den Leuten zu bringen. Da hatten wir jetzt im Dezember die 2.0er-Release und da haben wir jetzt relativ schnell im Februar die 2.1er hinterher geschoben. Und die läuft extrem gut. Also das Feedback, was wir jetzt kriegen, ist noch mal deutlich besser als alles, was wir vorher bis einschließlich ans Dreier hatten. Also jetzt diese 2.0er, 2.1er-Geschichte, die schlägt jetzt gerade so richtig ein, was auch ein bisschen mit dem Zuschnitt dieser Releases zu tun hat.
Zuschnitt?
Naja, wir haben ein paar Dinge adressiert, die lange auf der To-Do waren. Das Erste ist komplett Soundflower, ein und für alle mal und wirklich und endgültig ablösen. Das ist jetzt Erfolg, du Hu.
Und wie ist das Erfolg?
Daniel hat es komplett auf Co-Audio, frisch komplett selbstständig neu implementiert.
Also der Ultraschall-Hub liegt Ultraschall bei, macht im Wesentlichen dasselbe wie Soundflower.
Nämlich virtuelle Soundkarten im Mac anlegen.
Genau, wobei kann man sagen, da soll es ja auch nochmal eine Auskopplung geben.
Genau, also es gibt jetzt das, was jetzt ausgeliefert wird und was derzeit jetzt auch erstmal nur fertig ist. Allerdings auch wirklich fertig ist, dass man halt so die gängigen Sound-Devices, die man so für Podcasts braucht, auch installiert bekommt. Also sprich, du kriegst irgendwie ein Skype- oder Mumble-Device, du bekommst ein Streaming-Device, du bekommst ein AUX-Device, über das du dann noch alles Mögliche irgendwie machen kannst. Und das, was er noch vorhat, ist, dass eigentlich Daniel bei uns aus dem Team, der das alles gestemmt hat und sich da wirklich durch dieses totale Fledermausland von Apple-Core-Audio, der hat auch einiges an Bugs reportet, die ja noch gefixt worden sind von Apple. Also das hat ganz gut funktioniert. Auf dem Camp war er da unterwegs, ja. Krass. Da hat er so einiges an Debugging-Arbeit auch für Apple mitgeleistet. Aber gut, dass das dann zumindest alles nicht so vergeben und umsonst ist.
Ja, das wundert mich. Oh, dafür, dass sie nichts fixen.
Nein, das stimmt so nicht. Also das hängt wirklich sehr stark ab, wo man den Bug rein reportet und ob es einen Diskussionsspielraum dafür gibt, ob das jetzt ein Bug ist oder nicht. Also gerade wenn es relativ offensichtlich ein Fehlverhalten ist und man kann eine Example-Code mit dazu legen, der halt eindeutig zeigt, das funktioniert jetzt nicht so und schon gar nicht, wie es dokumentiert ist. Dann geht es in der Regel relativ flott. Also das ist... Es gibt halt wieder so andere Sachen, die sind so ein Diskussionsspielraum. Habe ich neulich wieder ein Bug reportiert, wo es dann hieß so, ja, aber die und die Klasse, die benutzt RFC so und so und die andere Klasse benutzt aber RFC so und so und weil in der neueren RFC ist das anders, verhält es sich auch anders.
Also wir hatten einfach das seriale Problem, dass vor Yosemite Apple eigentlich angekündigt hatte, so der quasi mehr oder weniger immer still und klammheimlich gebilligte Unterstützung und durchlaufen lassen von Soundflower wird jetzt final eingestellt. Das war eigentlich so deren Aussage und bis zur Release-Version, also wirklich bis einer Version von dem Golden Master, war es auch so. Da konntest du also Soundflower nicht mehr unter Yosemite, dem Betas, installieren. Und dann kam die Golden Ma- und das war halt der Punkt, wo wir einfach Stress hatten, weil es war klar, okay, die Leute wollen ja wie updaten, die wollen ihre Podcasts nicht auf veralteten Betriebssystemen machen und wir müssen denen irgendwas dann alternativ halt hin liefern. Von daher war dann also ziemliche Dynamik dann drin, diesen Hub-Triver irgendwie den Start zu bekommen. Dann kommt die Golden Ma- da raus und da ist dann plötzlich Soundflower doch wieder zugelassen. Also wir haben gemerkt, vielleicht nutzen das ja doch noch irgendwie so ein paar zehntausend Leute, die wollen wir jetzt vielleicht nicht so komplett gegen das Schienenbein treten. Aber Daniel hat dann durchgezogen und da wir das ohnehin vorhatten und sinnvoll fanden und auch die Flexibilität und Stabilität von Soundflower halt dann, es ist halt einfach halt irgendwie so acht Jahre alter Kot so und das siehst du auch, da wird immer ein bisschen gegengetreten, aber im Wesentlichen ist es einfach komplett tot das Projekt. Und naja, jetzt haben wir den Hub also schön neu implementiert und die nächste Ausbaustufe ist, damit will er im Wesentlichen halt so seine, er ist in DJ-Kreisen viel unterwegs, für die das auch immer sehr viral ist, komplexe Routings von ihren Abspielrechnern machen zu können, während ihre Live-Performance ist. War glaube ich gerade ein falsches Fremdwort, was ich da angestroht habe. Nee, sehr essentiell, relevant, wie auch immer. Hauptsache schwierig klingt.
Du meintest wahrscheinlich vital.
Ja, egal, verlassen wir einfach diesen Bereich. Und da ist der Plan, dass man sich also beliebige eigene Sound-Devices dann anlegen kann, auch mit der Anzahl an Kanälen, wie man es gerne hätte und mit der Benamensung, wie man es gerade braucht. Dafür wird es dann auch der Plan, dass das dann ganz offiziell in den Apple Store reinzugeben so als offizielles Tool. Da machen wir auch nichts Verbotenes, sondern es ist einfach nur Chor-Audio rauf-runter implementiert, sauber, keine Hacks, keine Querschiessen mehr. Warum es aber auch nur unter El Capitan läuft, also da gibt es keine Rückwärtskompatibilität mehr. Und da ist der Plan, dass er dafür dann auch wirklich mal ein bisschen Geld dann nimmt, aber die normale Podcast-Edition, die wird es dann nach wie vor umsonst mit der Distribution mit dazu geben. Da müssen wir mal gucken, wenn er das fertig hat.
Und gibt es einen Link zu diesem Standalone? Also das gibt es schon für die Podcast-Edition, das ist eine extra Tool?
Genau, das ist eine extra Tool, ist aber Teil unserer ganz normalen Suite und müsste eigentlich auch auf GitHub liegen.
Das heißt aber, es gibt als separaten Download auch oder muss man?
Das ist ein installer in dem Paket, ein Download, wo alles drin ist und installierst du einfach nochmal zusätzlich. Ultraschall selber kommt als normaler Installer, also muss auch sagen, es läuft ja nicht nur auf dem Mac, sondern auch unter Windows, ne? Aber ich kenne jetzt nur die Mac-Seite, auf jeden Fall installiert man das, installiert sich halt Reaper separat und dann ist quasi erst Reaper, dann Ultraschall, dann sind die ganzen Libraries und Plugins und so weiter alle an der richtigen Stelle und dann gibt es immer noch diesen leider nicht umgehbaren manuellen Schritt, du musst halt dann einmal Reaper starten und dann diese Präferenz-Datei da reinschmeißen und damit kriegst du halt erst diese ganze neue Optik und das ist halt zwar ein bisschen awkward, aber das erlaubt Reaper einfach nicht anders, warum auch immer. Naja, so ist das dann halt.
Okay, jetzt hätte ich nämlich noch eine Frage an den Experten. Mein Problem ist ja, ich mache ja Podcast und Musik und deswegen installiere ich mir nicht Ultraschall, hab es bisher nicht gemacht, weil ich...
Da muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, das ist absolut nicht unsere Zielgruppe.
Nee, nee, darum geht's, also das war gar nicht die Frage, sondern kann man das mit Reaper auch einigermaßen einfach hin und her schalten oder ist das einmal Ultraschall, immer verultraschallt und dann hilft nur noch der Cleaninstall?
Also wenn du dir die Welt einfach machen möchtest, installierst du unterschiedliche Mac-Profile, wo du einfach hin und her schaltest, weil das also alles im User-Ordner halt landet, im Wesentlichen. Wenn du es nur auf einem User laufen lassen willst, müsstest du dir mal genauer den Reaper-Mechanismus angucken zum Import und Export der ganzen Settings und Themes, die da alle mit reingepackt werden. Das war ja überhaupt die Geburtsstunde überhaupt. Ultraschall nicht nur als Privat-Hobby, sondern als Projekt, wo auch andere was von haben können. Du hast halt in Reaper diese Export-Funktion, wo du alles exportieren kannst, was irgendwo auch in den allertiefsten Settings parametrisiert ist, plus alle Skins, plus alle Themes, plus alle Extensions, die du irgendwie drin hast. Dann hast du wirklich so einen Bundle und das installierst du irgendwo anders und dann ist diese Installation plötzlich genauso, wie der von der du gekommen bist. Das ist ein sehr mächtiger Mechanismus und du könntest jetzt also hingehen und quasi immer deine Profile dadurch switchen, dass du es immer exportierst und das andere wieder importierst. Du müsstest allerdings dann darauf achten, dass du jedes Mal dann auch wirklich wieder exportierst, weil vielleicht hast du ja in den Settings wieder irgendwo was gedreht und die Taktzahl umgestellt. So ganz rudimentäre Unterschiede sind beispielsweise, Reaper ist normalerweise taktbasiert, was für Musiker total Sinn macht. Das ist halt Musikersoftware und wir stellen das um auf reine zeitbasierte Einheiten, damit du Kapitelmarken halt in der Zeit und nicht intakten angezeigt kriegst. Das sind alles so Settings-Geschichten, ich glaube wir schreiben so an die 200 Settings alleine um. Da ändert sich auch ständig was. Du wärst dann nicht mit zwei karbonisierten Setting-Dateien glücklich, sondern musst eigentlich fast nach jedem Prozess das wieder erstmal exportieren und dann wieder importieren. Das geht zwar recht schnell, dauert so 30 Sekunden oder sowas, aber so ein bisschen awkward ist das schon.
Ja, so viel. Gut, aber okay, gut, das war die Antwort der Frage. Und ich mein, den Podcast, den ich da so mache, der ist ja nur zweispurig und relativ unaufwendig. Da hatte ich bis jetzt noch nicht das ganz große Bedürfnis, eine komplette Unkonfiguration vorzunehmen. Aber wenn es irgendwann mal zum Beispiel in Reaper selber so ein Profilswitcher gäbe oder irgendwie so, wenn das so ganz galant ginge, würde ich das auf jeden Fall mal ausprobieren. Aber ich werde mal ein bisschen mit diesem Export und Import rumspielen.
Das ist einfach Settings General, direkt das erste ganz oben. Also generell ist das schon, Tim sagte gerade Pain in the S, das ist einfach völlig richtig. Der Installationsweg von Ultraschall ist schon irgendwie so, gerade auf dem Mac irgendwie ungewohnt sperrig.
Ich sagte glaube ich nicht Pain in the S, ich glaube ich sagte Awkward.
Du hast halt, ich meine, das ist, finde ich ja alles durchaus gut dokumentiert, also sprich wir haben hier irgendwie eine Seite, wo eigentlich Schritt 1 bis 10 beschrieben steht, was genau zu tun ist, aber du merkst einfach so an dem Feedback, was sich dann also im Sende-Gate und so was ablagert, die Leute sind halt einfach dann so hibbelig.
Ich will da einfach ein Icon von A nach B draggen und dann soll gehen.
Die haben einfach nicht mehr die Muße, die Jugend von heute, zehn Punkte mal durchzugehen. Und dann hast du wirklich den Punkt so, ich habe folgendes Fehler mit, was ist denn da wieder kaputt? Bei allen anderen geht es doch, ich habe es auch genau gesehen. Und dann sagst du, ja, Schritt 8, der Installation. Oh, Schritt 8, ja den habe ich nicht gemacht. Das hatten wir jetzt echt schon ein paar Mal. Das ist ja nicht dramatisch, aber das hätte ich natürlich generell gerne sehr viel einfacher. Und da ist auch Heiko sehr hinterher, ja auch ein Urgestein bei uns im Team. Wir basteln eigentlich an so einer Ultraschall-Menü-App, die sich also wirklich oben halt so in die Mac-Menüzeile reinklinkt und dann beispielsweise auch mal so nach Hause telefoniert nach Updates auf GitHub vorbeischaut und ähnliches. Weil das ist auch ein echtes Problem, was wir haben. Wir kriegen nicht kommuniziert, dass es eine neue Version gibt und dass es cool und wichtig ist, diese neue Version rauszugeben. Ich vermute, dass jetzt nach vier, fünf Monaten immer noch mindestens die Hälfte der Leute auf einer 1-3-Jähr-Installation unterwegs ist. Das sind also Mechanismen, die wir gerne mal... Haben wir auch alles diskutiert. Aber das kriegst du den Leuten ja auch alles nicht vernünftig so vermittelt. Das sind alles so Themen, so auf so einer Metaebene, wo wir auch durchaus denken, da kann das Projekt als solches noch runder werden, so richtig rund wäre es halt nur, wenn wir auch wirklich die eigentliche DRW-Software-Basis halt selber unter unserer Kontrolle hätten. Aber davon sind wir jetzt noch ein bisschen entfernt. Wobei eins meiner Ziele schon ist, wirklich auch die Reaper-Leute selber mal anzugehen und so sagen, schau mal hier, ihr habt 400 Installationen in Deutschland und das liegt an diesem kleinen, lustigen Projekt und können wir nicht mal so einen fröhlichen Backchannel mal zu euch irgendwie einrichten, weil ein paar Dinge sind wirklich skurril. Ja, genau, das sind ja die alten Windamp-Entwickler. Also eigentlich coole Leute, echte Hippies, echte Audio-Nerds, also nicht irgendwie von der dunklen Seite oder sowas, aber dann halt auch so in ihrem ganzen Support gebaren, auch ein bisschen eratisch manchmal.
Ja, das ist wirklich schade. Ich würde ja auch mal interessieren, wie gut die da so leben können von ihrem Reaper. Also die hauen ja immer fleißig Updates auch raus. Aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass das Entwicklerteam da nicht das Allergrößte ist wahrscheinlich. Ich würde die auch gerne mal sehen. So eine kleine Inhouse-Tour. Wie sieht es bei denen eigentlich aus? Ich könnte mir da alles vorstellen zwischen so einigermaßen coole Office-Base zu zu gemüllte Streibtische und zwei Nerds sitzen da und hacken halt.
Ich glaube, es ist mehr so ein Pizza-Shuttle-Bereich. Was mich jetzt nicht unbedingt beunruhigen würde?
Also ich verfolge das jetzt seit drei Jahren, auch wie die halt selber so agieren und gefühlt steigt bei denen eher die Dynamik, als dass sie abnimmt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das korreliert mit dem, was sie irgendwie einnehmen und ob sie also auch einfach irgendwie mittlerweile so einen Breaking-Point haben, wo das alles auch einfach so als Firma gut läuft. Aber die sind weiter von entfernt jetzt irgendwie in so eine Stall-Phase zu geraten.
Ich meine jetzt gerade mit Reaper 5 ist ja wirklich noch mal eine ganze Menge Zeug dazugekommen.
Gab es das mit dem Video schon vorher?
Nur so als hier so Proof of Concept quasi und dann haben sie es in 5 noch mal überarbeitet.
Also das merkt man schon, dass da auch große Sachen angegangen werden. Leider werden halt die kleinen Sachen nicht groß angegangen. Das ist das, was mich eigentlich am meisten stört. Also was zum Beispiel vollkommen wahnsinnig macht, ist diese ganze Konfusion mit dem Keyboard-Fokus. Du hast halt so ein Multipane-User-Interface und so in bester Unix-Manier schon fast. Weißt du einfach nicht, wenn ich eine Taste drücke, welcher Teil dieser Software empfängt jetzt diese Taste? Und das hängt dann so ein bisschen davon ab, wo so der letzte Mausklick war und so, weißt du, dann ändert sich da immer so implizit so ein Keyboard-Fokus und dadurch funktionieren dann auch Skripte auf einmal nicht richtig oder werden nicht richtig getriggert. Da hat Ralf jetzt auch gerade in der letzten Version noch mal so einige Sachen fixen müssen. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es auch wirklich Fortschritte, zum Beispiel das hier ist Python, man das nicht mehr benutzen muss, sondern dass man jetzt mit Lua das Ding skripten kann, das war auch ein Riesenschritt nach vorne. Ja, also ist so ein bisschen, es ist mühsig, sich darüber zu beschweren über eine Software, die wirklich eine Menge kann und ich bin extrem beeindruckt vor allem von der von der Stabilität. Ich habe das Ding noch nicht einmal crashen sehen und ich meine, das ist wirklich ein Kandidat. Hatten wir ja gerade auch die ganze Datengeschichte und es ist vor allem auch so unfassbar klein, also sehr download.
12 MB oder so was.
Und dann poppt das Ding auf und rockt wie Sau. Ich habe noch etwas erratische Ergebnisse, so mit dem Renderspeed, ich habe also gefühlt, ist mein Mac Pro langsamer als mein MacBook R, was ich irgendwie überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen kann. Da muss ich aber noch mal ein bisschen genauer forschen, bevor ich da irgendwelche Überhauptungen machen kann. Aber ich wollte jetzt auch noch auf was anderes hinaus. Du sagst ja gerade so schön, beste mögliche Recording-Software für Podcaser.
Da brauch ich ein Ziel im Leben.
Da würde mir ja so einiges einfallen. Was denkst du denn liegt denn jetzt noch so vor euch? Ohne jetzt hier zu viele Versprechungen zu machen. Nur immer so konzeptionell. Was wäre sozusagen schön, dass es im Einzelnen immer sehr schwer zu erzielen ist? Weil muss ja auch jemand machen, beziehungsweise nicht alles lässt Reaper jetzt als Host auch so ohne Weiteres zu. Aber erst mal so, wie es eigentlich sein sollte.
Also ein Bereich, den wir eigentlich schon seit zwei Jahren mal gerne machen würden, wo aber es musste sicher mal einer fehlen, der sich den Hut aufsetzt und sagt, da mach ich jetzt zumindest mal ein Proof of Concept von, so wie ich mir das vorstelle, ist so die Verbindung von Struktur der Sendung noch irgendwie besser während der Sendung reingeben zu können. Also beispielsweise sind wir jetzt hier in einem Workflow unterwegs, wo auch schon viel irgendwie an Links und sowas rein reindängelt alles, ist letztendlich aber einfach nur ein Textdokument. Mit Textdokumenten kann Reaper eigentlich relativ gut umgehen auf verschiedenen Ebenen. Du kannst also Textelemente, die auch irgendwie strukturiert sein können, sehr gut in der Timeline eigentlich platzieren und könnt es auch hinterher mit Textelementen in Schnitt machen. Wir hatten auch mal ein Proof of Concept, dass zum Beispiel komplette Show Notes mit akkuraten Zeitmarken richtig in der Timeline mit drin lagen. Das wäre so insgesamt so Sendungsvorbereitung, Kapitelmarken immer schon vorbereitet haben und die nächste abschicken, einfach während ich irgendwie auch das Kapitelmarken-Text setze. Das ist, glaube ich, denke ich, auf jeden Fall noch ein Bereich, wo noch was zu holen ist. Dann eine Ebene, die wir jetzt ja gerade erst anfangen, richtig auszuloten, ist ja das, was ich hier als Storyboard bezeichnet habe. Wirklich getriggert durch den vorletzten PPW, wo ja ein Vortrag gehalten wurde über gebaute Beiträge. Wenn wir jetzt hier als Gesprächspodcast sitzen, ist eigentlich immer das Setup ja so, dass irgendwie jetzt x Leute quatschen und man hat hinterher eine große lange Soundspur und dann wird maximal geschnitten. Dass ich also einfach nur sage, so die Pinkelpause muss raus und hier war es irgendwie langweilig und da noch mal das Räuspern. Aber so die Kontinuität oder das Verhältnis der Sprecher zueinander ist immer fix. Ansonsten passiert genau das, was wir in der letzten Folge hatten. Und dieser Storyboard-Modus dreht das jetzt komplett um und sagt so, wie sieht es denn aus, wenn jemand eigentlich eher so einen Radiobeitrag aus irgendwie 80 verschiedenen Soundquellen raus zusammen basteln möchte. Was ja auch hinterher als Podcast enden kann. Und dazu haben wir halt jetzt so ein Datenbankmodul wieder freigeschaltet innerhalb von Reaper, wo man also Verschlagworten kann, einzelne Soundfiles oder auch Segmente von Soundfiles, die man dann auch suchen und filtern kann und sagen, ich mache jetzt ein Interview mit fünf Leuten und ich tippe irgendeinen Namen rein in das Suchfeld und sehe dann die ganzen Antworten und ziehe die dann schnell rein in die Timeline und kann das schnell umarrangieren und so. Also eher so ein bisschen wie man Videoschnitt auch irgendwie so denken würde. Und da sind wir glaube ich noch relativ am Anfang. Da ist glaube ich noch viel zu holen in dem Bereich, weil da merkt man auch immer, wenn man sich mit Leuten unterhält, die damit wirklich ihr Geld verdienen, gerade mit Videoschnitt. Die haben einen ganz anderen Zugang nochmal zu Schnitt, wie Schnitt zu funktionieren hat, auch im Audio. Also für die ist einfach jede Minute ist bares Geld bei denen im Job, so Videoschnitt. Und die sind so darauf konditioniert, irgendwie mit Sequenzen zu arbeiten und das alles nur rein über die Tastatur. Da sind so wir Podcaster noch relativ, vielleicht im positiven Sinne, aber trotzdem amateurhaft unterwegs gegenüber dem, wie Schnitt im Videobereich passiert. Ich glaube, da können wir uns noch sehr viel abgucken. Ich habe auch schon zwei Kandidaten identifiziert, die ich demnächst mal ins Team befördern verhaften werde, um da nochmal so einen ganz anderen Effizienz-Ebene nochmal reinzukriegen. Das wird glaube ich auch ganz schick. Ansonsten werden wir die Windows-Version komplett feature-complete machen zur nächsten Release oder spätestens über nächsten Release. Das ist also auch wirklich kein Untermeschiet mehr macht, ob ich auf Mac oder auf Windows unterwegs bin. Und da wird natürlich der Schlüssel dann zum Erfolg sein. Studio Link hat das ja auch schon im Lautsprecher entsprechend drin. Das heißt also, diese ganze Skype- und Mumble-Misere ablösen durch Studio Link und das direkt in Ultraschall rein implementiert. Sodass du also dann zu dem Zeitpunkt eigentlich diese Hubs überhaupt gar nicht mehr brauchst. Also Komplexität rausnehmen, auch aus dem Routing rausnehmen, das Ganze noch einsteigerfreundlicher machen und wirklich in CD-Qualität Remote Recordings machen können. So das wird schick und das wird dann auch unter Windows klappen und unter Mac gleichermaßen und das wird dann glaube ich nochmal komplett durch die Decke gehen. Wenn die Leute das nicht nur so erzählt bekommen, sondern dann mal hören, was das alleine für ein qualitativer Unterschied ist, ob ich einen Skype-Call habe oder so einen Studio-Link-Call. Beide haben ja mal und zwar nur 10 Minuten auseinander, aber trotzdem wir haben ja mal so eine Schalte gemacht mit dem Studio-Link und es war halt echt, als ob du hier im selben Studio sitzt und halt einfach nur woanders hinguckst. Also es ist psychologisch ein riesen Unterschied, ob ich so eine schon kaputt komprimierte, irgendwie immer etwas dängelige Skype- oder Mumble-Audiospur hab von anderen Leuten oder ob es wirklich so kristallklar definiert ist, wie das jetzt bei Studio Link der Fall ist. Wenn die Leute das einmal gehört haben, werden sie nie wieder irgendwas anderes wollen und wissen dann das einzige Programm, was das Out of the Box richtig schön und cool drin hat, das wird nochmal ein echter Unique Selling Point. Und wird glaube ich Podcasting generell nochmal richtig boosten. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob der arme Junge weiß, was da auf ihn zukommt.
Ich glaube, da ist schon eine Ahnung.
Welcher arme Junge? Der Studio Link Junge?
Ja, der Sebastian Reimas. Ja, wobei es tut sich eine Menge in diesem Voice-over-IP-Bereich, Slack hat das ja jetzt auch gerade nachgerüstet. Scheint auch ganz gut zu funktionieren soweit. Aber ich wollte ja eigentlich, jetzt hast du im Prinzip die Roadmap ausgepackt, was so demnächst so kommt. Aber meine Frage ging ja eigentlich noch ein bisschen weiter.
Ja, so die ganze große Ferne Vision.
Naja, das ist jetzt zu abgehoben. Da könnte ich jetzt stundenlang drüber reden, aber das heißt halt DAW selber programmieren und das ist glaube ich einfach außerhalb der Reichweite. In dem Moment, wo man sowas wie Reaper mal in, naja, am liebsten halt so OS-10-native, wunderbar modular, zusammenklickbar, weißte, mit korrekten User-Interface-Verhalten und wo irgendwie nicht Keyboard-Fokus im Eimer ist und so, das wäre natürlich mal eine schöne Basis, dass man quasi so ein Gesamt-Framework baut, aus dem man sich sowohl eine Musiksoftware als eben auch eine Podcastsoftware so wirklich modular zusammenklicken kann, wo dann sozusagen der Code, den man nicht braucht, auch gar nicht mehr da ist. Aber das ist jetzt wirklich nur Träumerei. Nö, aber ich denke, es gibt ein paar Sachen, von denen noch nicht unbedingt klar ist, ob jetzt das sich jetzt mit dem aktuellen Reaper so realisieren ließe, aber gerade wenn man es schaffen würde, zum Beispiel da mal etwas exquisitere diplomatische Beziehungen aufzubauen, eben vielleicht dann auch die Entwicklungslinie mal ein wenig zu beeinflussen. Das ist ja jetzt nicht komplett außerhalb der Möglichkeiten. Dann ist halt die Frage, auf was würde man sozusagen, also jetzt jenseits des offensichtlichen Problem behebens, Buck Fixings, wohin würde man sie eigentlich gerne steuern wollen, um was zu machen? Und bin ganz bei dir, im Prinzip ist diese ganze Show-Notes-Idee bzw. überhaupt dieses Metadatisieren, ist ja ohnehin mein Hobby. Das wäre schon großes Kino. Vor allem dieses ganze Kapitel und Strukturmarken ändern. Das merkt man wieder, wie wichtig das ist. Ist auch schwierig, aber wenn man da erstmal so ein bisschen im Flow ist, dann ist das auch geil, dass man quasi schon während der Sendung sich darüber Gedanken macht, wie man sie später publiziert. Das tue ich ja hier in eingeschränktem Maße auch schon, eben mit Ultraschall-Unterstützung, also allein jetzt diese Kapitelmarken. Das ist ja schon mal ein großer Gewinn, aber ich würde natürlich in demselben Maße, wie ich mir über Kapitelstrukturen Gedanken mache, auch andere Dinge annotieren. Also vor allem dieses Realtime-Annotation, das ist wirklich was Tolles und da hätte ich halt gerne eher so ein System, wo ich eben unterschiedliche Typen von Annotationen einfach von vornherein unterscheiden kann, damit das nicht alles jetzt nur so als unterschiedlich befarbte Kapitelmarke rumlungert, wie das ja derzeit noch mit diesen Edit-Markern zum Beispiel ist, um zum Beispiel auch solche Marker auch verbleiben lassen zu können in diesem Dokument. Weil das ist ja eine Information, die ich unter Umständen später, wenn irgendein anderer Schneidebedarf zum Beispiel existiert oder ich auch so eine Sendung später noch mal zusammenfassen möchte. Also es gibt ja jetzt verschiedene Tools. Ich bin auch gerade so ein bisschen dabei, um Podcasts ein wenig zu featuren, Ausschnitte zu liefern. Und das ist zum Beispiel so eine der Dinge, die ich mir gerne markieren würde. Weil man merkt so, das war jetzt ein lustiger Teil, den findest du danach nie wieder. Du willst aber jetzt auch nicht unbedingt eine Kapitelmarke da hinsetzen beziehungsweise machst du das dann vielleicht, aber dann ist halt irgendwie alles, ist einfach was anderes. Oder es wurde ein Link gesagt, es wurde ein Fehler gemacht, es wurde keine Ahnung. Und das finde ich zum Beispiel schon mal eine sehr wünschenswerte Entwicklung, wenn es in diese Richtung gehen könnte.
Wobei ich da fast sagen würde, dass das eher ein konzeptionelles Problem ist als ein wirkliches Implementierungsproblem. Weil du hast in Reaper schon sehr, sehr viele unterschiedliche Metadatenlayer, die man für sowas nehmen könnte. Also beispielsweise, um jetzt eine besonders lustige Passage irgendwie auszuzeichnen, dafür würden sich Regions sehr gut eignen. Das sind so diese Viecher, die wir jetzt auch erst zum Soundboard sichtbar gemacht haben. Ich habe ja einfach zwei Drittel der ganzen Reaper-Funktionnehmer ausgeblendet und versteckt, dass man sie nie sieht. Und jetzt bringe ich sie so Stück für Stück wieder rein, nach dem Motto so, na schaut mal, das könnte für das Scenario XY ganz interessant sein. Und da wären beispielsweise genau diese Regions eigentlich dafür vorgesehen. Das ist natürlich völlig trivial, die über Tastatur-Shortcuts irgendwie während der Sendung zu setzen und auch zu sagen so, selbst wenn ich jetzt weiß, ok, jetzt ist die Region zu Ende, setze jetzt mal den Anfang der Region auf minus zwei Minuten ungefähr. Das könnte man alles relativ problemlos implementieren. Für die hast du dann wieder eine eigene Verwaltung, kannst die benennen, kannst die Einzelnen rausrendern beispielsweise, das ist auch gleich mitgebaut. So was auch sagen kannst, rende mir jetzt all Regions als Best-of irgendwie noch mal raus. Ja, das ist Up and Running, da muss man gar nichts mehr programmieren.
Während der Sendung geht es mir eigentlich wirklich mehr um Marker, die ich dann später vielleicht in solche Regions umwandeln würde. Aber ich will halt diese Marker schonmal unterscheiden. Ich will halt nicht alles in einer Liste haben, sondern ich will halt unterschiedliche Marker setzen. Ich will hier so ein iPad haben und irgendwie für jeden Fall sozusagen eine eigene Taste haben.
Ja, das ist jetzt kein wirklich neuer Feature-Request von dir, darüber haben wir schon häufiger gesprochen. Also das Datenmodell gibt es her, das kriegt man relativ einfach, meiner Meinung nach, in Lua implementiert. Das muss nur meiner machen, wie es immer so ist. Ja, mach doch mal selber was in Lua.
Vielleicht haben wir ja auch noch ein paar Lua-Experten, die Lust haben, sich da mal zu verdingen. Das ist ja durchaus eine verbreitete Skriptsprache. Das ist sozusagen jetzt eine Möglichkeit, Ultraschall zu helfen.
Genau, wir sind sowieso immer gerne auf Aufnahmefreudig noch für weitere Entwicklerinnen und Entwickler. Ich hab mal in den Chat schon jetzt vor ein paar Minuten und auch unser internes Board hier mal eine Visualisierung der Programmiersprachen, die wir in Reaper derzeit benutzen, alle mal rein implementiert. Aber im Wesentlichen läuft es eigentlich immer hinaus auf entweder C++ oder Lua. Das sind eigentlich so die beiden großen Ebenen, die wir jetzt bespielen. So und wer sich da irgendwie kundig fühlt und irgendwie Bock hat, einfach mal im Sende-Gate Bescheid sagen oder mir eine Mail schreiben oder sowas. Bisher hatten wir immer durch jeden solcher Aufrufe genau einen neuen Entwickler dazu bekommen. Der war auch immer super. Und wenn das wieder so wird, dann ist alles gut. Gesundes Wachstum sagst du ja auch immer. Das hat was für sich. Ansonsten hätte ich noch ein bisschen was vorbereitet, was ein bisschen visueller ist, aber finde ich auch ganz gut so in die Show hier passen würde. Das ist nämlich so die visuelle Komponente, also was das eigentliche User-Interface angeht. Besteht da Interesse oder habt ihr da eher nicht so Bock drauf?
Sind wir jetzt noch bei Ultraschall oder ein neues Thema?
Ja schon, aber es differenziert dann aus. Das ist hier Gui-Redesign in den Knubbeln, den kannst du mal aufmachen. Da versteckt sich noch so einiges. Und da versteckt sich noch mehr. Jetzt gehts ja ab hier.
Ja, hau rein, wir haben ja sonst keine Themen. Das war doch nur ein Spaß.
Kein Platz hier für Witze.
Ich hatte ja eben etwas salopp gesagt, hier so die beste Podcast-Software. Und das zweite Ziel, was ich hatte, wie gesagt, man braucht ja irgendwie Ziele im Leben, war auf jeden Fall die bestaussehnste DAW-Software zu verantworten. Weil man kann halt alles umskinnen in Reaper, wie damals halt bei Windamp auch schon. Und dann hab ich mir also gesagt, so Leute, jetzt machen wir das Ganze mal in schön. Das hat mich auch schon relativ früh umgetrieben. Und ich war auch schon immer so ein bisschen GUI-mäßig unterwegs, das hat mich schon immer sehr interessiert. Und hab mir da so tüchtig Mühe gegeben. Und irgendwann kommt man aber dann zu so einem Punkt, wo man dann so merkt, okay, das ist schon irgendwie ganz gut, aber alles andere ist trotzdem irgendwie geiler. Also wenn man so bei anderer Software dann vorbeiguckt, hat man schon irgendwie so den Eindruck, naja, das ist irgendwie alles runder und besser und so weiter. Dann gibt es, glaube ich, so vier verschiedene Phasen, wie man damit umgeht. Ich bin ja Kommunikationswissenschaftler, und als solcher versucht man immer gleich in irgendwelchen Modellen und Theorien zu arbeiten. Und so die erste Phase ist halt die des Verdrängens. Das heißt also, nein, meine ist die schönste, und alles andere taucht nichts. Die zweite Phase ist einfach der Abschied. Das heißt, ich schaff's halt nicht, ich bin schlechter, ich muss mir irgendwie andere Hobbys suchen. Die dritte Phase, und das ist das, was ich in den letzten zehn Jahren eigentlich immer mache, ist kopieren und nacheffen. Das heißt, du siehst irgendwie etwas, was du geil und cool findest, und versuchst das irgendwie so nachzubauen, dass das dann so hinkommt.
Great artist's deal.
Was ich jetzt vom Vierteljahr begonnen habe, ist die vierte Phase, nämlich das Verstehen. Also wirklich mal reingehen und sagen, ich will jetzt nicht mehr Cut and Paste machen, was Design angeht, sondern ich will wirklich mal runter in den Maschinenraum und gucken, warum ist etwas besser? Warum ist eigentlich etwas besser? Und was macht es eigentlich wirklich zu einer besseren Nutzeroberfläche? Und warum gefällt mir dieser Button dort so viel besser als der andere Button? Und dann, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, habe ich mich dann doch in einen mittleren Wahn hineingesteigert. Es gab also wirklich...
Das kennen wir durchaus, würde ich sagen.
Mittlere Wahne kennen wir nicht.
Also vom Programmieren kenne ich das auch, aber es gab also wirklich, ich habe mal wirklich zwei Stunden auf eine 5-Pixel-Gruppe gestartet. Um also wirklich durch den Screen hindurch zu sehen und zu gucken, was genau klappt jetzt hier eigentlich nicht. Also es ging irgendwann auch so etwas in einen ungesunden Bereich vielleicht ein bisschen rein. Der Punkt ist, dass ich dann aber auch mir mal sehr systematisch angeguckt habe, was machen die anderen? Das ist das, was ich jetzt hier in den Chat mal abgeworfen habe. Das sind jetzt einfach mal so die großen DAWs mal nebeneinander gehalten. Und bei einigen sieht man sofort, dass das irgendwie ein gigantischer Clusterfuck ist. Weil ich also irgendwie 120 Buttons und GUI-Elemente habe und sowas. Und dem gegenüber sieht man auf den ersten Blick jetzt schon, dass die Ultraschall-Geschichte mit Abstand die minimalistischste ist.
Kannst du ganz normal den Reigen hier kurz erläutern? Das ist ADUR.
Ihr findet das auch in den Show Notes. Und es steht auch ein drunter. Links oben ist ADUR. Open Source und eigentlich so das Reaper der Open Source-Welt. ADUR nehme ich sehr, sehr ernst. So eine interessante Variante wäre auch nochmal zu gucken, ob das ganze Ultraschall-System auf ADUR zu übertragen. Der Punkt ist aber, dass sie gerade auf dem Mac schon noch echt immer richtig wonky sehen. Wenn man zum ersten Mal startet, muss man irgendwie durch so einen Configuration Wizard durch, wo ich denke, das kannst du niemanden verkaufen. Das ist unmöglich. Also da müsste man nochmal sehr tief reinsteigen. Aber vom Grundkern her ist das glaube ich ziemlich gesund. So, oben rechts haben wir dann Logic Pro X. Letzte Version. Also das rechts unten Flaggschiff von Apple.
Was schon ziemlich aufgeräumt ist im Vergleich.
Ja, wir kommen gleich dazu.
Im Vergleich zu vor zehn Jahren. Da hättest du es mal sehen sollen.
Im Vergleich zu den anderen Kandidaten hier.
So, und dann eine Zeile tiefer. Da haben wir Hindenburg.
Das hab ich ja noch nie gehört.
Hindenburg ist sicherlich auch ein sehr, sehr...
Was für ein fatalistischer Projektname.
Die haben auch wirklich die Absturzsequenz bei sich auf der Homepage drauf.
Also es sieht auf jeden Fall ganz schick aus, muss man mal sagen.
Hindenburg ist auch die einzige Software, die explizit für denselben Use-Case gedacht ist. Das ist etwas, was sich explizit an Radiojournalisten wendet und wirklich eine ganze Menge Kessafeatures hat, die so auch nirgendswo anders zu finden ist. Zum Beispiel haben sie jetzt auch als einzige Lautnis mit drin, was wir halt alles mit auf Phonik machen. Das ist da sozusagen mit eingebaut. Kapitelmarkeneditor und so weiter ist da auch schon relativ sophisticated. Die können halt auch dieses MP4 von Apple rausspucken, etc. Ist aber auch so eine, hier oben die Icon-Leiste, siehst du schon, hier so Cross-Plattform Voodoo mit Diskettensymbol und so. Das geht auch schöner. Cut-Schere.
Und sie nehmen halt auch mal so lockere 350 Ocken dafür. Und das ist dann halt auch eine Geschichte, wo man, finde ich, so in die Amateurbereite nicht so richtig mit reinkommt. So, dann haben wir Audacity, was halt von der GUI... Ja, das ist Stand vor zwei Wochen.
Das ist doch das System 7.
Ja, es ist ein Drama, das gerade für Audacity niemand findet, der da einfach mal Design drüber schüttet. Aber so kompliziert ist es dann auch nicht. Na, wir kommen gleich dazu. Dann haben wir hier Adobe Audition, was innerhalb von so GUI-Design-Kreisen, gerade so als der Heilige Gral gehandelt wird. Die haben halt jetzt sehr, sehr flat, sehr reduziert die ganze Sache angegangen, auch sehr dunkel. Ja, so alle Themes außer Audacity sind eigentlich dunkel, so. Also dunkel ist einfach gerade so im GUI-Design das Ding der Stunde. Aber das ist auch wirklich pro. Das heißt also, ich hab da jetzt zweimal aus Gründen ein bisschen mitgearbeitet und das ist schon echt so Photoshop für Audio. Es gibt praktisch nichts, was du damit nicht machen kannst, aber die Lernkurve ist echt nochmal richtig, richtig steil. So, dann haben wir da daneben halt jetzt aktuell Ultraschall 2.1. Also weit so klar. Aber da sieht man auch schon, dass da echt nur ein Zehntel der GUI-Elemente unterwegs ist gegenüber den ganzen anderen, was einfach eine bewusste Entscheidung auch ist. Keine Redundanz und keine Sachen, die man nicht braucht für Podcasting. Und dann haben wir unten links das Garage Band.
Die Holzleisten.
Viel Ähnlichkeit dazu. Die haben wir noch in der Scoiomorfer Holzleise.
Die haben damals die Entwickler, als sie die einbauen sollten, die haben alle gekotzt. Also ich war ja mal bei der Bude dabei und die haben wirklich alle gekotzt. Die wollten diese Holzleisten nicht haben, aber sie mussten sie dann doch einbauen.
Versteh ich auch nicht so ganz. Und unten rechts dann halt Ableton Live.
Und warum hast du nicht das Original Reaper Theme mal reingeworfen?
Das stimmt, jetzt wo du es sagst, dann wär es nicht mehr symbolisch gewesen, aber das wäre eigentlich auch immer hilfreich. Ja, so, jetzt, Tim hat ja gerade eben schon gesagt, naja, hier das...
Logic?
Das Logic, das sieht doch schon ganz manierlich aus. Das dachte ich auch immer. Das war so ein bisschen auch mein Design-Target, zu sagen, so, bei Apple kann das nicht so verkehrt sein. Daran orientieren wir uns mal. So, und jetzt werfe ich euch aber mal was in den Chat, wo man dann plötzlich sieht, dass die Matrix in sich zusammenbricht. Ich hab mich dann also wirklich mal zwei Tage lang nur mit Logic-Design beschäftigt, und zwar mal explizit mit Button-Design. Weil für mich also die Frage war, wie mache ich jetzt eigentlich diese Ultraschall-Buttons? Und das sind jetzt mal auf einer Folie zusammengetragen, die verschiedenen Button-Konzepte, die alle gleichzeitig in ein und derselben GUI sich bewegen.
Die Musiktastatur kommt übrigens auch von GarageBand. Ist das das Original-Design von der Version 2?
Egal in welches Detail man guckt, es ist eigentlich alles schlampig. Und da habe ich mich gefragt, John Alphas, was ist los? Also wenn wir jetzt mal in den verschiedenen Zeilen durchgehen. Die oberste Zeile, das ist jetzt also die Playbar. Da haben wir so als Effekt, das ist erstmal ein tief versetzter Button, der so eigentlich schon so planaufliegt und den man nur noch runterdrücken kann. Da drüber ist so ein Glossy-Effekt. Klar kann man machen, ist nicht mehr so ganz heutig, aber ist halt so. Ok, so, aber jetzt gucken wir uns mal diese eingedrückten States an, und zwar von dem Mixer-Regler und dann rechts wiederum dieses Pinker. Das heißt also, manche der Bereiche sind, wenn sie gedrückt sind, farblich hinterlegt. Andere Bereiche sind einfach irgendwie grau mit so einem ganz leichten Blauschimmer. Das ist überhaupt nicht konsistent. Dann diese Taktuhr. Warum ist das als einzigste jetzt eigentlich lila, wohingegen alles andere irgendwie grau ist an Element? Du gehst in eine Zeile tiefer, da hast du andere Buttons. Die haben nicht mehr diesen glossy Effekt. Im Grundprinzip des Buttonbaus ist schon was anderes. Die haben auch nicht mehr diesen leichten Emboss-Eingedrückteffekt.
Und die sind nicht arretiert.
Guck dir diese Arretierung an. Also geh nochmal ein bisschen nach links. Der erste ist arretiert, intelligent. Und alle anderen hängen... Die sind alle in derselben Zeile. Die anderen hängen alle zwei Pixel zu hoch. Warum? Das ist ja furchtbar. Ja, schon. Jetzt hast du links weiter... Links, links, links, das andere links. Danke. Mute-Buttons sind in der GUI mal zusammengefasst, dass sie so zusammenkleben und mal auseinandergezogen. Warum eigentlich? Wird man doch auch gar konsistent machen. Jetzt hast du plötzlich einen Bereich rechts daneben, wo du überhaupt keine Buttons mehr hast, sondern direkt anklickbare Flächen, die jetzt eher so iOS 8, iOS 9 mäßig irgendwo drin hängen.
So Toolbar, ähnliche Dinge.
Und je mehr du hinguckst, desto schrecklicher wird das Ganze. Diese Temple Hope IO-Beschriftung, diese ganze Widespace da, was macht dieser Button da an dieser Stelle? Wo nichts anderes in dieser Leiste da ist, was irgendeine Funktion hat. So, jetzt rechts rüber, diese Musiktastatur kommt aus einem komplett anderen Zeitalter, mit diesem hellen Grau.
Ja, und aus einem anderen Programm eben auch. Also es kommt aus Garage Band.
Und jetzt hier Tempelhof, guckt euch dieses rote Teil an. Wisst ihr noch, was dieses rote Teil da ist?
Oh ja, das ist so ein alter Closeback.
Das ist ein alter Closeback.
Mit Glossy.
Ja, was erlaube live? So geht das doch nicht. Ja, und oben rechts ist auch nochmal schön, da hab ich jetzt mal einfach einen Querschnitt gemacht. Das ist wie so ein Baumquerschnitt durch die Gui durch, wo man auch, wenn man reinzoomt, nochmal genau sieht, was für unterschiedliche Prinzipien bei Flächen auch angewandt werden. Ja, dass du also zum einen halt so einen leichten Shadow-Effekt hast, das nächste ist Flat, dann hast du eins durchgestrichelt, dann kommt wieder ein Flat, dann kommt eins mit so einem Tiger-Streifen-Modus. Da denkst du einfach nur, was soll denn das? So, und wenn das bei dir ein Flaggschiff ist, und wenn das bei Apple ist, was ist los mit dieser Welt? Und das ist jetzt auch jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt irgendwie Logic Pro X jetzt mal gerade irgendwie seit einem Monat draußen ist. Die haben diese Inkonsistenten jetzt die existensten Seiten.
Das ist aber noch das konsistenteste Logic, was es je gab. Also das muss man einfach mal sagen. Man muss halt sehen, wo es her kam. Also wenn du mal ein Logic 7 gesehen hast, dann ja.
Stellst du keine Fragen mehr.
So, und dem gegenüber kann ich jetzt...
Angeblich hat ja Steve Jobs, nachdem ihm gezeigt wurde, was man ihm da gekauft hat, das nur gesehen und sofort gesagt, iiiih, mach's weg! Dann war das Thema für ihn erst mal vergessen.
Ja, aber das, was wir sonst immer Microsoft vorwerfen, dass du auch jetzt irgendwie in Windows 10, wenn du drei Klicks machst, immer noch so in Windows 3.11-Anmutungen unterwegs bist, das ist jetzt hier bei Logic nicht wirklich viel besser. Warum jetzt hier auch bei Apple, die nun wirklich irgendwie Geld und Liebe und Attention und Detail anmalen sollten, die ja nicht jemanden rüber schicken, der sagt, ey, mach das mal einheitlich und zwar hier auf El-Kapitarn-Niveau. Das fand ich dann schon ein bisschen verstörend. Aber umso selbstbewusster kann ich jetzt sagen, die Ultraschall-Buttons, die sehen alle gleich aus. There's just one button.
Naja, also dieser Clear- und Render-Matrix, der sieht irgendwie ein bisschen anders aus als die anderen Buttons, die ich so sehe, da rechts unten.
Wo jetzt?
Rechts unten? Da, so, Clear-Render-Matrix. Achso, da hab ich leider keine Antwort.
Das ist das, was mich jetzt wirklich auch tödlich ankotzt. Es gibt Bereiche in Reaper, die kannst du nichts kennen. So, und die fallen jetzt natürlich je mehr du den Rest bei Distent machst, desto schlimmer fallen die Sachen halt raus. Naja, ich bin jetzt also hochgradig geschädigt, was Guis angeht. Ich bin jetzt also überall nur noch im 400%-Zoom unterwegs. Das ist kein schönes Leben, was man sich da einkauft.
Ja, ich bin auch sehr froh, dass meine Button-Kritik neulich da so umfangreich beantwortet wurde.
Wir hatten einfach das Grundproblem, dass die da schon immer waren, diese Buttons bei Ultraschall an der Seite, die aber offensichtlich von vielen Leuten als Buttons nie ernst genommen wurden. Wir hatten wirklich viele Rückmeldungen, da hab ich noch nie draufgeklickt. Das ist ja interessant, was der macht.
Das ist die Kernfunktion.
Die folgten vorher diesem Wandel von ScoioMorph zu Flat, was ja mit iOS jetzt wirklich sehr radikal habt ihr ja auch schon lange diskutiert.
Lange schon nicht mehr, aber...
Die Leute können jetzt Touch-Oberflächen, die brauchen keine Buttons mehr. Den reicht irgendwie, wenn deine Texte oder dein Symbol irgendwo einfach nur auf dem Hintergrund steht. Für Sonnenssoftware ist das offensichtlich nicht ausreichend gewesen. Jetzt haben wir es klarer wieder als Button definiert und das Feedback ist sehr viel besser. Jetzt muss man wieder gucken, dass man es irgendwann wieder runterfährt.
Ich bin nach wie vor der Meinung, dass ein Button aussehen sollte wie ein Button, damit man ihn auch gleich als Button erkennt.
Ich finde zum Beispiel Havareffekte wichtig. Hat Apple auch nicht drin, lustigerweise, bei Logic. Wenn ich über einem Button bin, mir schon mal angezeigt wird, hier passiert was, wenn ich jetzt auch drucken würde.
Du meinst auch so Tooltips und so ein Zeug?
Ja, die auch, aber vor allen Dingen auch einfach schon so ein leichtes Zeug, es wird ein bisschen was heller oder so was, es kommt irgendwie ein Glow-Effekt rein.
Da kommen sie ein bisschen ab durch ihre Touch-Devices, die einfach Havare nicht haben.
So ist es. Ja, also für mehr Liebe im GUI-Design. Wo ich dankbar wäre, wenn mir der Hörerinnen und Hörern nochmal einen Tipp geben können, mit was für einer Software man eigentlich heutzutage jetzt so ganze Batterien vernünftig designt bekommt. Weil ich habe den dringenden Verdacht, dass Photoshop da echt nicht mehr das Ding der Stunde ist. Du sagst jetzt wahrscheinlich Sketch, richtig? Okay, dann habe ich jetzt mal so ein paar Feature-Quests.
Benutzt unser Designer in der Firma auch.
Ob Sketch das kann oder nicht. Ich möchte zum Beispiel mal, also ich habe jetzt schon in Photoshop mit Templates gebaut, dass sämtliche Buttons in einem einzigen Dokument drin sind. Und wenn ich da eine Farbe ändere, wird das sofort auf alle Buttons durchwirkt. Das klappt schon alles ganz gut. Ich habe mich da schon ein bisschen professionalisiert. Aber kann ich zum Beispiel in Sketch Farben als Variablen anlegen? Dass ich also sage, dieser Bereich hier von dem Button oder dem Design-Element hat jetzt diesen Farbwert. Und ich kann ihn aber irgendwo überschreiben. Und er vererbt sich dann auch durch Ableitung runter. Das heißt also, wenn ich sage, das ist jetzt nur 18, und zwar nicht über Transparenz. Der ist nicht nur 80% Transparenz, sondern der ist meinetwegen 80% dunkler. Nicht nur transparent. Geht das?
Also ich kann überhaupt keinerlei, ich weiß, dass es genau so ist, Aussagen treffen über Sketch. Dafür habe ich einfach viel zu wenig Erfahrung. Das ist reines über die Schulter schauen und gezeigt bekommen Wissen und das ist auch noch sehr eingeschränkt. Am besten, ich sag gar nichts. Ich glaube aber, dass du da schon auf einer guten Reise bist. Weil so habe ich Leute damit arbeiten sehen. Also dass man da so eine Basisfarbe hat, die man an verschiedenen Stellen, du änderst sie an einer Stelle und blumm, auf einmal ist wirklich das komplette Dokument an allen Stellen entsprechend angepasst. Das ist schon genau eine dieser Sachen. Und Sketch hat ja auch, sagen wir mal, da. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Software eigentlich von Anfang an dafür gemacht war. Da kenne ich die Historie zu wenig. Ich habe so Sketch zwar relativ früh mal ein bisschen auf dem Radar gehabt, weil als ich auf der Suche war nach Vector-Software nur, mein Bedarf war ein ganz anderer. Also ich suchte einfach mal nach Tools, die uns halt von diesem Illustrator-Fluch befreien können. Und da ich auch Adobe-Software schon lange nicht mehr installiert habe, seitdem sie diesen ganzen Creative Cloud-Mumpeds angefangen haben, ist für mich Adobe einfach raus. Da spiele ich einfach nicht mit. Und deswegen ist halt mein ganzes Photoshop und eingeschränktes Illustrator-Wissen, was eigentlich schon immer ein Freehand-Wissen war, irgendwie so ein bisschen vor die Hunde gekommen. Und ich bin froh, dass es so im Pixel-Bereich mit Archon und Pixelmater gute Alternativen gibt mittlerweile und es gibt ja auch noch ein paar andere Kandidaten. Wie heißt diese andere Bude, die gerade jetzt so... Genau, diese Affinity-Geschichten habe ich noch nicht benutzt, aber es schwören ja auch einige drauf. Und im Vektor-Bereich tut sich halt mittlerweile auch einiges. Und Sketch war dann eben relativ früh da. Nur habe ich halt die Qualität der Software daran bemessen, wie gut sie mit Dateiformaten klarkamen. Also, das muss einfach alles geöffnet bekommen und SVG und PDF und so weiter gut parsen können. Da sind sie auch so schlecht nicht und machen auch im laufenden Meter Verbesserung. Aber was mir so ein bisschen entgangen ist, ist, wie schnell Sketch zu dem Tool wurde für User-Interface-Design. Also, nur mal so als Maßstab. Sogar Apple gibt Sketch-Dateien raus, damit man mit neuen User-Interface-Elementen rum experimentieren kann. Gut, das heißt jetzt nicht, das kann alles, was man will. Ich sag nur, alle Leute, die mit User-Interface arbeiten, die ich in letzter Zeit bewusst wahrgenommen habe, benutzen Sketch.
Ja, ich werd mir das, glaub ich, für die zwei mal angucken, wenn wieder alles anders muss.
Ja, vor allem kannst du halt auch wirklich so dieses verschiedene Varianten in allen Größen und so parallel entwickeln und dieser ganze Vererbungsklimb, der ist da dabei und das eben dann schnell exportieren in verschiedenen Varianten, dass es da halt irgendwie realisiert. Wird schon besser.
Heiko wirft mir übrigens gerade noch auf unserem Entwickler-Chat rein. Ich soll unbedingt noch bei sinnvollen Programmiersprachen bei uns Swift und C-Sharp erwähnen. Das heißt also, auch die sind gerne gesehen, wenn da jemand noch was beisteuern möchte. Ja, so sieht's aus. Aber läuft gut, Feedback im Moment ist Bombe. Ich wüsste immer noch mal gerne, wie viele Leute es eigentlich gerade installiert haben. Wir haben jetzt die 2 Einser, haben bei 300 Downloads. Das ist schon ganz ordentlich. Das meiste zur 1,3er waren wir so bei 800. Ob die dann auch wirklich alle damit Podcasts produzieren, ist immer eine andere Frage. Aber läuft.
Mein Name ist Tim Prydlawin.
Kein Wahlkampf, kein US-Präsidentschaftswahlkampf.
Nein, ich bin einfach glücklicher Kunde, sag ich jetzt mal so. Und Prydlawin kommt auch wieder zurück.
Ich sag's dir. Du hast so den Schneid abgekauft im letzten Jahr.
Geht gar nicht mehr.
Wir haben es, glaube ich, aber auch einfach ein bisschen einfacher, weil die Leute... Ich glaube, du hast einfach ein strategisches Problem. Weil Prydlawin halt einfach so diese Metadaten-Publizierschiene ist. Einfach so maximal unsexy. Du hast irgendwie zwei Stunden ins Mikrofon geredet, oder vier Stunden, oder acht Stunden. Und dann hast du noch diesen Kreativprozess des Schneidens hinter dich gebracht. Und dann musst du auch noch publishen. Also wir sind da psychologisch einfach den Schritt davor, wo die Leute einfach noch frischer und mit mehr Dynamik am Produkt sind.
Dafür habe ich sehr viel mehr User-Interaktionen. Von daher ist die Exposure mannigfaltig.
Aber eigentlich wäre doch dein perfektes Produkt eins, was sich komplett unsichtbar macht und so One-Button-mäßig funktioniert. Dann wäre doch eigentlich der perfekte Zustand von Potluff erfüllt. Also möglichst wenig Beschäftigung damit, möglichst wenig zusätzliche Arbeitsschritte. Dein Mission-Statement ist eigentlich, dich selber überflüssig zu machen an der Stelle. Und das ist halt bei uns ein bisschen anders, weil wir eher so versuchen, ein Kreativwerkzeug den Leuten noch zu geben. Oh, jetzt guckt er ganz grimmig. Ich glaube, das hat ihm jetzt nicht gefallen, diese Interpretation.
Also...
Ich verstehe... Mir würde es im Traum nicht einfallen, Potluff Publisher nicht als Kreativwerkzeug. Also das ist ein... Das ist genau das, was es ist. Also das ist sozusagen ein Werkzeug für Kreative.
Ja, aber du wirst nicht selber im WordPress Backend kreativ. Sondern das ist nur ein...
Ja, da sind wir leider auch noch nicht so weit vorangeschritten, wie wir sein sollten. Mir würde da eine Menge einfallen, wie man da sich kreativ ausleben kann. Egal, das müssen wir jetzt auch gar nicht weiter diskutieren. Auf jeden Fall Ultraschall ist toll und ihr müsst das alle installieren. Wenn ihr mit irgendwas andere aufzeichnet, dann habt ihr irgendwie, weiß ich nicht.
Schaut euch meine einschlägigen Screencasts an.
Ja genau, den kannst du nochmal hinterher. Ist ja da auch schon in deiner Liste drin. Du hast ja einen langen Screencast aufgenommen. Mehrere langere Screencasts aufgenommen.
Ja, die habe ich jetzt auch alle lange vor mir hergeschoben, weil das ist auch echt mal harte Arbeit, so eineinhalb Stunden Screencasts rauszugeben. Also drei Stück, die ich noch einhintelle, die schauen uns in den Chat. Das erste ist der, der finde ich wirklich rund ist vom Kongress. So einmal in einer Stunde quer durchs System, dass man mal so alle Komponenten gesehen hat. Dann habe ich einen gemacht jetzt nur über Storyboard, wo man nochmal sieht, wie das genau funktioniert und einen, auf den ich ein klein bisschen stolz bin, wo es wirklich nur um Routing geht. Das heißt also die ganzen Situationen, wo welches Monitoring ist, wo welche Fehler auftreten, wenn ich plötzlich Doppelungen habe, wenn ich Hall drin habe, wenn ich gar nichts höre, wie gehe ich das ins Streaming raus, wie mache ich eine Skype N-1 schalte. Also wirklich in einer knapp zwei Stunden sind es geworden, wirklich das Thema mal sowohl systematisch als auch theoretisch, als auch dann am praktischen Modell mit drei unterschiedlichen Soundinterfaces, die alle unterschiedliche Logik mitbringen. Das glaube ich, das hat einen gewissen Bestand, so die Screencast-Folge. Wenn das mit Ultraschall alles vor die Hunde geht, diese Folge wird überdauern, weil das ist auch unabhängig davon, welche DAW ich einsetze.
Gut, ich glaube, das Podcast-Thema können wir jetzt erstmal abschließen. Und jetzt haben wir hier Wheel of Fortune. Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher.
Siri, wollt ihr was zu Siri hören?
Du kannst dir mal was rausgreifen.
Was zu Siri? Also ich hab... Genau, ich bin bei TV OS. Und zwar, da gab's jetzt von dieser Gruber, John Gruber von Daring Fireball.
Dieser John Gruber.
Der macht ja auch einen Podcast, ne? Und da gab's vor zwei oder drei Folgen gab's eine Folge, da hatte er, warte mal, ich hau das jetzt erst mal in den Chat. Da hatte er Craig Federighi und wie heißt der andere? Eddy Cue da und die haben so ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, wie denn das ist mit Siri und der Apple TV und so. Und dann sind sie genau auf den Painpoint gekommen, was ich sehr spannend fand. Nämlich, dass wenn man jetzt nicht in Amerika wohnt, man wahrscheinlich auch nicht Englisch spricht, man aber trotzdem Inhalte sehen will, die englisch bezeichnet sind. Die Folge heißt auch interessanterweise They Might Be Giants With A Spanish Accent. Es gibt also das Problem, Leute sind nicht Native Speaker und fangen jetzt an, englische Worte komisch auszusprechen. Und Siri muss das abkönnen. Also, Apple hat es tatsächlich auf dem Schirm. Und dann hab ich mir gedacht, naja, gut, dann installierst du jetzt doch mal die Beta-Version auf deiner Apple TV und probierst es mal aus.
Und dann hast du gesagt, ich hätt gern was von Michael Jackson.
Ja, und dann erstmal einfach anfangen. Erstmal deutsche Sachen, die Ärzte, kein Problem. Geht doch relativ schnell. Andere Sachen, dann mal was Englisches. Jethro Tull. Da hat er sofort gemacht. Okay, dann. Was hatte ich denn noch? Ach ja, was Gemischtes. Farin Urlaub Racing Team. Sind zwei deutsche und zwei englische Worte. Kein Problem, hat er gemacht, ohne Probleme. Dann dachte ich mir, naja, machst mal was Abseitiges. Den bayerisch-diatonischen Jodel-Wahnsinn. Wer es noch nicht kennt, mal reinhören. Das ist super.
Bayerisch-diatonischer Jodel-Wahnsinn.
Bayerisch-diatonischer Jodel-Wahnsinn. Gibt's leider nicht mehr.
Also wundert euch bei Roddy ein paar gar nicht mehr.
Doch, die muss man mal gehört haben. Die sind lustig. Irgendwann wird man verzweifelt und denkt, man muss den doch jetzt aushebeln können. Das nächste, was ich versucht habe, ist Heavy Metal Bands, die diese komischen, wie heißen sie, Heavy Metal Diacritics benutzen. Zum Beispiel Motorhead hat er hingekriegt. Und noch besser, Mödli Krüe.
Ach ja, die gehen ja einmal quer durch Unicode durch, um eine Freie Tomäne zu finden.
Hat er auch hingekriegt. Da dachte ich so, was geht denn jetzt ab?
Du hast es noch besiegt.
Wie spricht man das eigentlich wirklich?
Mödli Krüe, also die verteilte oder zusammengesetzte Krüe halt.
Was ist das von Remodli? Was?
Das wird doch ganz anders geschrieben, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, wie wird das überhaupt geschrieben.
Mödli Krüe, M-Ö-T-L-E-Y-C-R-Ü-E. Nicht, dass ich Musik von denen kennen würde, aber der Name, der bleibt irgendwie hängen.
Modli Krüe angeblich. Zusammengewürfelter Haufen heißt das.
Zusammengewürfelter Haufen, ja. So wie die Buchstaben in dem Wort. Aber wie gesagt, das hat er hingekriegt.
Können wir uns auch so nennen?
Können wir uns theoretisch schon. Und dann habe ich ihn mit einer Band ausgehebelt, wo ich dachte, das ist doch jetzt die Band, die müsste Apple doch eigentlich hinkriegen. Also die Band, die Apple jedem aufs Device geschoben hat. Viele Leute das nicht haben wollen, aber wenn man U2 sagt, dann findet er nur YouTube. Naja, und dann gibt es halt noch diesen einen Film. Ja, U2 geht.
Aber findet er nicht?
Doch, findet er dann auch YouTube.
Aber es sagt doch niemand U2, oder?
Nein, sagt es niemand. Aber...
Okay, und was noch?
Ja, und der King war natürlich, das hab ich gestern gleich noch tweeten müssen, das ist dieser Film Koreaner Katzi. Und da ist das Geile, also Siri ist relativ schnell geworden und du merkst so, wie er während du noch sprichst schon anfängt zu versuchen, die Worte zusammenzubauen. Und zwischendrin hat er's, er hat's richtig. Und dann kommt doch Koreaners Katzi raus.
Koreaners Katzi.
Ja, aber es ist ja auch, also ich guck grad in der Wikipedia, die Lautschritte.
Was ist denn das, Koreaners Katzi?
Keine Ahnung, also ich hab keine Band, die so heißt.
Ja, aber kam da was bei raus?
Nee.
Wie würdest du das, würdest du den Film aussprechen?
Du musst den Soundcheck mal hören, da wird das mehrmals erwähnt, das Wort. Da meint auf Twitter auch gleich einer, na toll, jetzt muss ich erstmal Philip Glass hören.
Und hast du auch bei Jethro Tal, hast du es auch mal mit falschem TH probiert? Also irgendwie oder irgendwie so, weißt du, so Sauerkraut-Englisch.
Nee, das hab ich allerdings nicht.
Weil wir sind jetzt schon einigermaßen geschult im Englisch, auch wenn das wahrscheinlich immer noch nach Sauerkraut-Englisch klingt, aber es gibt ja durchaus noch Leute mit weniger Übung, sagen wir mal.
Na ja, weiß nicht, also die Franzosen sind da glaube ich ganz besonders toll. Also da werden sie ein Problem haben, wenn die anfangen mit Jettro Tüel, dann ist es halt irgendwie...
Und hat der John Gruber dem beiden noch irgendwelche anderen interessanten Details aus der Nase gelockt?
Nee, das war reiner Marketing-Krasch.
Nee, so spannend war es dann nicht.
Es ist wirklich so...
Also Sellout, Peek John Gruber und so?
Ach naja, ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht wirklich uninteressant, aber das ist so dieses... Das ist einfach keine Ahnung. Das hat mich nicht aggressiv gemacht, aber glücklich auch nicht. Weil da werden halt einfach viele Fragen nicht gefragt, die man einfach mal fragen muss. Und ich meine, das ist jetzt schon das dritte Mal, dass er da irgendwie die Executives hat.
Echt?
Aber glaubst du, er hat mal irgendeinen von denen mal mit diesem App-Store-Desaster konfrontiert? Einfach mal so die allererste Frage, die mir in den Kopf kommen würde, aber nüscht. Ich meine, ist ja auch klar. Ich meine, die sagen, wie wär's, wenn ich in deinen Podcast komme? Du weißt, was das für deinen Podcast bedeutet. Aber dafür haben wir uns auch ein bisschen lieb. Das war so Geschwätz.
Würde mich mal interessieren, wie so die Aufnahmesituation ist, welches Papier da unterzeichnet werden muss.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie da ein Papier unterzeichnen. Du weißt, welche Fehler du nicht machen musst, sonst warst du das letzte Mal.
Aber wenn ich die einmal da hätte?
Dann willst du die auch noch mal haben.
Der hat sie auch schon dreimal gehabt. Also so richtig neue Erkenntnisse kommen da nicht rüber. Das mit der Bluetooth-Tastatur funktioniert übrigens auch. Man kann sie tatsächlich pairen und sie tut dann auch was. Was jetzt auch kein spannendes Feature ist, aber irgendwie fehlte das.
Die sind auf jeden Fall gut dran, glaube ich, an diesem Apple TV. Die sind schon dabei, das noch zu verbessern.
Ja, er meinte in dem Interview, dass mit der Tastatur eigentlich von Anfang an geplant war, nur hatten sie es halt zu 1.0 nicht hingekriegt. Ja, nun, dann ist das halt so. Aber Siri ist schon deutlich besser geworden. Das muss man neidlos anerkennen, das funktioniert jetzt.
Es ist ja ohnehin die Zeit der künstlichen Intelligenzen, haben wir ja gerade auch gemerkt. Irgendjemand twitterte gerade, sein Opa hätte ihm gesagt, man müsste sich über künstliche Intelligenz keine Sorgen machen, solange sie nicht im Go siegen.
Ja, das Thema ist durch.
Und genau das hat wohl jetzt gerade stattgefunden. Ich weiß nicht, ich hab das nicht live verfolgt, hab so die Aufzeichnung mir so ein bisschen angeschaut.
Das ist Koreaners Katzi.
Das hat auch jetzt keiner gesehen.
Ja, Entschuldigung, da war jetzt ein Bild von wie heißt der Kim Jong Un, der so ziemlich die fetteste Katze der Welt in der Hand hält.
Ja, soll ich nochmal anfangen?
Also, Google, künstliche Intelligenz.
Genau, Google, genau. Also Google treibt seinen Nerd-Wahnsinn weiter voran und hat wohl seine KI-Truppe unter anderem dazu ermuntert, doch mal das mit dem Go zu machen. Ich meine, dass die Computer im Schach mittlerweile eigentlich alles wegfegen, ist nicht wirklich so eine Neuigkeit. Aber jetzt geht das wohl auch mit Go. Wer sich jetzt eine intensive und einsichtsreiche Diskussion von uns zum Thema Go erwartet, muss leider nachhaltig enttäuscht werden, weil wenn ich das so richtig sehe, haben wir alle auch nur einen Schimmer von Go, oder?
Ich habe mal versucht, es zu lernen und mein Skillset dazu erweitern.
Bist du jetzt der Experte in dieser Woche?
Ich habe es auch mal versucht zu lernen, so weit, so gut.
Und ich meinte, auf Regellücken gestoßen zu sein. Ich habe also zwei oder drei Grundlagentexte gelesen, habe immer wieder Partien gespielt und in denen kamen immer wieder dieselben Fragen auf, die ich in diesem Regelwerk nicht beantwortet glaubte. Was wahrscheinlich eine Fehlwahrnehmung war, weil das Spiel nur gut durchdefiniert ist. Und es ist maximal unwahrscheinlich, dass da wirklich Regellücken drin existieren. So komplex ist es dann auch nicht. Was aber vielleicht eher was darüber sagt, ist es vielleicht kein guter Gedanke, wenn sich Anfänger versuchen, gegenseitig beizubringen, sondern da braucht man einen Wizard schon für. Und das Zweite ist, dass mal wieder, glaube ich so, die Lehrbuch-Fraktion einfach mal beliebig scheiße ist. Also von daher war dann meine Go-Experience dann irgendwann so nach, weiß ich nicht, 15, 20 Partien dann auch irgendwie beendet, weil ich irgendwie den Eindruck hatte, okay, ich kriege jetzt hier so meinen Hirn nicht drum, was jetzt hier die besten Strategien sind, weil es müsste doch...
Also man kann glaube ich so viel sagen, Go ist ein sehr facettenreiches Spiel, obwohl es auf sehr, sehr, sehr einfachen Prinzipien basiert. Man spielt mit schwarzen und weißen Steinen auf so einem Gitterbrett mit keiner Ahnung wie viel Feldern und man muss sie irgendwo hinlegen. Und je nachdem wo denn die liegen, darf der andere die einsammeln oder so.
Also eigentlich sind die Regeln ja sehr viel simpler als bei Schach. Die Problematik, die bei Go hinzukommt, ist einfach, dass das Feld zu viel größer ist. Das heißt, das ist exponentiell, oder das ist mehr als exponentiell, das Wachstum der zu berechnenden Pfade. Das sind so Podcast-Worte für die Ewigkeit. Also ein Go-Spiel irgendwie jetzt auf dem Schachbrett zu berechnen wäre sehr viel einfacher als auf dem 64 x 64er-Gobrett. Es ist auch echt schon zehn Jahre her, dass ich mich damit beschäftigt habe. Von daher ist jetzt auch wieder alles gefährliches.
Die hat die Wikipedia schon offen eigentlich.
Kinder aus 19 horizontalen und 19 vertikalen Linien, die 361 Schnittpunkte bilden.
Genau. Und beim Schach hast du halt 8, 8 x 8. Und das ist eigentlich so der Hauptzerstörerische Faktor beim Go. Ansonsten ist Schach definitiv komplizierter. Du hast natürlich beim Go mehr Steine, das kommt auch noch hinzu, die ja auch irgendwie ständig auswuchern und so was und halt zueinander in Beziehung stehen oder auch nicht. Aber ich würde jetzt, wie gesagt, wirklich absolut ungesundes Halbwissen vermuten. Der Hauptpunkt ist eigentlich die Größe des Brettes, warum es länger gedauert hat.
Auf jeden Fall hat Google es geschafft, da jetzt eine KI zu entwickeln, mal wieder auf Basis von diesen Deep Learning Algorithmen.
Basiert das auf TensorFlow?
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich habe mich auch noch nicht so richtig reingelesen. Ich habe gerade mal so ein bisschen durch dieses Video geskippt, die sie abgeliefert haben, diesen horrendschlechten Stream mit permanenten Audioaussetzern zum Heulen. Das scheinen sie irgendwie noch nicht hinzubekommen. Da müssten sie vielleicht auch bei ihrer Human-Intelligenz noch mal ein bisschen nachlegen. Auf jeden Fall haben sie das fett gefeatured, das ist wohl auch ganz ordentlich wahrgenommen worden. Sie haben jetzt so einen der Großmeister abgeledert und jetzt geht es wohl nochmal in weitere vier Kämpfe. Wer nach fünfen gewonnen hat, ist überhaupt der King. Und so wie sich das abzeichnet, kriegen sie jetzt den Rest vielleicht auch noch eingesackt. Das werden wir dann sehen. Es wurde gelobt, wie gut die Maschine gespielt hat. Nicht nur, weil sie gewonnen hat am Ende. Also gewonnen, weil der Großmeister dann aufgegeben hat. Sondern, weil das wohl auch eine sehr ansehnliche Partie sei. Da bin ich natürlich jetzt noch sehr weit entfernt, das auch nur im Ansatz nachfühlen zu können. Ich hab jetzt auch nicht die Musse, mir so ein 3-Stunden-Spiel nochmal im Detail anzuschauen. Aber vielleicht hat das ja von euch irgendjemand gemacht. Gibt ja eine ganze Menge Go-Fans in Nerd-Kreisen. Was ist daran bemerkenswert? Ich hab so den Eindruck, dass diese Deep Learning-Nummer jetzt einfach in den nächsten Jahren alles umreißen, was bisher noch sakrosank war. Ich hab so den Eindruck, in 5 Jahren ist das Thema einfach mal durch. Man wird, glaub ich, mit diesen Algorithmen alle nennenswerten, grosseren Probleme in irgendeiner Form begleitet bekommen.
Jein. Du hast dir einen sehr schönen CRE zugemacht. Der Punkt ist, dass wir hier aber jetzt auch bei dieser Go-Geschichte immer noch von Narrow Intelligence sprechen. Das heißt also, wir haben jetzt hier so ein, nehmen wir mal an, es war ein neuronales Netz, was jetzt also bis zur absoluten Perfektion sich selbst darauf trainiert hat, Go zu spielen. Dann kann es jetzt trotzdem noch keinen Zug Schach. Und das wäre jetzt beispielsweise auch völlig außerstande, das, was du gerade reingebracht hast, so etwas wie die Schönheit der Partie selber zu bewerten. Um irgendwie so was wie eine Dimension eines interessanten Spielzuges zu haben. Dafür habe ich wirklich zu wenig Go gespielt, aber beim Schach ist es schon so, dass du ja durchaus auch so eine gewisse Ästhetik in so ein Spiel irgendwie reinbringen kannst. Darüber kann jetzt aber dieser Algorithmus exakt mal 0,0 aussagen. Da bräuchst du wieder einen anderen Algorithmus drauf trainieren, der also die Schönheit von Go-Partien klassifizieren kann. Das würde auch funktionieren, der kann aber wieder selber nicht Go spielen. Das heißt also, was wir definitiv in den nächsten fünf Jahren sehen werden, ist einen absoluten Durchmarsch der Narrow Intelligence, aber deshalb werden wir noch lange keine General Intelligence haben, also General Artificial Intelligence. Habt ihr hier in der Freak Show schon mal diesen Wait But Why Blog-Artikel dazu über KI besprochen? Angesprochen?
Ich hab den irgendwann angefangen zu lesen und bin dann aber ausgestiegen, weil es ein bisschen heftig war.
Das ist überhaupt nicht heftig. Das sind die besten 120 Minuten, die man im Jahr 2016 investieren kann. Das ist mein bitterster Ernst. Ich hab vor einem Jahr mit...
Du hast durchaus das Recht, aber das ist zu lang für einen Klogang.
Ja, das ist es. Du musst zwei Stunden investieren. Aber danach hast du eine Ahnung von dem, was mit dieser Welt eigentlich so passieren wird demnächst. Zumindest ist es eine sehr valide Annahme von dem, was mit dieser Welt passieren wird. Der ist also so voll gepackt von faszinierenden Erkenntnissen und Methoden. Ich will den jetzt hier nicht repräzieren. Ich hab schon mal einen Vortrag darüber gehalten. Bitte, bitte, bitte investiert diese zwei Stunden in eurem Leben. Lest den durch. Selbst wenn ihr es nach Scheiße findet und ihr dacht, es wird alles ganz anders kommen. Der ist alleine so clever und so intelligent und so geistreich geschrieben. Das ist also das Beste, was ihr eurem Gehirn antun könnt. Das ist Zweiteiler.
War das nicht der, der auch über diesen Great-Filter und dieses Zeug geschieht?
Genau, das Fermi-Paradox-Geneuheit.
Das Fermi-Paradox-Geneuheit. Also wenn der ein Thema abgrast, dann ist es abgegrast.
Der Punkt ist, ich meine, das ist ja eine kurzweil technologische Singularität. Singularität sagt ja eben, wir können es nicht abgrasen. Das heißt also, wir können jetzt nur Annahmen bis zum Tag X machen und ab da, ja, the rest is up to God. Oder dem, was wir dann Gott nennen ab dem Moment. Das heißt also, das Abgrasen geht eben gerade nicht. Superartikel, und da wird nämlich genau auch diese Unterscheidung zwischen Narrow Intelligence und General Intelligence und Superintelligence halt gemacht. Und Narrow Intelligence ist einfach wahnsinnig gut in irgendeiner Aufgabe und aber auch nur in dieser. Und General Intelligence ist halt so was wie, ich bin nahezu allem gut. Weil es ist nur noch eine Ressourcenfrage, ob ich, wo drin ich überall gut bin. Und erst dadurch kann dann auch so ein Spark von Gesundheit reinkommen. Was ich zum Beispiel liebe, ist dieses Bild mit dem U-Bahnhof. Warst du da schon? Bist du schon darüber weggescrollt? Ich hatte gerade letzte Woche eine vehemente Debatte mit einem sehr gut befreundeten Pärchen. Die sind beides Geisteswissenschaftler. Und die haben immer diese Perspektive. Ja, aber guck dir doch Siri an, wenn ich dir irgendwas frage, was jetzt irgendwie halt auch nur annähernd irgendwie so philosophisch ist. Da kommt doch nie irgendwas bei rum. Das sind doch alles nur intelligentere Schachcomputer. Ja, und ja, exakt so ist es. Aber hier in diesem Artikel wird die Situation verglichen mit wir stehen jetzt als Menschheit in einem U-Bahnhof oder S-Bahn, sagen wir mal, macht mehr Sinn, überirdisch. Und wir gucken nach, vor uns ist also so der das S-Bahn-Gleis der künstlichen Intelligenz. Und da fährt jetzt also der KI-Zug. Kommt auf uns zu und fährt an uns vorbei und fährt irgendwann weg. Und je weiter der nach vorne fährt, desto intelligenter wird quasi so die Gesamt-KI sein. Und wir sind jetzt im Moment in der entspannten Situation. Wir stehen auf dem S-Bahn-Bahnhof, gucken nach links und sehen, der KI-Zug, der ist so zwei Kilometer entfernt. Und mein Gott, ist der weit weg! Mein Gott, ist das primitiv! Na jetzt können sie go, na super! Zehn Jahre hat es gebraucht, nachdem sie schon Schach konnten. Das kann ich doch nicht ernst nehmen. Aber durch die optische Verkrümmung ist es so, dass selbst wenn der halt 100 Meter von uns entfährt ist, wird er immer noch ziemlich weit aussehen. Und dann wird aber irgendwann der Moment kommen, wo er mit einem Affenzahn an uns vorbeifährt, und von da ab ist er dann binnen weniger Sekunden einen Kilometer rechts. Genau, exakter Effekt. Und bis dahin wird die Menschheit stehen, auf diesem S-Bahnhof und wird sagen, guck mal, der Zug ist total weit entfernt. Und die eigentlichen Durchbrüche werden innerhalb von Tagen passieren. Es sind Tage, wo der KI-Zug durch unsere S-Bahnstation durchrauschen wird. Das ist meine feste Überzeugung. Viel von dem, was wir jetzt tun, ist völlig überflüssig. The good news is, wir sind dabei. Wir werden es erleben. Wir sind die Generation, die den Fun hat. Oder dann halt in irgendwelchen Bakta-Tanks landet. Aber wie auch immer, wir werden dabei sein.
Dann wird es nicht vorher selbst schon zerstört haben.
Das kann auch passieren, ja.
Vielleicht fangen sie auch mit Laber-Podcasts an. Erst hören sie 50 Jahre lang zu.
Und dann erzählen sie mehr und besseren Quatsch als wir. Und mehr durcheinander.
Stell dir vor, du hättest so eine KI, wo du einfach die Freak Show-Sendung reinmachst. Und dann kann sozusagen jegliches Gespräch passend emuliert werden. Es gibt ja jetzt auf Twitter den schönen Deep Drumpf. Twitter-Account, kennt ihr den?
Deep Drumpf?
Deep Drumpf. Hier, John Oliver von Last Week Tonight. Wird ja immer besser. Er ist ja auf dem besten Wege Daily Show vergessen zu machen. Und er hat dieses wunderbare Teil gegen Trump, wo er irgendwie ausgegraben hat, dass Trump sich ja mal oder seine Familie sich irgendwann mal umbenannt hat und früher tatsächlich Drumpf hieß. Ja, und er plädiert halt dafür, man sollte halt irgendwie Make Donald Drumpf Again mit dem passenden Hashtag irgendwie auspacken und sozusagen dafür sorgen, dass man ihn einfach so nennt und auch damit klarmacht, was Sache ist, etc. Das John Oliver Video wird bestimmt gleich jemand in den Chat. In dieser Sekunde ist es da. Genau, und jetzt gibt es dann noch passend dazu den Deep Drumpf Twitter-Account, der halt auch wieder so eine AI ist, der sozusagen gefüttert wurde mit Trump-Speeches und Trump-Tweets und jetzt selber anfängt so zu twittern, als wäre er Trump.
I know Mexico, I said.
This is going to be, we need money today.
Our country.
Ja, sowas, ne?
Wobei das ja gefühlt dann doch noch irgendwie so eine Stufe unter Eliza ist. Dieser Chatbot. Also dahinter steckt ja wieder so ein bisschen die Frage hier mit dem Tuing-Test. Und ab wann erkenne ich nicht mehr, dass das gegenüber irgendwie von einem Menschen geschrieben ist, sondern von einer Maschine.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, die Maschine kann halt auch nur mit dem arbeiten, was von sich gegeben hat.
Die Datenbasis überschaubar. Habt ihr euch schon mal die Picazo-App angeguckt? Es gibt mehrere davon gerade im Store. Aber das ist so die, über die ich gestolpert bin. Du kannst da mal auf den Klick drauf klicken. Und zwar... Genau. Das, was da ein Algorithmus drunter liegt, hattet ihr, meine ich, schon mal besprochen. Und zwar der Deep Dreaming Bilder-Algorithmus von Google. Da gibt es ja diesen endlosen Zoom, wie plötzlich die Google-Bilderkennung auch ein neuronales Netz anfängt, Konzepte und Formen zu erkennen. Das ist so ein 8-Minuten-Clip. Ich meine, den hättet ihr schon mal besprochen.
Das ist im CAE auf jeden Fall auch empfündigt worden.
Genau. Die haben ja den Algorithmus Open Source gestellt.
Das ist dieses TensorFlow. Wenn du mal kurz das Icon von dem Deep Drumf anschaut.
Das ist genau aus...
Mit den Augen und so, ne?
So, dieses Picasso geht jetzt, finde ich, noch mal eine Stufe weiter. Das macht nämlich Folgendes. Du lädst in diese App ein Bild hoch und kannst dann in einer ersten Stufe auswählen, mal jetzt dieses Bild so, als hätte Picasso es gemalt. So, und zwar aber so, dass es nicht einfach nur ein Filter ist, wie bei irgendwie Instagram, mach irgendwie die Kontraste so und simulier irgendwie einen Pinsel, sondern es gibt wirklich offensichtlich ein Konzept davon, was quasi so Picasso als solches ausmacht. Und das weißt du deshalb, dass es nicht nur besonders cleverer, normaler Fotofilter ist, weil du nämlich auch ein zweites Bild hochladen kannst, was die künstlerische Grundlage für dein erstes bilden soll. Das heißt, du lädst also jetzt zum Beispiel Casper David Friedrich hoch oder was auch immer du an Bild irgendwie cool findest. Das dauert dann relativ lange, also ungefähr 10 Minuten, das ist ein Cloud-Dienst. Und dann wird ein neuronales Netz direkt auf deine Anfrage hin trainiert, die künstlerische DNA des ersten von dir hochgeladenen Bildes zu lernen, um es dann auf das zweite Bild anzuwenden. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt also beliebig anfangen, Kunststile zu remixen. Oder irgendwie halt ein beliebiges Bild, was du machst, in einer Poetelismus zu machen oder abstrakt oder was auch immer. Wenn du mal ein bisschen runterscrollst, da sind Beispiele. Ich experimentiere da jetzt seit wirklich vielen Wochen mit rum. Und das, was da häufig bei rauskommt, da siehst du also wirklich, das ist also weit entfernt von, also zum Beispiel diese rechts diese Kirche, ist also einfach ein Foto halt. Das ist weit entfernt von etwas, wo ich sagen würde, das ist Kunst, so schlicht. Hier hat es eine Maschine geschafft, wirklich ästhetisch, anspruchsvoll und interessante Kunst zu produzieren. Ich habe irgendwo ein Set mit Porträts von mir selber, das glaube ich auf Facebook, die ich da durchgejagt habe. Wenn du also da jetzt noch einen Tüwing-Test machen würdest und die irgendwie im Museum ausprintest, würde dir kein Mensch irgendwie sagen so, das ist jetzt keine Kunst, das hat. Manches davon ist auch ein bisschen verstörend. Da kommen wir diese Augengeschichten mit rein, die man ja auch hatte. Also da kann man wirklich mal schön ein paar Stunden drin versenken. Das ist kostenlos, wie gesagt ein Webservice.
Na die App kostet drei Euro, ne?
Die hatten doch auch irgendwie so ein... War das nicht... oder ist das nochmal was? Hast du das in einem Podcast schon mal erzählt? Weil mir kommt das gerade irgendwie bekannt vor. Ich hatte das als Web-Dienst im Sinne, wo man dann aber... Wie war denn das? Irgendso ein Bezahlmodell hat, wenn man das dann irgendwie in Hi-Res haben will, dann gibt man dafür in Abhängigkeit von irgendwas, was ich vergessen habe.
Das gibt es. Michael hat das gepostet. Der Algorithmus ist halt open source und es gibt einfach mehrere Implementierungen davon. Das ist eine, die halt jetzt auf iOS-App-Base, zum Beispiel hier jetzt mit einem Secret-Board halt gemorft. Auch sehr schön. Und es gibt auch das Ganze als online. Und wenn du es halt als Poster irgendwie ausgedruckt haben willst, dann bezahlst du denen dann entsprechend Geld dafür. Genau. Und das sind immer diese Momente, auch das ist Narrow Intelligence. Also ich würde schon sagen, hier kann man von sowas wie Intelligenz offensichtlich sprechen. Also das kann viel mehr als ich als Künstler irgendwie könnte. Das heißt also hier ist schon irgendwo wieder eine sehr fokussierte, spezielles Talent irgendwo ausgeformt jetzt in diesem Algorithmus. Aber der hat natürlich jetzt wiederum null Ahnung vom Großspielen. Und solange diese Barriere nicht überwunden ist, wird es halt, kommen wir halt mit der KI dann doch noch nicht so richtig vorwärts. Aber ich glaube, das ist eine Frage der Zeit. Und die arbeitet da für uns. Und wow, wird das alles geil.
Die Singularität ist nah.
So ist es.
Kuschelig.
Also ich finde, man merkt schon, die Einschläge werden dichter. Also so diese Entspanntheit, ach naja, der Zug ist noch irgendwie zwei Kilometer weit weg. Gefühlt ist er schon so auf 500 Meter rangerollt. Sicherlich fehlt noch der ein oder andere Quantensprung.
Man spürt schon den Wind, der aus dem Tunnel kommt.
Das wird auch so viel Geld drauf geworfen. Das ist ja auch eine Frage. Wenn jetzt alle ihre Forschung einstellen, dann passiert da natürlich nichts mehr. Aber wer da jetzt gerade alles Geld hinwirft, das würde mich sehr wundern, wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Ja, man sieht das ja auch hier, Boston Dynamics, auch so eine Google-Company, die jetzt da ihren humanoiden Roboter da durch den Wald laufen lassen, der natürlich auch nicht mehr hinfällt, aber jetzt auch battery-powered ist und nicht mehr die ganzen Motorgeräusche von sich gibt, wie das mit diesem Hund da vorher noch war, Big Dog, wo man sich immer weggeworfen hat vor Lachen mit dem Waaawaaawaaawaa. So, aber das ist ja jetzt schon irgendwie ganz cool. Das ist aber auch ein schönes Mem. Ich habe irgendwo so eine Vertonung gehört, wo irgendjemand diesem Roboter so eine Stimme gegeben hat, wie er dann die ganze Zeit geflucht hat, wenn er irgendwie so weit irgendwo einsinkt und so Ah Shit! Auch ist das lustig, ne?
Na schauen wir mal.
So, soviel zur Singularität. Ich hoffe, ihr könnt noch schlafen.
Ich schock damit bei mir immer in der Bibliothek, wenn ich den Leuten sowas zeige, weil da wird beispielsweise noch im massiven Umstand Umfang Sacherschließung betrieben. Das heißt also Schlagworte generieren, die halt Bücher beschreiben.
Augen auf beim Eierlauf!
Also gerade mit Text kommen diese neuronalen Netze nur extremst gut klar. Wir sollten da mal irgendwie etwas radikaler unsere Bibliotheken umdenken, fürchte ich.
Wo wir gerade bei schönen Bildern sind, ziehe ich mal was anderes vor. Das ist eine kleine Sache, was mir heute erst über den Weg lief. Und zwar schöne Poster von der NASA. Und die fand ich einfach so großartig, dass ich das euch allen nahelegen will. Endlich mal euren Laserdrucker. Es ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal neu, ich bin da irgendwie nur gerade reingerannt. Visions of the Future, Poster von der NASA, wo sie vor allem Planeten bzw. Objekte unseres und anderer Sonnensysteme thematisiert haben mit so romantischen, schicken Posters. Also Titan finde ich geil. Einfach Enceladus ist auch ganz großartig. Jupiter, das ist so dieser, was ist das überhaupt für ein Stil? Das ist so dieser, was ist das, 50er Jahre?
Nee, ich würde sagen 30er, so Metropolis und so ein Futurismus.
Ja, genau. Also so frühes 20. Jahrhundert-Style, Blick in die Zukunft und das Ganze eben so mit so, naja, Planeten und Monden und Exoplaneten, Ceres, Venus, Mars. Ich finde die jetzt nicht nur schick, sondern was ich besonders geil finde ist, sie haben jetzt nicht nur so ein paar nette Bildchen ins Web gestellt und man kann die dann geil finden, nein, man kann sie sich dann auch als 52 Megabyte TIF-Datei herunterladen. Das wird dir gefallen, Ralf. Und selber ausdrucken. Und dann hat man die auch in maximaler Qualität.
Ästhetisch gefallen wird die auch sehr schön.
Ja, ja, also Farbgebung, alles irgendwie.
Download-All-Poster, 6x Megabyte.
Genau, nur 600 Megabyte demnächst in ihrem Browser.
Es gab auch kürzlich, bin ich auch über so eine Seite gestolpert, war das wirklich ein Kickstarter-Project? Da hatten die nämlich auch für die Voyager und sozusagen auch die ganzen alten Mission-Posters und da waren halt auch neue in dem gleichen Stil für die Rosetta-Missionen dabei. Also die haben dann quasi das auch gleich weitergeführt. Aber jetzt müsste ich das mal finden, verdammt, wenn man mal was nicht booken mag, ist einfach weg. Ich guck mal in meiner Twitter-Timeline, aber das dauert ja einen Moment, weil ich es runterladen muss und so weiter.
Das ist auch geil hier.
Ein Plakat für PSO J3185-22. Visit the planet with no star, where the nightlife never ends. So ein James Bondeskas, blau, dunkel, gehaltenes Bildchen.
Ist das so ein Wacker-Bodierender? Ein Free-Floating-Planet.
Genau, so ein Planeten, den sie gefunden haben, der einfach mal von irgendeinem Sonnensystem abgeschmissen wurde. Soll ja auch mal passieren. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich hier einen Favoriten habe. Hängengeblieben bin ich glaube ich erst bei Enceladus, den finde ich ja auch einfach mal so als, den finde ich ja auch, das finde ich einfach das geilste, zweitgeilste Objekt des Sonnensystems. Na, wenn man die Erde noch mit rein nimmt, das ist ja leider doof, dass wir von so verhältnismäßig langweiligen, oder zumindest so, naja, passiert halt nix, ne? Also gut, auf Venus ist eine Menge los, aber man sieht nix, und auf Mars sieht man alles, aber ist nix los.
Das finde ich so ein bisschen ungeil, ja?
Ich meine, Jupiter hat da irgendwie seit Jahrhunderten irgendwie einen Sturm, der nicht aufhören will, ja, und die ganzen Monde, da schießen, die Saturn-Monde, da schießen dann Eisfontänen ins All und einfach so abgefahrene Scheiße. Oder Titan ist ja genauso cool wie Erde, so mit Ozean und Flussdeltas und das alles irgendwie in Ammoniak. Das ist doch mal Action, und das ist leider so weit weg. Deswegen finde ich es schön, hier ein Enceladus-Plakat gesehen zu haben. Da wollen sie jetzt irgendwie, glaube ich, auch noch mal hin. Ah nee, da waren sie gerade. Sie sind dran vorbeigeflogen. Aber es gibt noch so einen ähnlichen Kandidaten beim Jupiter, wir vergessen, wie der heißt. Da wollen sie jetzt irgendwie hin. Und hier mit einem Ballon kann man zum Jupiter experience the mighty auroras of Jupiter. Herrlich. Gut. Aber wir sollten ja mehr über Max reden.
Können wir das überhaupt noch?
Weiß ich nicht. Und zwar wollte ich mal einen Fall schildern, der mich so anfangs ein bisschen vor Rätsel gestellt hat. Jetzt gehen mir einfach nur die Optionen aus. Und zwar im erweiterten Freundeskreis gab es einen Diebstahl. Und es wurde ein McIntosh geklaut, konkret. Ein Mcmini. Neuer Bauart. Und ja, wurde halt so entwendet beim Einbruch. Und dieser wurde aber remote administriert und war über Find my Mac und über entsprechende Remote Access Screensharing Geschichten immer erreichbar. Und war es eine Woche nach dem Einbruch auch wieder. Das heißt, man sieht in etwa, wo er sich befindet, vermutlich. Also es gibt so GPS-Koordinaten, es gibt da einen blinkenden Fleck auf der Karte. Problem ist natürlich, das Ding sagt dir jetzt nicht, wo es ist. Genau. Also in welcher Wohnung. Man kann sich ja auch nicht so sicher sein. Dann meandert das immer so ein bisschen links und rechts über die Straße. Man kann nicht so genau sagen. Vielleicht, wenn man es länger beobachtet, das ist sozusagen schon mal eine der Fragestellungen. Also wie kann man von dieser Kartenposition jetzt auch irgendwas Verwertbares für die Polizei liefern? Weil wenn du nur sagst, naja, da irgendwo in dem Haus, kannst du nicht gleich anfangen, alle Wohnungen zu stürmen.
Es sei denn, das ist in der Riga an der Straße.
Aber die IP-Adresse? Also ich meine...
Ja, jetzt kommen wir auf den interessanten Punkt. Die Remote-Zugriff war möglich über die dort konfigurierte Apple ID. Also das sind halt so Einbrecher, die schließen den Rechner halt einfach an, Netz ran, tralala. Los geht's! Und waren aber wohl klug genug, die Möglichkeit zu nutzen über die Recovery-Partition, gibt es nämlich explizit eine Möglichkeit, die Passwörter für die bestehenden Accounts zurückzusetzen. Und das wurde wohl getan, sodass die eigentlichen lokalen Passwörter geändert wurden. Trotzdem ist der Remote-Zugriff noch möglich, weil der läuft ja über die Apple ID. Leider wurde vergessen, einen Login für diese Accounts auch über die Apple ID zu erlauben. Das kann man ja auch machen. Das schaltet man natürlich gerne aus, weil man an so ein Szenarios vorher nicht denkt. Und leider, auch wenn es jetzt wahrscheinlich in dem Fall auch nicht viel geholfen hätte, beziehungsweise doch auch hätte helfen können, auch SSH war nicht angeschaltet. Die eigentliche Frage ist, hat man in dieser Situation noch irgendeine Möglichkeit über FindMyMac in irgendein Metadatum heranzukommen, was unter Umständen einem der Aufklärungen dieses Falls näherbringt? Kann natürlich jetzt anfangen, es immer mitlaufen zu lassen und ein bisschen Kino zu machen und den Leuten beim Brausen zuzugucken, aber es würde wahrscheinlich sogar funktionieren. Aber es ist die nächste Eskalationsstufe, dass man die ganze Zeit remote mittaped, was so läuft. Meine erste Idee wäre natürlich gewesen, einloggen, whatsmyip.com, man hat eine IP-Adresse und dann hast du ja sozusagen einen Ermittlungsansatz in dem Fall. Ja, weiß nicht, ob ihr da noch irgendwelche Ideen habt. So ganz nebenbei wäre wahrscheinlich das Coolste gewesen, man hätte sich einfach einen Account gemacht, der über FindMyMac zu erreichen ist, über SSH, und hätte sich da noch so ein Public Key reingelegt. Und dass man sozusagen auch ohne das Passwort, selbst wenn das Passwort geändert ist, in diesen Rechner rein telefonieren könnte.
Also FindMyMac ist ja quasi ja nur so eine Bonjour-Verlängerung. Das heißt, FindMyMac macht, glaube ich, oder Remote Access, also er macht im Prinzip ja nur, dass die Bonjour-Dienste, die da sowieso drauflaufen, dann hinterher bei dir auf dem anderen Rechner aufpoppen über irgendwie iCloud-Mechanismus. Das heißt, wenn du SSH anhast und du hast da ein Key gesetzt, dann kannst du dich da immer einloggen, weil du kriegst immer über dieses Remote Bonjour kriegst du immer einen Zugriff zu deinem Rechner.
Ja, wenn SSH an ist. Wenn SSH an ist, ja. Und selbst wenn es angewesen wäre, wäre da auch kein Key hinterlegt gewesen. Also mir ist schon einiges klar, du hättest auch einfach nur die Accounts für iCloud-Login freischalten. Also dass du dich auch mit einer Apple-ID einloggen kannst. Hätte dir das auch schon gereicht. Die Tür ist aber leider auch schon zu.
Ja, hatten wir auch schon diesen Fall auf jeden Fall. Im Office wurde ja auch schon mal so. In jedem Office wird irgendwann mal irgendwas geklaut. Und da sieht man dann halt auch, das war in dem Fall besonders interessant, weil der Rechner dann zwei Tage später schon in, nicht Slowenien, sondern noch ein bisschen weiter unten am Balkan gelandet war. Und man dachte so sportlich, sportlich, so in zwei Tagen. Nicht schlecht, aber ja, dann war halt genau ähnliche Sachen da. Also natürlich war jetzt nicht SSH an, ich hab auch nicht SSH auf meinem Laptop an. Also jeder offene Port, den ich nicht brauche, gibt es nicht sozusagen. Und dann saßen wir halt auch da und konnten dann in dem Punkt zwar schön zugucken, aber ja, das war's dann halt auch. Also es wäre ja schon ausreichend, wenn im Find My Mac eigentlich so die IP-Adresse noch von dem Rechner stehen würde. Das wäre ja das Simpelste von allem.
Warum nicht?
Das hat ja Apple, offensichtlich.
Ja eben, weil sie bauen ja ein V6-Tunnel auf zu diesem Teil. Aber jetzt bin ich gerade aufmerksam geworden, Roddy, du sagst klar, Bonjour, was steht denn in diesen Bonjour-Daten drin? Steht da eine IP-Adresse drin? Also kann ich sozusagen schon den Bonjour-Anmeldungen selber das ansehen oder ist das dann sozusagen schon das Ergebnis des Tunnels? Aber der wird ja erst aufgebaut, wenn ich mich dahin verbinde. Also vielleicht ist das schon mal so ein Ansatz.
Ein Netter ist das.
Also die eigentliche Frage ist ja, was kann man, also nein, es gibt zwei Fragen. Fällt irgendjemand noch was ein, was man hier nochmal ausprobieren kann, was uns noch nie eingefallen ist? Das andere ist natürlich, was ist sagen wir mal der beste Act für den Fall, dass geklaute Systemen wirklich so blöd die Passwörter zurückgesetzt werden? Der Trick scheint sich wohl rumgesprochen zu haben.
Der ist wahrscheinlich im Zweifelsfall auch Google.
Das Beste, was einem passieren kann, ist ja, dass das Ding nicht gleich platt gemacht wird. Weil wenn es platt gemacht wird, ist es halt platt. Und dieses Find My Mac sehen halt viele nicht diese Funktionen. Die denken halt, ah ja, hier ist jetzt der Computer, jetzt kann ich den genauso weiter benutzen. Also unser eins würde natürlich als erstes alles neu installieren, aber es scheint zumindest in diesen Kreisen sich noch nicht ganz so rumgesprochen zu haben.
Also ich glaube mit einem normalen Bonjour-Scanner müsste der Rechner auch auftauchen als Rechner, der da drin ist und der müsste dann als Serviceadressen ganz normal angeben, was er für IP-Adressen hat. Weil da laufen ja Dienste drauf.
In einem normalen Scanner müsste der auftauchen.
In einem Bonjour-Scanner. Da müsstest du jetzt natürlich einen haben, den du Back-to-my-Mac-mäßig, genau, Back-to-my-Mac, so hieß es.
Hab ich ja auch.
Und da müsstest du dann die entsprechenden Dienste von diesem Back-to-my-Mac-Mac sehen. Und da müssten eigentlich die Adressen drin stehen. Weil das ist ja genau das, was Bonjour tut.
Also ich sehe genau keinen einzigen Eintrag von diesem Rechner, obwohl er bei mir hier in der Seitenleiste erscheint.
Erscheint in der Seitenleiste.
Aber vielleicht schau ich auch mit dem falschen Tool. Was würdest du denn so empfehlen für Bonjour Browsing?
Warte mal, ich hab hier meinen auch an der Seitenleiste.
Ich benutze noch so ein uraltes Tool, was irgendwie noch nicht durch ein anderes Tool in der Nützlichkeit für mich ersetzt wurde. Das wird schon seit Jahren nicht mehr weiterentwickelt. Heißt Observation Post. Crashed manchmal, aber ist auf jeden Fall nützlich.
Also der Roddy hat hier irgendwie so ein ganz schickes Tool.
Ja, aber da steht es auch nicht drin. Einet heißt es einfach nur, ein Network Scanner, aber steht tatsächlich jetzt auch nicht drin. Wie war denn das? Würde der... Das ist ja hier ein normaler...
Einet.
Einet heißt der einfach nur...
Einet Network Scanner heißt der.
Genau, Einet Network Scanner.
Netzwerk Scanner. Ist das eine deutsche Webseite? Ist das über... Das scheint mir aus Deutschland zu kommen.
Die Banana Glue GmbH.
Berlin. Na guck an, warum in die Ferne schweifen.
Hat zwar jetzt sagen wir mal nur dreieinhalb Sternchen.
Ja, viereinhalb.
Also ich hier in meinem App Store sind es dreieinhalb.
Achso, auf ihrer Webseite meinen sie ja vier einhalb. Vielleicht waren es immer mal vier einhalb. Ah, wie passend, den hatte ich schon mal gekauft.
Ah, hier folgendes. Wenn du im Terminal sagst, unter dem Kommando Shell eine neue entfernte Verbindung, siehst du dann das SSH von dem? Oder FDP oder Telnet?
Du meinst jetzt hier mit meinem eigenen...
Ja, der scheint ihn ja irgendwie zu erkennen, ne?
Ja.
So, wenn du da sagst, im Terminal...
Dann kriege ich hier diese Members.btmm.icloud.com-Geschichte, ne? Ja, okay, ja, das stimmt. Dann gucke ich mal, was das ist. Und da kriege ich, ja, aber dann kriege ich aber als Adresse... Ne, kriege ich gar keine Adresse. Sondern kriege ich nur ein...
Members.btmm.icloud.com-Ding, ne?
Dann kriege ich aber keine IP-Adresse für...
Seien Sie dabei, live dabei.
Wenn wir hier den Rechner wiederfinden.
Also ich kriege da nur ein SOA hostmasterapple.com Was heißt denn das? Ach Clemens, ist wieder nicht da.
Fragen Sie jemanden, der sich damit auskennt.
Ja, fragen Sie jemanden, der sich damit auskennt. Also okay, wir kriegen ja jetzt so schnell nichts raus.
Aber immerhin, du kriegst diese btmmicloud.com.adresse da raus.
Ja, die ist sogar immer die gleiche, weil da steckt ja letzten Endes nichts anderes drin als deine eigene ID. Und du hast recht, hostname.lalalaidmembers.btm.icloud.com, aber da ist halt jetzt sozusagen über DNS krieg ich da jetzt gar nichts.
Naja, du müsstest unter DNSSD oder wie das Ding heißt, oder?
Guck mal, hier mit dem Inet kann ich explizit sogar diese Domänen auswählen. Und da kriege ich auch eine Service-Adresse als V6-Adresse. Aber das ist vermutlich...
Stimmt, die kann man auszahlen und dann kriegst du...
Oh, was ist die Service-Adresse?
Also die Service-Adresse ist hier immer die gleiche. Es müsste die Adresse von einem Rechner sein.
Ja gut, aber es ist ja eine V6-Adresse und die stammt dann wahrscheinlich aus einem Tunnel.
Naja, gut, also ich kriege jetzt hier bei einem Dienst nochmal die V4-Adresse. Die ist aber natürlich nur lokal für das dortige Netz.
Während du verbunden bist mit diesem Rechner, also hast du irgendeine Verbindung dahin aufgestellt oder browsest du das jetzt nur?
Ich browse jetzt hier nur das Bonjour von diesem...
Du hast jetzt keine Verbindung in irgendeiner Form aufgebaut.
Naja, doch hab ich.
Naja, das ist dann was anderes. Das ist dann was anderes.
Nee, Bonjour annoucet die Adressen. Ohne, dass du eine Verbindung aufmachst. Also Bonjour annoucet einen Service. Ich bin ein Drucker. Ich bin unter der Adresse zu erreichen. Und ich hab diese Kapazitäten und diese Features. Das macht Bonjour. Da hast du keine Verbindung hin aufgebaut. Und diverse andere Bonjour-Geräte cashen irgendwie die Gesamtwahrheit in diesem Bonjour-Netz.
Ja gut, aber dieser Rechner, der jetzt in meiner Apple-ID vorgesehen ist, der postet hier diese Adresse, ist aber jetzt nicht zu erreichen. Für mich. Und das ist auch irgendwie nur so eine Tunnelgeschichte. Also wir drehen uns hier im Kreis. Wir wissen es nicht. Andere Frage ist natürlich, was kann man sich unter Umständen für Software installieren? Oder wie sollte man seinen Rechner konfigurieren, um sozusagen einen potentiellen Entwender die Sache sehr schmackhaft zu machen, ins Messer zu laufen?
Ich kann ihn aber pingen. Wenn ich mir über die Bonjour die V6-Adresse nehme und die mit Ping 6 anpinge, kann ich den pingen.
Ja, weil du aber auch schon eine Verbindung dahin aufgebaut hast.
Na ja, dadurch, dass der announced ist, hab ich ihn ja, ich weiß ja die Adresse von ihm.
Na gut, aber das ist ja dann sozusagen eine, ja bevor du eine Verbindung einmal aufgemacht hast, hast du einmal eine SSH-Verbindung dahin aufgebaut?
Nee, hab ich nicht. Nein, eine SSH-Verbindung hab ich auf jeden Fall nicht aufgebaut.
Oder irgendeine andere.
Ja.
Ja, das mein ich. Dann baut er ja einen Tunnel auf. Aber erst dann.
Ja, aber du kannst dir ja auch eine Verbindung aufbauen, indem du jetzt das Zugucken anschaltest.
Ja, aber das ist halt eine Tunnel-Adresse, das hilft mir halt auch nicht weiter. Das ist sozusagen nur ein Endpoint von einem Tunnel, der über Apple geht. Das ist sozusagen keine Information, sondern eine Information wäre halt eine Public-Adresse. Aber die haben diese Rechner ja in dem Sinne gar nicht. Das heißt, da müsste schon der Tunnel selber, der halt dann diesen Tunnel aushandelt, müsste die in diesem Zuge gewonnenen Informationen durchreichen und sagen, was die öffentlichen Adressen dieser Tunnelverbindungen sind. Aber die sehe ich ja selber durch den Tunnel nicht.
Na dann, machst du dir einen Cron-Job auf dem Rechner, der dir eine beliebige E-Mail-Adresse jede Stunde, falls sich sie ändert oder so.
Immer die Public-Adresse, die sich genau... Das ist eine gute Idee.
Also Low-Level-Shit, der man auch nicht so mal eben sieht oder so. Also LaunchD würde es ja dann in dem Fall sein.
Das würde tun, ja.
Das wäre in der Tat eine sehr einfache Geschichte, ja. Das ist einfach per Mail, regelmäßig.
Oder man hackt sich halt was, wo dieser Job einfach nur Guten Tag sagt und dann siehst du ja die Absenderadresse quasi.
Auf dem Webserver sozusagen.
Und kannst die sozusagen auf der Empfängerseite aufschreiben. Dann muss dein Rechner nicht die ganze Zeit immer ifconfig.me oder was auch immer aufrufen.
Ja, ein Mail ist ja auch immer so eine Sache.
Einfach stumpf, HTTP. An so einer Adresse hast du es im Webblog drin.
Legst du ein kleines Clickpixel rein, machst einen Curl.
Blagif. Fertig, ist die Laube.
Hatrequest reicht. Spart Bandbreite vom Einbrecher.
Manchmal muss man einfach nur einfach genug denken. Dann ist natürlich die Frage, gibt es noch andere Informationen außer einer IP-Adresse und einem Live, was noch wertvoll sein kann?
Naja, wenn du die Wohnung findest, also das iPhone kann ja mit Luftdruck auch die Höhe. Dann wirstest du zumindest noch den Stock in etwa.
Ich höre jetzt von Mac.
Ja, ich weiß.
Also sagen wir mal so, wenn dieser Rechner tatsächlich benutzt wird, dann fallen da natürlich auch Daten an. Du kannst über Bonjour relativ viel abgucken. Wenn der jetzt anfängt iTunes zu benutzen und sowas macht, wie seine iTunes-Bibliothek zu veröffentlichen und deren schlauen Namen gibt, den eigenen, Maximilianseibchen, dann hast du schon mal einen Vornamen.
Ja, wobei in dem Fall haben sie ja den Account beibehalten.
Ja gut, das könnte trotzdem natürlich solche Änderungen geben. Ja gut, bei Rechnern mit Kamera ist natürlich die Kamera auch sehr interessant.
Ja gut, da geht immer das Lampal an. Ja gut, aber Mac Mini hat keine Kamera.
Das ist richtig, in dem Fall fällt die Option auch weg.
Kannst du beim Ende das Mikro anschalten? Obwohl, hat Mac Mini ein Mikro?
Aber, du könntest natürlich auch statt einem Head Request ein Post Request machen von deinem Launch Service. Und auch so die recently changed files und so.
Nein, kein Mikro.
Nee, hat er nicht.
Das Internet sagt kein Mikro.
Du Tim, wieder Shells Script. Einfach die recently opened files. Also alles, was so an Klartext auf dem Rechner getippt wird, einfach direkt dann so mit Remote-Flag. Also weißt du, das Skript...
Keyboard-Logger.
Ja, nee, einfach das Skript, das fragt die ganze Zeit, so bin ich geklaut, so, ne? Und lässt dann halt auch die IP-Adresse da. Das macht die ganze Zeit nichts. Und in dem Moment, wo du auf dem Webserver sozusagen die Antwort schaltest auf, ich bin geklaut, dann sofort irgendwie erstmal alle recent files, seitdem du es umgeschaltet hast und so weiter abgib. Also mit HTTP, Postrequest und so, ne?
Ja, das ist cool, so ein Running-Modus. Und dann sozusagen als Remote-Bot, dass man irgendwie einfach alles, dass er selber einen Server macht und man holt sich dann einfach...
Also schickt dir ein Request und in der Antwort sagst du, gib mir mal die Datei. So, gib mir mal die Info, gib mir mal die Info und dann sammelt er einfach ein und...
NSA yourself, man!
Ja, stimmt, so einfach.
Aber, also ja, ich meine, wirklich einen SSH-Key ablegen für seinen eigenen Account, SSH anlassen und wenn dann dieses Skript dir immer die aktuelle IP-Adresse da liefert, dann kommst du ja auch schon mal eine Gipfelke weiter.
Wenn du natürlich ganz creepy sein willst, dann schreibst du dir ein Skript, das regelmäßig die Keychain hochlädt. Wenn das Passwort von der Keychain nicht geändert wurde, dann kannst du da eventuell nachgucken, wie denn die Passwörter zu email accounten sind.
Wenn die Passwörter zurückgesetzt werden, dann fällt die Keychain ja eigentlich weg.
Das wird in diesem Tool damit gemacht.
Die wird dann sozusagen komplett gelöscht?
Nee, die wird nicht gelöscht, das Passwort geändert.
Aber sonst schick. Erinnert die auch noch von dem Assault?
Dann könntest du ihnen auch sein Leben zu Hölle machen. Ich hab das nämlich kürzlich mal gemacht, wenn du dann diese Rescue-Konsole putest.
Man kann ohne das Passwort haben, das Passwort von der Keychain ändern?
Warte mal, Moment. Also es war auf jeden Fall so, wenn du diesen Recovery-Modus gehst und du sagst Passwort resetten, dann sagt er dir so. Aber jetzt gibt es zwei Optionen. Entweder...
Du kannst auf die alte Keychain nur zugreifen, wenn du das alte Passwort verwendest. Oder du legst eine neue Keychain an.
Genau.
Also du kannst nicht die alte Keychain... Ich mein, dann wär sie ja nicht sicher. Also dann wurden die diesen Namen nicht verdient. Also ich finde so ein paar... Man muss natürlich aufpassen, dass einem die eigenen Tools da nicht rogue laufen. Aber dieses eben remote Spy und dann einfach mal so einen Opus-Stream von dem Bild in Mikrofonen abholen, ist wahrscheinlich wirklich die fieseste Nummer. Weil damit kannst du einfach mal alles komplett mit tapen, was die Damen und Herren dazu sagen haben. Und die werden sich sicherlich zu dem Kauf äußern.
Schniko schlägt gerade noch im Chat vor, verfügbare WLANs abgreifen.
Oh ja, genau. Die ist ja...
Das ist eigentlich auch ziemlich naheliegend. Darüber käme man wahrscheinlich auch relativ zügig in einen engeren Bereich rein. Aber halt nur bis auf so und so viel.
Naja, halt so in den Bereich, den dir find mein Mac sowieso anguckt.
Nicht verfügbare, sondern gejointe WLANs sind sozusagen eigentlich das Interessante, weil dann kannst du einfach mit dem Laptop in der Hand die Wohnung wahrscheinlich schnell aufsuchen. Zumindest hast du dann auch Guten Tag, ich bin ihr neuer Nachbar. Ist das ihr WLAN? Kann ich das mal mitbenutzen?
Schön, das WLAN haben sie da.
Dann sagen die halt, das ist nicht mein WLAN. Dann ist das okay, dann wissen sie, welches WLAN das ist. Das ist in der Tat fetzige Datenspur. Weil das wird schon irgendwie heißen. Also im Zweifelsfall heißt das natürlich Fritz Box 7210.
Siehst du da nicht auch die MAC-Adresse von dem WLAN?
Das könnte schon ein richtiger Beweis werden. Klar, im Netzzeit siehst du das. Ich meine, wenn du SSH hast, dann kannst du einfach Netzzeit machen und dann hast du die WLAN.
Ich meine auch, ist das hier nicht älter, wenn ich hier mit irgendwie auf die WLANs gehen und sage, ach so, ich bin gerade gar kein WLAN gejoint. Ach so, von den anderen sieht man es dann hier nicht, aber ich hab ja diesen Wi-Fi-Skin, irgendwo gehabt, aber noch nicht installiert. Aber da sieht man doch, sieht man die MAC-Adresse oder nicht? Clemens!
Na, die MAC-Adresse kannst du leicht rauskriegen. Du machst halt einfach ein Netzart, wo dein Gateway ist und machst dann ab, also über die Shell kriegt man diese Informationen schnell.
WLAN, SSID, also von dem Gejointed, aber nicht von Fremden.
Ja, von dem Gejointed, aber das Gejointed ist ja das Interessanteste. Die anderen sind bei Werk. Die kriegst du wahrscheinlich auch so raus, weil du weißt ja, die Position hier ist ja schonmal da. Also das ist halt, es gab doch beim iPhone, kann man doch über iCloud explizit sagen, dieses Telefon ist jetzt geklaut. Und ab dann wird sozusagen permanent getrackt. Geht das eigentlich auch für Macs?
Ich glaube schon. Warum nicht?
Ich hatte das hier auf dem Camp aktiviert. Du entsinnst dich, wo irgendwie auch mein Macbook Pro mal irgendwo abhandengekommen ist, durch deine eigene Verschusselung. Aber da hatte ich nur ein relativ wagens Feld. Aber das war so plus minus 500 Meter oder so was, war das schon.
Nee, aber gab es für dich die Option zu sagen, dieser Mac ist geklaut?
Also geklaut meistens.
So was ich jetzt auch nicht erinnern.
Also Sperren und Alarmton abspielen und so was, das war alles da. Aber geklaut könnte ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Sperren und Alarmton, ja.
Sperren will man ja nicht.
Genau.
Davon habe ich abgeraten, weil dann bist du draußen. Also in dem Fall, also man muss natürlich abwägen, ist mir das Gerät oder der Zugriff auf die Daten oder die Daten selbst sozusagen. Also was ist der Wert für mich, ja? Und Daten ist natürlich richtig doof, weil da muss man das Gerät auf jeden Fall haben oder eben Fernzugriff, wo man sich zumindest mal selber nochmal einen Backup holen kann. Und gut, Gerät verständlich, wenn man das zurückhaben will. Aber wenn es einem um den Zugriff auf das Gerät geht, primär, dass andere nicht die Daten bekommen sollen, dann macht Sperren natürlich Sinn. Aber wenn man irgendwas zurückhaben will, macht Sperren keinen Sinn. Trotzdem würde man eben gerne einen Modus haben bei Apple, wo man sagen kann, gib mir mal mehr Informationen, weil es ja meiner. Und ich verstehe gar nicht, spricht irgendwas dagegen, dass Apple nicht so was einbauen kann, dass sie einem sagen, ja hier Alpietto, das wird kaputt.
Wenn du dein Gerät privat verkaufst und das dann benutzt, um irgendwie dem Käufer noch nachträglich sozusagen hinterher zu stalken, dann gibt es da keinen offiziellen Weg, jetzt deine Ownership von diesem Gerät wieder abzugeben.
Ja gut, aber das ist... Ich meine, wer einen Computer kauft und den nicht neu aufsetzt, ist...
also...
Sache nur! Vielleicht spielt das so eine Rolle.
So, ich guck mal hier.
Ja, wie ist denn das? Also sind die entsprechenden Leute denn schon bei der Polizei gewesen?
Äh, ja. Okay. Die zuständige Sachbearbeiterin war aber nach 14.30 Uhr nicht mehr zu erreichen und überhaupt. Also das ist ein sehr langsamer Prozess. Na, ich weiß nicht, ob man da überhaupt bei Apple in dem Sinne einen...
Ich würde mir zumindest einen Apple Store Termin klicken und sich vom Genius mal erklären lassen, was die Optionen sind.
Aber also ich hab bisher von noch keiner Option gehört. Und bei uns in der Firma wurden schon diverse Geräte geklaut, wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass unser IT-Department durchaus begeistert wäre, wenn man zumindest den Leuten...
Also bei den Zeit ist da leider keine echte Option. Ich hab da bei den Wiki-Geeks schon mal lange drüber gesprochen. Ich hab mein iPad in einem ICE liegen gelassen, an einer Endstation in München, wo der abgerüstet wurde. Bin dann im nächsten Zug nach Göttingen umgestiegen und hab binnen 30... 2, 3 Minuten gemerkt, oh Scheiße, du hast dein iPad da in einem Netz einfach hängen lassen. Sofort irgendwie rumtelefoniert und find mein iPad und so weiter und konnte dann live mitsehen, wie mein iPad also dann erstmal noch von München in den anderen Münchner Bahnhof gefahren ist, wo nämlich der Zug abgerüstet wurde, wo dann die Abrüstcrew war und wo es dann von da aus irgendwie dann so 400 Meter entfernt vom Bahnhof irgendwie positioniert war und da es dann irgendwann war Akku durch und ausgeschaltet, aber ich konnte so quasi das Wohnhaus sehen in der Ortung. Bin dann in Göttingen zur Polizei hin und ich kürze das wirklich ab, wie gesagt, hört das euch bei dem Wiki-Geeks nach. Die Pointe der Geschichte war, ja mit einiger Sicherheit wäre es vermutlich die Abrüstcrew, also vom Polizeibeamten, aber da machen wir jetzt nichts, weil das müssen sie verstehen, die verdienen halt nicht so viel Geld. Rechtsstaat? Hallo? Ja, also viel Geld verdienen hin oder her. Aber ich meine, hallo, wir haben ja einen dringenden Tatverdacht. Ich habe eine Adresse, sie haben irgendwie die Liste der Leute, die da das abrüsten gemacht haben. Es hat nachweislich irgendwie kein anderer User im ICE, das irgendwie entwendet. Ansonsten wäre es nicht zu dem Abrüstbahnhof irgendwie gefahren. Was ist das denn jetzt irgendwie für eine... Das sehen alle zu kompliziert. Die dachten auch, ich komme vom Mond, als ich ihnen diese Ortungssachen ausgedruckt irgendwie gezeigt habe. Das hatten die irgendwie auch noch nie gesehen. Das ist ja so unverständlich.
Ich meine, was kann ihnen Besseres passieren?
Du musst halt eine peinliche Befragung machen von den Leuten und so was. Und da hat halt irgendwie offensichtlich niemand Bock drauf. Passiert halt Selbstschuld, Schlampigkeit. Aber diesen Spruch müssen sie halt verstehen. Die haben mich von drei unterschiedlichen Beamten gehört. Das scheint also offensichtlich dann auch irgendwie so die Standardreaktion zu sein. Ich fand, das hat sich mir nicht so ganz erschlossen, dieses Argument, aber naja. Klar war es eigene Blödheit, aber trotzdem, wenn man jetzt einen dringenden Tatverdacht hat, ich meine, die dürfen da trotzdem nicht alles mitnehmen, was da rumliegt.
Ja, und ja, gut. Freunde und Helfer. Dieses Inet-Tool sieht eigentlich sehr nett aus.
Ja, ich bin da als Nachfolger zu dem, den Bonjour-Browser, den ich vorher mal benutzt habe, der dann irgendwann nicht mehr ging. Da bin ich schon ganz zufrieden mit.
Ich hatte das bereits gekauft, aber das muss schon lange her sein.
Da hatten die Bubbles noch Akk?
Ich weiß nicht. Ich kann mich überhaupt nicht mehr daran erinnern, wie das mal aussah. Aber ich habe es, wie gesagt, schon gekauft. Aber diesen Look erkenne ich auf jeden Fall nicht wieder.
Tim, hier zum Thema Look noch kurze Cross-Referenz. Klick mal hier kurz auf den Link im Irrki-Irki. Ganz unten. Du scrollst ja nicht heute. Scrollfoul ganz unten. Richtig. Boden. Klick mal da nochmal auf die da. Da gibt es nämlich auch einen Poster von Rosetta.
Sind wir jetzt durch mit dem Cloud-Thema?
Ja, wenn du nicht noch was hast.
Dann hast du hier noch einen kleinen Nachtrag zur vorigen Kapitelmarke. Kannst du jetzt noch eine Rück-Referenz machen? Backlink? Sprungmarke einfügen.
Ah, das ist sozusagen von, wo ist das? Nicht von der ersten, die du kaufen solltest.
Genau, aber scroll mal runter. Da gibt es auch Schick. Genau, von den so diversen Missionen halt nochmal was. Aber wo bist du denn jetzt gerade abgebogen? Auf der Hauptseite, da waren nämlich eigentlich so auch die Postern einzeln. Ja, scroll mal da runter jetzt. So, da gibt es so Sticker und so weiter. Und irgendwo ist genau dieses Rosetta-Poster zum Beispiel. Das kann man auch nochmal größer machen. Gibt es auch als Aufkleber und so weiter. Und auch als große Kollektion. Fand ich auf jeden Fall auch alle ganz schick.
Ja, in der Tat, sehr hübsch, sehr hübsch.
Ja, als kleiner Nachtrag, ich kopier und paste den Link da mal in deine...
Bist du sehr freundlich. Sehr freundlich.
So bin ich.
Deswegen will ich auch nur mit euch podcasten.
Weil wir so freundlich sind?
Ja, klug und schön seid. Ihr dürft euch noch was aussuchen.
Ich hab ja gespoilert. Ich hab im Workflow diesen Link gesehen, hab da mal drauf geklickt und dachte mir, das darf ja wohl nicht wahr sein. Also ich muss ja sagen, One Password ist für mich auch so ein Tool, das hab ich immer gemieden. So ähnlich wie iTerm 2, weil mir das irgendwie schon immer suspekt zu erschienen, wenn so ein Third-Party-Tool mit Sync hier und Sync da und automatisch Dinge ausfüllen und so weiter. Also es war so prinzipbedingte Skepsis, jetzt ohne dass ich mich genau damit beschäftigt hatte, aber mir sah das irgendwie so nach, wie bei iTerm hat es so ein bisschen so Feature Creep und wir machen noch ein bisschen mehr Fancy Schmancy Convenience rein. Und ich bin ja immer der festen Überzeugung, dass so irgendwie Sicherheit und Convenience, die schließen sich zu einer gewissen Menge oder schließen sich aus, sagen wir mal, nicht grundsätzlich, aber es gibt nicht beides im vollen Umfang, so könnte man es vielleicht sagen, gleichzeitig. Und dann habe ich diesen Link gesehen, dass jemand halt rausgefunden hat, dass One Password, also wenn man dann dieses Web-Formular oder diesen Browser-Button, diese Extension benutzt.
Was die Sache so richtig convenient macht.
Was die Sache sehr convenient macht, die Passwörter dann in Cleartext halt übers Loopback-Interface schickt. Stellte sich dann raus in den Kommentaren, dass die Macher der Software das selber auch schon tatsächlich in einem Blogpost thematisiert haben. Und als ich das getwittert hatte, haben die auch mir nochmal getwittert, ja, hatten wir ja schon drüber geblockt und so. Und ja, die Sache ist aber, es macht die Sache an sich halt nicht besser. Und ich meine auch so, naja, es ist ja schön und gut, dass ihr das blockt, aber sagt ihr das auch dem User, weil die ganzen Follower jetzt gerade alle sehr überrascht scheinen. Und das scheinbar noch nicht wussten, inklusive dem Typen, der das da geblockt hat.
Sie darfst nicht blocken, sondern fixen.
Naja, und sie meinten halt so, ja, naja, also das Mindeste wäre ja, dem User in der App beim Installieren noch Bescheid zu sagen, hier, du installierst jetzt diese Browser-Extension. Und übrigens, das bedeutet das. Also, ne, einfach.
Ne, die müssen einfach sagen, wir haben es jetzt gefixt und es ist nicht mehr unverschließend.
Ja, das wäre natürlich die bessere Alternative. Aber beides haben sie jetzt erstmal.
Da sind die sehr gut drin. Die haben ja auch früher schon in Korken gebracht. Das haben sie ja Gott sei Dank jetzt mit dem neuen Format geändert. Das erste Archivformat von One Password war halt so, deine Passwörter waren zwar alle verschlüsselt, aber wofür deine Passwörter sind, waren nicht verschlüsselt. Das heißt, diese Datei war sozusagen so ein Cleartext von allen deinen Logins, wo du über allen Account hast. Das war sozusagen unverschlüsselt. Das fanden sie irgendwie auch unproblematisch die ganze Zeit lang, bis ja mal genug Leute irgendwie drauf eingehauen haben. Also ich verstehe das auch nicht so richtig. Also manchmal...
Die schrammen halt gefühlt so seit Jahren immer so knapp am Skandal vorbei, aber sie schrammen aber auch immer dran vorbei. Ja, weil sie kriegen noch so eben die Kurve.
Ja, weil sie kriegen dann immer noch die Kurve gefühlt ein bisschen zu spät. Machen es dann, aber auch wenn sie die Kurve kriegen, gehen sie ganz gut in die Kurve.
Aber bisher, also dieser Blogpost von denen, der ist ja, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe, von 2015, wo sie das schonmal thematisiert haben und dass sie auch nicht so genau wissen, was sie da jetzt tun sollen und was denn die User dazu denken würden und so weiter.
Sie wissen nicht, was sie da tun sollen.
Lies dir mal das Kommentar dazu durch. Also natürlich gibt es, ist ihnen bekannt, man könnte jetzt A oder B oder C machen, aber sie sind noch unentschlossen. Oder sie, was? Ja, liest dir mal die Antwort von denen in dem Blogpost durch und dann ihren eigenen Blogpost.
Und das ist halt, da denkt man sich schon so, also ihr Kernargument ist halt, naja, wenn du halt Malware auf deinem Rechner hast, dann bist du halt, dann können wir dir auch nix gegen machen. Das ist so ihre Hauptverteidigungslinie.
Das ist doch Quatsch.
Also das ist einfach, ja, also das hat mich auf jeden Fall wieder darin bestätigt, in meiner These, dass, also, nee.
Ja gut, ich meine jetzt ist natürlich das Lupec-Interface nicht, also das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so eine mega akute Geschichte, weil das bedeutet ja sozusagen, du müsstest jemanden auf deinem Rechner mit lauschen haben. Klar ist natürlich alles vorstellbar, aber wenn du an der Stelle sozusagen schon jemanden mit lauschen hast, dann ist wahrscheinlich dein Keyboard das bessere Target als jetzt dieser One-Password-Kram, aber es heißt natürlich auch nicht, dass sie das nicht irgendwie fixen sollen. Aber das finde ich jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen absurd.
Okay, das ist Juni 2015, da ist das sozusagen schon das erste Mal von denen thematisiert worden und da gab es wahrscheinlich schon einige Leute, die das noch mal vorher erwähnt haben.
Sie berichten, sie berichten halt explizit einen Security-Researcher, der das irgendwie sozusagen rausgebracht hat.
Also since November 2014, stehe ich da unten, we've been engaged in discussions with Lee about what, if anything, we can do about such attacks.
Ja, der Argument ist andere. Sie könnten ja dann auch gleich noch viel schlimmere Sachen machen. Das ist irgendwie einfach keine gute Argumentation. Also das müssen sie irgendwie schon irgendwie besser auf die Kante kriegen. Und ich meine, was man da macht, ist ja wohl klar, oder? Oder sind sie, ach so, warte mal, oder sind sie unter Umständen mit ihrem One-Password-Mini-Browser- Extension-Ding davon, werden sie davon abgehalten?
Na die Frage ist, sind jetzt die Extensions für alle Browser betroffen?
Local Websocket. Aber kann man in einem Websocket keine Verschlüsselung machen?
Naja, du müsstest deine Verschlüsselung wahrscheinlich in JavaScript selber programmieren.
Es geht über HTTP. Wenn es ein lokales Websocket ist, dann ist es ja kein Socket, sondern ein Websocket. Das heißt, es muss auch HTTPS können. Also das sehe ich jetzt nicht so.
Kann man einen lokalen Websocket über HTTPS?
Naja, ich will dir ja erzählen, dass man jetzt ausgerechnet mit Websockets nicht über HTTPS kommunizieren kann. So, Mutual Authentication, dafür gibt es Zertifikate.
Ja gut. Ich finde es halt bei so vielen Sachen, die Sicherheit oder Privatsphäre tangieren, das Mindeste, was man tun könnte, ist halt beim Beginn der Nutzung einfach dem User mal so fünf Bullet Points zu präsentieren. Pass auf, du meldest dich jetzt bei Facebook an, wir dürfen alles machen, was wir wollen mit deinen Daten pengen, bist du damit okay, weiter geht's. Hier, du installierst jetzt die Browser Extension, du sendest Passwörter, Clear Texts über das Loopback Interface, ist mir egal, gut weiterfahren. Aber das halt nicht bescheid zu sagen, aber trotzdem davon wissen und so weiter. Das ist eigentlich immer so das Mindeste, was man tun kann. Dann kann der User sich immerhin noch selber entscheiden, ob man den Aluhut noch eine Lage dicker macht oder eine Lage weg. Genau, passt ja super gleich dazu.
Ja, weil jetzt wird es wirklich, also ich muss sagen, mir stand schon eine kleine Schweißperle schon auf der Stirn, die ich Gott sei Dank wieder zur Seite schieben konnte, als ich feststellte, dass meine Transmission-Version 286 oder sowas war.
Alter, ich habe zwei Wochen vorher Transmission bei mir vom Rechner weggeschoben und bin umgestiegen auf ein anderes, weil mich das irgendwie insgesamt genervt hatte. Aber ich war da echt knapp dran.
Ja, viele wahrscheinlich. Also was ist passiert? Auf irgendeine Art und Weise ist der Installer von dem Transmission BitTorrent Client in der Version 2.9.0 mit einem, ja, mit Malware infiziert worden und zwar nicht mit irgendeiner Malware, sondern mit Ransomware, der ersten bekannten Ransomware für den Mac. Das ist halt so Erpressersoftware. Die verschlüsselt deine Daten und wenn sie dann alles schön verschlüsselt hat und ihr greift wahrscheinlich...
Einschließlich Backups?
Einschließlich lokal verfügbarer Backups. Schönes Argument für Offside-Backups im U-Ring. Ja, und sagt dann hier, du zahlst Bitcoin, dann kriegst du deine Daten wieder. Das scheint ja gerade ein sehr beliebtes Geschäftsmodell zu sein.
Schon seit Jahren tatsächlich. Aber es gibt ein größeres deutsches Festival, dessen Ticketsystem auch schon mal von so einer Ransomware befallen war. Glücklicherweise war da die Krypto nicht so ganz ausgefeilt, dass da befreundete und bekannte Hacker das auch wieder rückgängig machen konnten, ohne Bitcoin-Überweisung. Aber das geht schon eine Weile um. Das hat schon einige Kandidaten getroffen. Teilweise empfindlich.
Was ich mich mal frage, vielleicht bin ich jetzt irgendwie völlig naiv, aber habt ihr gesicherte Erkenntnis, dass dann dieser Entschlüsselungsprozess auch wirklich stattfindet, wenn ich da ein Bitcoin hin überweise?
In der Regel ja, weil würde das nicht stattfinden, wäre das Vertrauen in diese Lösung sozusagen weg und die Leute würden kein Geld mehr überweisen. Also da sind sie dann richtig gute Dienstleister.
Oh my, ja macht Sinn.
Die sehen das sozusagen als Dienstleistung.
Geht auch so wirklich schön schnell mit der Entschlussung, also sofort nach Erhalt des Geldes. Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall, das ist gerade großer Sport und aber wie gesagt eben auch schon eine Weile, aber jetzt eben auch auf dem Mac mal.
Ja interessant wird es natürlich, meistens läuft ja diese Bezahlung über BitTorrent und diese ganze Kommunikation läuft dann auch nicht selten, also ich sag nicht immer, aber das gibt es auf jeden Fall.
Bezahlung über Bitcoin?
Ach so schön, ich meine Bitcoin natürlich und die Kommunikation mit dem Server, der sozusagen sagt, du darfst jetzt entschlüsseln, läuft dann über Tor. Das ist natürlich, wirft das mal wieder schön so ein Blick auf so ein Dual-Use- Aspekt von modernen Netztechnologien und Freiheitstechnologien im Besonderen, wo man eben eigentlich wieder mal nicht sehr viel mehr dazu sagen kann, als ja, ist halt so. Wer ist das nicht, wer ist was anderes? Also die Debatte wollte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht aufmachen. Es sollten jetzt bloß alle gewarnt sein. Ich vermute mal, hier bei der Freak Show dürfte auch der eine oder andere Transmission mal gehabt haben und wer auf jeden Fall die zwei neuen Null auf der Platte hat, nicht nur löschen, wer es gestartet hat, mal ganz schnell die Kabel abziehen.
Also die war wohl für zwei Tage in the wild, dann haben die quasi die nächste Version nachgepatcht. Genau.
Also das Zertifikat revoked, mit dem...
Die Apple lässt sich nicht mehr starten sozusagen.
Naja, sie lässt sich nicht starten, ohne dass es heißt, ist nicht von einem verifizierten Entwicklungsrat.
Genau, was ich aber sagen würde, was so dem und der geneigten Transmission-Standard-Userin einigermaßen wurscht sein würde. Also da klickt man doch dann lustig drüber weg.
Kann schon sein, aber immerhin, besser als nix.
Ja, aber ich hab das jetzt nicht genau gelesen. Musste man zum Beispiel dafür seinen Admin-Passwort oder sowas eingeben für die Installation, also zur Benutzung oder war das einfach ganz normal einfach App reinziehen, starten, los geht's? Also die hatten das, es war signiert, korrekt?
Offenbar, wenn Apple den Key zurückziehen kann.
Na, es war nicht mit dem Transmission-Key signiert, sondern mit einem, also äh...
Anderen?
Mit einem anderen Key. Also ich hatte das gelesen, das klang irgendwie türkisch, als hätten sie irgendjemandem da draußen den Key geklaut. Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die ihren eigenen Key bei Apple geklickt haben, das wäre ein bisschen doof.
Ja, aber es kann gut sein, dass sie auf ähnliche Art und Weise sich an Designing-Infrastruktur von irgendeiner kleinen Bude, irgendeiner App-Bude, ran gewanzt haben.
Na ja, ich meine, Apple verifizierte Entwickler, das sind irgendwie drei Klicks bei Apple. Und dann hast du halt so ein... War's zumindest mal.
Also da könnte dir jetzt Heiko auch irgendwie fünf Stunden Rand halten über...
Ja, für Kernel Extensions, aber nicht für...
Ja, für Kernel Extensions ist das was anderes. Da musst du denen schreiben und musst sagen, ich möchte jetzt das und das machen, dann könnt ihr mir mal und so weiter. Das hab ich auch irgendwann mal gemacht und ich hab auch noch einen Key dafür. Ja, aber für eine normale Mac App ist das... Du musst halt so einen Account haben, so einen Entwickler-Account, und dann musst du irgendwann mal klicken, ich will jetzt hier so ein Zertifikat haben dafür.
Und die nächste Frage wäre noch, haben die die Checks haben auf der Webseite? Die hatten auf jeden Fall früher mal eine.
Das guckt sich doch eh keiner an.
Nee, ich frage ja nur, ob das... Also, das wäre halt die Frage, ob das was gebracht hätte oder ob sie sozusagen auch... Also, wenn sie da ein falsches Binary hochladen können, dann ist ja die Chance auch hoch, dass sie den Inhalt der Webseite ändern konnten.
Es wird jetzt übrigens im Chat gerade behauptet, es sei gar nicht die App selber infiziert gewesen, sondern das beiliegende RTF-Dokument. Das finde ich wiederum jetzt einigermaßen absurd in Bezug auf, wer zum Teufel liest denn bei Submissionen ein RTF-Dokument. Also, das finde ich jetzt ein sehr vagen Angriffsvektor. Da dürfte so die Conversion Rate aber so eher gegen null gehen, oder? Gibt es da irgendwo ein Beleg zu, Chat, zu dem das der gerade so behauptet?
Also, die Transmission-Seite schreibt, dass der Client Installer war infektet.
Ah, und die haben einen richtigen Installer, oder?
Wundert mich jetzt auch, warum die einen Installer haben.
Okay, wir sind wie immer super gut informiert.
Was natürlich sein kann, ist, dass... Das ist ja ein Disk-Image. The malicious executable pretends to be an RTF-Document. General RTF. Also, tatsächlich. Das kann aber sein, dass du kannst irgendwie, wenn du ein Disk-Image baust, kannst du dem Disk-Image sagen, bevor der User den Inhalt des Disk-Images sehen darf, muss vorher dieses und jenes RTF-Dokument angezeigt werden. Es kann sein, dass sie über diesen Mechanismus da irgendwie reingeraten sind.
Ah, no, when the user clicks the infected apps, their bundle, executable, transmission, bla bla bla, will copy this RTF to library kernel service and execute this kernel service before any user interface appearing.
Genau, also ich lese es auch gerade. Man musste jetzt nicht irgendwie einen general RTF-File, so hieß es wohl, extra anklicken, sondern das war schon ein Teil des Installationsprozesses. Nur da haben sie sich halt reingehackt. Ja, uncool, echt sehr uncool. I don't like.
Willst du eigentlich gerade hier hinschnupfen während der Sendung oder was?
Nee, ich bin sowieso eigentlich schon ein bisschen krankhut angeschlagen.
Naja, wir nähern uns ja ohnehin schon dem Ende.
Der Bestmarke. So, das heißt, dann hat diese... Dann hat also diese Transmission-Mailware dann praktischerweise das Loopback-Interface noch abgeschneuchelt und... Bestimmt. Ja, Mac-Thema.
Ein letztes Mac-Thema hatte ich noch. Ich hab zu Hause auch ein Mac Mini stehen. Deswegen wurde ich etwas hellhörig mit Mac Mini. Da konnte ich aus irgendeinem Grund, aus dem App-Store keine schon bereits gekauften Sachen mehr runterladen, weil er gesagt hat, Mac kann nicht autorisiert werden. Irgendwann wurd's mir zu bunt, dann hab ich mal geguckt, ob man irgendwo Hilfe kriegt und hab da so eine Mail an den Support geschrieben, woraufhin ich eine Mail zurückgekriegt hab. Ich soll doch mal diese 0800er-Nummer anrufen. Und hab dann tatsächlich den Apple Support angerufen. Das ist ganz witzig.
Was war jetzt der Anlass?
Der Anlass war, dass der Mac App Store, das App Store Programm, man konnte nichts runterladen aus den Sachen, die man schon hatte, weil es hieß, dieser Mac kann nicht autorisiert werden.
Ach so, die Nummer ja.
Fehlermeldung.
Jaja, das war ja jetzt wieder so ein Key-Problem.
Nee, es war interessanterweise.
Ach so, der Rechner kann nicht autorisiert werden?
So, und wie gesagt, Mail geschrieben, Mail zurückbekommen, hier Telefonnummer. Hab ich also eine Woche später da angerufen. Und das hat zwar ein Stündchen gedauert, aber hinterher war auch gut. Interessant fand ich, die benutzen auch dieses Bomgar. Schonmal Bomgar gehört? Das ist so eine Bude, die verdient damit Geld, dass das, dass die, das CS, also der Customer Service, kann dir quasi in dem Bomgar einen für dich zugeschnittenen Client zusammenklicken, den du dann runterlädst und startest und dann haben die Remote Access. Also gibt's verschiedene Stufen. Nur zugucken oder tatsächlich den Rechner steuern. Ich kenne es schon über die Firma, da machen die das immer. Die Inder, die machen immer den Bomgar auf, wenn sie irgendwas tun sollen. Und das fand ich interessant, dass Apple also das gleiche Tool benutzt. Hätte ich jetzt so nicht erwartet, ich hätte von Apple erwartet, dass sie irgendwie ihre eigene Lösung stricken. Aber ja, ist wohl so.
Sie machen Remote Zugriff auf was genau?
Auf den Rechner.
Auf deinen Rechner?
Na ja, sie fragen mich natürlich vorher. Ja, hier und so, können wir das mal so machen? Dann würde ich ihnen jetzt hier...
Und musstest du diese Interaktion explizit auf deinem Rechner bestätigen?
Ich musste sie initiieren.
Ah, wie?
Download von Binary und starten wahrscheinlich.
Ja, genau. Also du gibst dann... Also die hatten da so eine Seite, da konnte man dann so ein Code eingeben. Und das hat dann ausgelöst, dass er dieses Ding runtergeladen hat. Und wenn sich das dann startet, dann hast du dieses kleine Bomgar Fenster und dann kannst du in den Bomgar nochmal klicken. Ja, der Agent darf jetzt hier zugucken. Das ist, wenn man das erste Mal macht, ein bisschen scary, aber es scheint zumindest jetzt keine... Ja, hat wahrscheinlich Sicherheitslücken, ich weiß es nicht, aber... Also das Tool, das ist auch so, dass du startest es und dann verschiebt es sich selber direkt in den Papierkorb. Und wenn du die beendest, dann ist es halt...
Dann ist es schon weg sozusagen.
Ja, dann ist es schon wieder weg. Also es ist schon so einigermaßen trustworthy. Ich weiß, wie gesagt, gibt es bestimmt Sicherheitslücken drin, aber ansonsten, ja. So, und die Lösung des Problems. Und das war wirklich, was so ich echt dachte, es kann nicht sein, nach vielem Hin und Her probieren, hat die Frau da irgendwie dann nochmal andere Kollegen gefragt und so weiter. Und die Lösung des Problems war, dass in Root Library Preferences gibt es eine Datei NetworkInterfaces.plist. Und da stand irgendwie Müll drin und auf Grund dessen konnte sich das App Store Programm irgendwie nicht richtig beim App Store autorisieren. Root Library Preferences Network Interfaces.plist. Da meinte sie so, legen sie die doch mal auf den Schreibtisch, dann hat er sie kopiert, dann habe ich das Original gelöscht.
Okay, ich habe eine solche nicht.
Ja genau, und nach einem Reboot ging es dann und er hat die Datei auch nicht wieder angelegt. Keine Ahnung, wo die her kam.
Könnt ihr mir vorstellen, dass das sozusagen aus einem alten US-Ten...
Ich hatte auf dem Rechner aber einen Clean & Store gemacht, also es ist irgendwie...
Ganz clean oder mit Restore?
Was, was?
Es reicht nicht, wenn es nur sauber ist, es muss rein.
Also ich habe jetzt keine ganz saubere Erinnerung daran, aber ich weiß, dass der Rechner kam irgendwie mit, weiß ich nicht was, und dann habe ich halt einfach irgendwie die neueste Version drüber gebügelt und fertig.
Und keine Daten übernommen, kein Time-Mission?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Der Rechner, der ist, der ist auch sonst bis jetzt nichts drauf, also nichts Großartiges irgendwie. Aber das war, das war ganz lustig, also dieses Ding gelöscht und danach ging's. Also, root-library-slash-preferences-slash-network-interfaces.plist. Ich kann das auch noch mal.
Ja, hab ich nicht.
Hier, hauen wir das doch noch mal in den Chat. Und nochmal hier in die, wenn ich sie finde. In das große Dokument mit rein. Ja und dann ging alles wieder. Hat mich zwar eine Stunde gekostet, aber die war es dann wert. Fertig. Ja, also ich.
Ich hätte jetzt noch zwei potenzielle Themen. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir die noch aufnehmen sollten. Ihr könnt mit entscheiden.
Na dann, welche von den Vieren meinst du denn?
Also abgesehen von so Kleinkram. Fänd ich, also ich weiß nicht, diese FBI Sache.
Ja, gibt's da jetzt?
Hatten wir die letztes Mal überhaupt erwähnt?
Klar.
Die war da gerade frisch.
Umfangreich.
Da war sie gerade frisch.
Also es gab noch nicht wirklich größere neue Erkenntnisse.
In der Tat nicht.
Ich glaube, zu dem Zeitpunkt hatten sich auch die anderen Tech-Firmen noch nicht wirklich aus der Deckung gewartet. So ein bisschen, aber inzwischen ist das, hat sich jetzt entwickelt?
Hat sich definitiv verfestigt und aber ich glaube, substanziell gibt es da jetzt eigentlich gar nichts mehr groß nachzutragen. Dann können wir uns ja über Kopfhörer unterhalten.
Na gut, das ist fast das gleiche Thema.
Das ist das Abschlussthema.
Und noch eine Stunde, aber gut. Da habe ich ja viele klare Meinungen, ich sage nur hier.
Dann mal los.
Ich weiß noch nicht, was hier der Angriffsvektor ist.
Der Angriffsvektor ist der Miniklinkenport an deinem iPhone.
Das ist der, der geruhmortzt wird, musst du jetzt sagen.
Genau, also das ist sozusagen, nichts Genaues weiß man nicht. Ich finde allerdings den Gedanken an sich jetzt erst mal ganz interessant, was das sozusagen für Implikationen hat, ohne dass wir jetzt hier unterstellen wollen, dem sei so. Aber die Einschläge kommen ein bisschen näher und mittlerweile werde ich unruhig. Wovon ist eigentlich die Rede? Nämlich davon, dass Apple unter Umständen auf die Idee gekommen, sein mag, dass man doch den dreieinhalb Zoll, dreieinhalb Zoll, dreieinhalb Millimeter Mini-Klinken anspürt.
Dreieinhalb Zoll wäre ein bisschen groß.
Ein bisschen sehr Return of the Disc. Ja, ersetzt durch was anderes, was im Idealfall halt schon da ist, sprich den Lightning-Power zum Beispiel.
Also ersatzlos gestrichen nennt man das normalerweise. Ersetzt durch etwas, was schon da ist.
Tatsächlich ist es ja so, man kann heute bereits Kopfhörer kaufen, die über den Lightning-Port...
Ein Kollege von mir hat so einen, hat den ganz stolz vorgeführt.
Von Sony?
Ja, von Sony. Ich habe ihn nicht rein gehört, weil ich da sowieso Meinungen dazu habe, welche Kopfhörer wie klingen. Und dass ich das auch sinnlos finde, einen Lightning-Kopfhörer zu haben. Aber ja, ich fand den ganz toll.
Warum findest du das sinnlos?
Weil das so ein Single-Use-Case ist. Also ich meine, den kann ich schön ans iPhone stöpseln, den kann ich noch ans iPad stöpseln. Und dann kann ich ihn vielleicht noch an meine Tastatur stöpseln oder an meine Siri Remote. Also jetzt mal rein vom Stecker her, ne?
Dann hörst du Siri mit völlig neuem Schmelz in den Obertönen.
Also es wäre natürlich interessant, wenn man tatsächlich den Kopfhörer in die Siri Remote stecken könnte und dann tatsächlich Audio-Ausgang hätte. Aber das glaube ich wird nicht passieren.
Also ich habe da vielleicht irgendwie etwas unpopuläre Meinung zu. Ich finde das hochgradig schwachsinnig. Und zwar aus dem Grund, dass...
Hab ich auch gesagt.
Also der mir bekannte Grund ist, die wollen es halt immer alles noch sehr viel flacher machen. So wir haben gesehen, sie haben USB geopfert, jetzt irgendwie bei den neuen MacBooks. Und jetzt ist halt als nächstes irgendwie hier der 3,5er Anschluss dran, weil der ist zu groß und man will die Sachen kleiner machen. Ich habe jetzt hier ja ein iPhone 6S bekommen und mir ist das signifikant zu flach schon als Handy, so wie es funktioniert. Also ich hatte das...
Und mit Case geht es eigentlich.
Exakt das ist der Punkt. Du brauchst ein Case, damit es benutzbar ist. Wie ist das denn zu flach? Du kannst... Es ist A, zu groß und B vor allen Dingen, aber zu flach, weil also das zu groß und zu flach geht Hand in Hand. Ihr könnt das irgendwo bei mir auf Twitter die ersten zwei Tage weil ich kreuzunglücklich mit diesem Teil war, weil ich noch keinen Case hatte, weil diese Kombination aus, es liegt relativ halt quasi flach in der Hand, weil es einfach schon wahnsinnig flach ist und es ist dann zu groß, um eigentlich mit dem Daumen überall hinzukommen. Das Problem nimmt ab, wenn es weiter höher ist und dicker wird. Das heißt, sobald du also ein Case hast, wird das Ganze sofort irgendwie besser händelbar, weil die Abstände sich verschieben. Zumindest bei meinem Daumen und bei meiner Handgröße so. Das mag bei anderen komplett anders sein. Das heißt also, ich sehe überhaupt nicht den allergringsten Wert darin, diesen Miniaturisierungs-Fetisch hier noch irgendwo weiter vorzuschreiben.
Aber das ist jetzt erst mal unter der Prämisse, dass sie wirklich auch den opfern, um es flacher zu machen, wenn das gar nicht so ist.
Aber warum denn sonst? Also ich meine, du kannst natürlich immer noch richtig übel argumentieren, es sollen nur noch Beats verkauft werden und die sind dann nur noch mit dem Anschluss.
Es gibt noch mehr Argumente dafür. Ich meine, es gibt auch Argumente dagegen.
Also jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was für Argumente dafür sprechen.
Du spartest ein Dutzend Kubik-Millimeter an Platz ein.
Also erstmal ist der Lightning-Stecker besser als der Mini-Klinken-Stecker. Also er ist einfach technisch besser.
Wenn ich mir jetzt schon nicht ganz günstigen Kabel von der, wie heißt die Bude, die die Netzteile auch macht, Anker angucke, die eigentlich schon nullen Geld kosten und trotzdem nach einem Monat hin sind die Stecker, scheint mir diese Stecker-Konstruktion so rasenstabil nicht zu sein. Da hast du selber ein paar Mal gesagt, wenn du nicht original Apple kaufst, sind diese Anschlüsse innerhalb von einem Monat hin. Egal, was für ein Kabel du kaufst. Amazon habe ich schon, glaube ich, drei oder vier durchgeorgelt und jetzt die Anker, die echt nicht günstig sind, mit irgendwie sonst was noch für Faserungen drumrum, genauso Wackelkontakt. Also erzähl mir nichts von der Stabilität dieser Stecker.
So ein Sechserpack hatte ich mal von den Kabeln gekauft und die haben halt einfach die Ströme nicht abgekont, was so ein 12 Watt Netzteil da durchjagt und wenn man dann irgendwie das falsche iPad anschließt dann macht es halt einmal zinken und dann dieses Zubehör wird nicht unterstützt sondern dann weißt du, ah jetzt ist wieder ein Kabel über den Jodl.
Also und so eine Klinke, die kann man im Zweifel auch noch mal selber löten, ne?
So ist es, das kannst du alles selber löten.
Na ja.
Ein Unique Selling Point von Lightning, so dass es egal ist, wie rum du es einsteckst, ist, dass man auch scheißegal, wenn die Konkurrenz rund.
Gut, Lightning kann mehr Daten übertragen, man könnte da, sagen wir mal, etwas intelligenter.
Dann sitzen wir wirklich noch zwei Stunden hier, wenn wir jetzt über HD-Audio reden.
Nee, nee, mir geht's nicht um das Audio, mir geht's um die Metadaten. Also mir geht's ja immer um die Metadaten.
Im Kopfhörer, du brauchst Metadaten im Kopfhörer.
Ich hätte halt ganz gerne mal eine etwas aufwendigere, ich hätte mehr Klickoptionen.
Ja, aber das willst du doch einfach auf der Watch haben.
Nein, nein, nee, nee. Ich wollte schon immer, immer so ein Multi-Button-Klicker haben, mit dem ich einfach mal meinem Telefon sagen kann, was Sache ist. Verstehst du, weil mein Telefon versteht mich nicht. Ich will spulen, ich will 10 Sekunden zurück, ich will 20 Sekunden zurück.
Das ist jetzt aber echt ein Use-Case, den Apple sicherlich nicht.
Und da garantie nicht, ich sage nur, es wäre dann möglich.
Aber ernsthaft, das willst du doch wirklich auf der Watch machen?
Aber das wäre auch jetzt schon möglich.
Genau, du kannst ja jetzt auch so, wenn es die Wahl gäbe, benutzen. Also es ist nicht so, dass es nicht ginge, wenn die Klinke bleibt.
Dann könnte es bedeuten, dass es sie in die Lage versetzt, dieses Telefon wirklich wasserdicht zu machen, weil sie für Lightning-Ports da entsprechende Maßnahmen wohl auch schon weitgehend ergriffen haben, den bei der Medi-Klinke nicht funktionieren kann.
Ich habe irgendwann mal ein Video gesehen, ich weiß nicht, ob es fake war, aber da hat einer ein 6S und ein 6S Plus in eine Wasserschale gelegt. Und man sah in dem Video, wie die Stoppuhr von den Telefonen läuft und in einer halben Stunde hat es wieder rausgenommen.
Und hat er danach den Kopfhörer reingesteckt und der funktioniert noch?
Also ich würde jetzt aber ernsthaft behaupten, dass das ein gelöstes Problem ist.
Ja, also einen wasserdichten Kopfhörer.
Eine Mini-Klinke wasserdicht zu machen.
Ganz im Gegenteil, das ist einfacher als den Lightning dicht zu kriegen. Und noch einfacher als hier diesen Button dicht zu kriegen. Staub fangen sie auch beide.
Genau, vor allem so Fussel von hier so Sachen, die man so in seinen Hosentaschen mit sich trägt. Also Schnupftücher und ähnliches.
Ja, und man kann es nicht gleichzeitig laden und Kopfhörer drin haben.
Das ist ja schon mal richtig.
Na ja gut, wir reden von einer Firma, die ein Notebook rausgebracht hat, wo nur noch ein Anschluss dran ist. Was ich mir bestimmt nicht kaufen werde. Einziger. Und dass diese Waren das alles noch viel einfacher zu machen, kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass der auch das iPhone trifft und dass sie halt einfach nur den Kopfhöreranschluss weglassen, weil es geht.
Ich glaube das nicht. Ich kann mir das wirklich überhaupt nicht vorstellen. Diese Mini-Klinke ist einfach so ein universeller, weltweit, international, an alle Schichten durchdrungener, kompatibler Anschluss, den weglässt es wirklich.
Ja, ich mein gut, die werden ihre Statistiken haben. Das heißt also, du lieferst es natürlich dann mit EarPods aus, die halt entsprechend zugeschnitten sind und die werden sehr genau Statistiken haben, wie viele iPhone-Käufer überhaupt den jemals auswechseln gegen irgendwas anderes, seit die Qualität tiefer dramatisch besser geworden sind gegenüber der ersten Generation. Ich hab noch nie einen Apple-Käufer benutzt. Ich mein, diese EarPods, die sind schon super. Also ich meine, da habt ihr schon drüber gesprungen.
Ja, sie bleiben nicht im Ohr, aber ansonsten sind sie super.
Also bei mir sind sie perfekt und sind also dramatisch viel besser als bei mir.
Das ist aber auch keine Kunst, weil alle Headphones von denen vorher einfach absolute, unterste Schokolade, Grappelregal-Qualität waren.
Völlig klar, aber dann haben sie immer noch ihre Beats-Schiene, wo sie sagen, die kommen natürlich dann auch alle da drin so. Das ist dann für die Leute, die irgendwie was Wuchtigeres haben wollen, wie viele dann noch übrig sind, so schön Geister wie wir, die dann so Senderheiser Momentum und sowas, die müssen halt irgendwie ein paar Lizenzgebühren abdrücken. Also dass Apple das durchziehen könnte, glaube ich schon. Ob das clever ist, ist noch mal eine andere Frage. Also ich persönlich hasse ja Miniklinke. Das ist einfach ein super Scheißformat. Alleine den Zoom H6, das nur eine Miniklinke dran ist, so als Line-Out ist schon Drama. Also eine große Klinke oder irgendwie selbst Zinsch ist alles besser als diese Miniklinke. Also wie viele kaputte Miniklinke hast du?
Nein, Zinsch, da musst du jetzt eigentlich wieder sprechen. Also Zinsch ist wirklich, das ist wirklich das Ende.
Echt? Also Zinsch geht gar nicht.
Also das hat gegenüber Miniklinke schon Vorteile.
Zinsch?
Nicht viel, aber ein bisschen.
Nicht viel, ja.
Ach, was war noch gleich der Vorteil? Die Dinger sind labberig. Was? Labberig. Labberige Scheiße.
Du hast die falschen Stecker.
Ich hab noch keinen labberigen Zinsch gesehen, aber bitte.
Du hast noch keinen labberigen Zinsstecker gesehen?
Also wenn man ein ordentliches Kabel kauft, dann sitzen die aber so was vom Bomben fest.
Genau, Blausann schreibt in Chat, wir wollen XLR am iPhone haben.
Das ist das Einzige. Mini-XLR oder Mikro-XLR. Nee, aber es gibt schlechte Kabel, gibt es mit allen Steckern, habe ich irgendwie eher so die These.
Die These, die Erfahrung.
Ja, die Erfahrung. Wir sind auch schon billige XLR-Stecker auseinander gebröselt.
Es ist auch insofern ein merkwürdiger Bruch. Ich meine, bei dem neuen MacBook, du hast ja gesagt, das Ding hat nur einen Port. Stimmt nicht, es hat zwei Ports. Das hat USB und es hat einen Mini-Klinke.
Den Kopfhöreranschluss.
Genau, den hat das nämlich auch noch. Und das ist auch das Schöne, dass man diese Earpods immer, ich habe ja immer welche dabei, weil ich benutze diese Geldtasche von meiner Jeans. Da habe ich einfach immer Kopfhörer drin. Immer so.
Ich habe immer diese In-Ear-Dinger.
Ja, die gehen mir vom Leib.
Aber die Earpods, die halten halt nicht.
Aber auch die könntest du sozusagen in diese Tasche tun. Was ich sagen will ist, man kann halt die Dinger ans MacBook anschließen und man hat eine halbwegs korrekte Skype-Headset- Lösung dabei. Das ist einfach geil, weil in den Laptop rein quatschen, während man Skype macht, halte ich ja für, muss ich mich mäßigen, eine mittlere Idee, kulturell für fragwürdig, besserungswürdig.
Ich weiß, da gibt es auch nicht so übe, den man damit hinkriegt.
Besser geworden auf jeden Fall. Ich war auch überrascht, ich hab das auch mal gemacht, weil in früheren Versionen immer in Klo-Brille sprechen oder Klo-Schlüssel sprechen, aber irgendwie haben sie da ihr Gate noch mal ein bisschen getunt, es ist besser geworden.
Also da muss man auch echt mal sagen, so diese 0,5 Millimeter Mikrofonmembran an den Earpods, so richtig der wahre Jakob ist das halt auch nicht. Also da hast du schon eigentlich mehr Mikrofon in so einem MacBook drin, als in dem Kopfhörer.
Ja, aber du brauchst halt keine Echo-Cancellation.
Das ist richtig. Naja, mit der technischen Singularität, mit dem Angriff kommt das alles in Ordnung.
Ja, und was du vorhin auch schon sagtest, Huckel, so dieses offene Party mal eben den DJ übernehmen und so, schleppt man dann immer Adapter mit sich rum. Ich meine, da wirst du doch bekloppt bei. Und du kannst ja deinen Kopfhörer auch nicht in jemandes anderes Telefon reinstecken, weil der Rest der Welt, und das ist eigentlich das, was mich am meisten daran stört, der Rest der Welt wird nicht auf Lightning nachrüsten. Also das wird auf gar keinen Fall passieren. Wenn sie jetzt irgendwie gesagt hätten, USB-C ist jetzt the shit und ab jetzt kommt das iPhone 7 mit USB-C, okay, da könnte ich noch so halbwegs mitgehen, nur dass bei Apple wahrscheinlich auch allen klar ist, dass USB-C schlechter ist als Lightning.
Ist es das, technisch?
Also ich finde einfach Lightning ist halt einfach Stabilitätsvorteil. Du hast halt einfach so einen massiven Metall-Schnupsi in der Mitte und nicht diese inverse Geschichte da wie bei USB-C.
USB-C ja, das tut schon, aber ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass das ein Standard für die Ewigkeit ist.
Den Eindruck habe ich nämlich auch irgendwie nicht. Ich meine, das wird schon noch mächtig aufrüsten. Dann kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich demnächst Thunderbolt über USB-C. Das hat ja dieses MacBook leider noch nicht. Also das kann dann sozusagen wirklich sich an alles anschließen. Also ich glaube auch nicht, dass das so schnell wieder weggeht. Also es mag vielleicht nicht für die Ewigkeit sein, aber dieses USB-C, das werden wir noch sehr lange sehen. Ich meine, wir werden USB-A noch sehr lange sehen. Und dieses C ist dann schon doch...
Ja, ja, USB-A ist aber halt auch robust. Also ich meine, dass das so einen langen Weg gegangen ist, das robust, außer dass man das nie richtig rum einstecken kann. Ja, dass man es nicht richtig rum reinstecken kann, ist natürlich blöd, aber ich meine...
Ja, mal gucken, wie die Ports so überleben, weil der Stecker schließt sich um die Buchse herum. Ich weiß nicht, also ich finde das sozusagen... Also Lightning und USB-C sind ja im Prinzip genau vertauscht. Also bei Apple ist sozusagen die Funktion der Buchse übernimmt der Stecker und das macht einfach von der Stabilität her einfach mehr Sinn, weil die Buchse ist halt wirklich nur ein Loch und der Stecker ist nur ein Stecker.
Ja gut, aber solche Sachen hatte man doch früher, dieser Zentronix-Stecker oder wie der hieß, war da auch so ein Ding.
Der hatte noch mal außen noch mal ein Rand, der Stecker. Der hatte innen die Kontakte, das ist richtig, da ist er so ähnlich, aber er hatte ja auch noch mal außenrum noch mal den Rahmen und noch mal die Klammern, falls du dich daran erinnerst. Also es ist nicht ganz das gleiche. Also USB-C ist eigentlich der, Lightning ist eigentlich der einzige, der wirklich so frech daherkommt und sagt, ich brauche wirklich hier nur ein Metallstück mit Kontakten drauf und fertig ist der Stecker. Das Ding ist wirklich, also ein Minimalismus, einfach nicht zu überbieten und super stabil.
Einspruch. Also ich finde dieses Konzept von, das eine wird reingesteckt und es wird umfangen und dann hängt das irgendwie zueinander. Also ich fand einfach so der Weg, den sie hier bei den Stromkabeln gegangen sind, fand ich viel effizienter.
Magneten, das ist ja für Kopfhörer nicht zu ertragen.
Das kommt, finde ich, auf den Magneten an. Also wenn du dir alleine anguckst, was die jetzt hier so an Power entwickeln, das ist mir allesamt lieber, dass es irgendwann abreißt, als wenn du ständig mit irgendwie rausgerissenen Buchsen das zu tun hast. Also das hier fand ich ein super Konzept und ich finde es betrüblich, dass sie das so verbessert haben. MagSafe, genau. Dass sie das mit weniger Magnetismus auf der letzten Generation jetzt so runtergefahren haben. Das fand ich irgendwie so in diesem, so wie Stecker funktionieren müssen, fand ich eigentlich immer echt am besten. Also die konsequente Weiterentwicklung wäre, dass es so magnetisch ist, dass es eigentlich zwei glatte Flächen sind, die einander pappen und dass du gar nicht mehr irgendwie große, hier so diese Pinüppel noch in der Mitte überhaupt hast. Das wäre auch noch ganz schick.
Also wir sind uns zumindest einig.
Die Klinke muss bleiben.
Die Klinke muss bleiben, weil Lightning kann nicht der Weg sein. Ich meine das MacBook hat auch kein Lightning-Port. Das heißt, ich könnte deinen Kopf für mal...
Na gut, das ist ja was, was Apple fixen könnte.
Adapter verkaufen sie auch gerne.
Ja, aber was glaubst du nicht ehrlich, dass sie jetzt in ein MacBook einen Lightning-Port einbauen?
Also sagen wir mal so, in die Tastatur und ins Trackpad haben sie jetzt Lightning eingebaut. In die Serie Remote haben sie Lightning eingebaut. Es würde mich nicht wirklich wundern.
Welche Funktion soll das Ding übernehmen, außer die neuen Kopfhörer, die man sonst nur so reinstecken kann?
Dann eine Tastatur zu laden.
Ja, dann brauchst du aber ein Lightning zu Lightning. Die gibt's noch nicht.
Das kommt noch dazu. Ja, also auch diese ganze V-Rum-Nummer, das ist ja schon bei diesem Pencil irgendwie jetzt so bekloppt, dass du dann diesen Pencil in das iPad reinsteckst.
Kann man den Pencil eigentlich an der Tastatur laden? Oder am Trackpad?
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, wenn sie das wirklich bringen und die Klinke wegmachen, dann zeige ich Apple ein Vogel.
Ja, so richtig Hand und Fuß hat das halt alles nicht, wo sie jetzt hinwollen mit ihren Ports.
Aber das Internet ist ja auch so Konnektoren und Standards, ist ja auch eine Geschichte voller Missverständnisse. Sie hätten auch mit Firewire, hätten sie sich da nicht so mit ihrer Lizenzierung so irgendwie verkniffen angestellt, sie hätten da so rocken können.
Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht.
Ja, vor allem, was ich am Anfang sagte, also ich finde Miniaturisierung kommt hier irgendwo an seine sinnvollen Grenzen. Es gibt so viele andere Bereiche, in denen sie mal vernünftig noch Innovationen umsetzen können, also ja, es vergeht kein Tag, wirklich kein Tag, an dem ich mich nicht hier auf mein MacBook Pro starre und ich mich zur Tode ärgere über diesen schwarzen Rand hier ums Display drum rum. Also ja, wir haben 2016, ich erwarte verdammt noch mal fugenloses Display bis exakt an die Grenzen. Also ich habe nämlich hier ein 15 Zoll Display und ein 13 Zoll.
Die Sendung kommt langsam wirklich ans Ende.
Also ja, ich habe aber, das muss ich tatsächlich auch sagen, ich habe nämlich auf Arbeit einen Dell Ultraschall 27, U27 irgendwas und der hat den dünnsten Rand, den ich so bisher an einem Display gesehen habe und das ist einfach, das ist Zukunft.
Und Apple ist nicht dabei.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob dieser Laden dieses Jahr irgendein Produkt rausbringt, was ich mir gerne kaufen möchte. Letztes Jahr hat es ja nichts geklappt.
Ja, ich auch nicht, aber ich hab die auch, aber nur zum Sonderpreis. Für 150 hätte ich sie wahrscheinlich nicht genommen.
Du hast ja doch das Trackpad gekauft.
So, wir kommen zum Ende, oder? Ja, ich bin mal gespannt. Das war jetzt das erste Mal, dass ich die Sendung mit einem Backup aufgenommen habe, was quasi, naja, fast äquivalent ist zu meiner Hauptaufnahme. Also mein feines Mischpult schickte jetzt diese ganzen Spuren nicht nur an meinen einen Rechner über Ethernet, sondern auch an den anderen. Sieht das nicht schön aus?
Multicast macht es möglich?
Nee, das ist nicht Multicast, das ist einfach Doppel-Unicast. Könnte ich so konfigurieren, habe ich aber nicht getan, weil das hat dann immer noch so andere Konsequenzen mit irgendwelchen Embedded-Devices, die dann irgendwie durchdrehen und so.
Aber ich glaube, du hast die Rolls-Royster-Tasten nicht konfiguriert für diese Sendung, oder?
Ja, vielleicht hast du auch nicht die richtige Remote.
Wie ich habe die Rolls-Royster-Tasten nicht konfiguriert.
So wie ich das da sehe.
Das ist ein Litter.
Ach, sie baden gerade ihre Hände drin.
Ach, schau. Na gut, ok, alles gut.
Das findet alles bei mir im Mischpult statt, um mal deinen Gedanken dazu zu befreien.
Aha, ich denke, die Möglichkeiten sind...
Diese Zukunft.
Diese Metaebene, ne? Wir sind durch, wir sind müde. Wir bedanken uns fürs Zuhören, oder? Ich guck mal, ob ich hier noch den passenden Rausschmeißer am Start habe, den ich mich hier wieder fast verknackt habe. Ich probier's mal.
Wann kommt der mal in Stereo? Ja, morgen.
Ralf, vielen Dank für die kulturellen Beiträge. Tschüss, wir hören uns in zwei Wochen wieder.